all right uh so it's uh we're few
minutes late it's a little after nine um
I'm going to open uh proceedings of the
house Judiciary Committee and would you
please all uh rise and join me for
pledge of
allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for all
thank you uh I'm now going to um open
the hearing on uh
cacr uh 12 and I'm going to call on the
uh Prime sponsor representative Dan
Maguire thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire and I represent
the town of Epsom the uh constitutional
amendment in front of you cacr 12 is
meant to to address and and essentially
overturn the 30-year-old Claremont um
ruling um be before suing Court ruling
before I get into the details I want to
just tell you uh what I handed out to
you so um um attorney Greg sorg who's a
former member of your committee um asked
me to hand out a letter from him so I I
did that he's somebody who did um
considerable scholarship on this issue
who and he created a a compendium of a
book length comp compendium of Articles
and and other writings about Claremont
which I probably still have on my
computer somewhere if somebody wanted a
copy I could give it to you that's that
I also handed out a copy of the original
Claremont ruling which you can you know
it's it's very nicely written um even
though it's wrong in my opinion but it's
it's well written I mean you don't get
to be a Supreme Court Justice without
having skills in arguing so um if you
want to read it um there it is
so let me start by making some points
about the Constitution and then we'll
get into the details of this um so so
the the the bill itself the amendment
itself is is Trivial it it replaces the
word cherish with the word cherish and
the point of that is that the ruling in
front of view um turns in some sense it
it discusses and puts emphasis on the on
the word cherish and the meaning that it
had in
1784 and it sort of ascribes different
meaning on to that word than it has
today in in fact there is no different
meaning of the word then and now but in
any case um so the idea
is that moving the meaning from from
1784 to today
would sort of undermine the um the basis
of this ruling and I think if if a
subsequent case came before The Supreme
Court they would then have to reconsider
that case fresh and I think they would
have second thoughts so um let's talk
about the Constitution a little bit
first
so the Constitution is not something
that is subtle is is written so that
only experts only the court Etc can can
um interpret it the
Constitution is the people's document
all right until the
1960s it was only the people who created
it and so on no legislators or judges or
anything as such other than their role
as as ordinary citizens were involved in
in writing it or creating it and so on
right the way the Constitution was
created was in the early 1780s there was
a committee and the committee was
charged with with drafting a
constitution they took the Massachusetts
constitution written by John Adams as a
as a basis and then they made changes
and they sent those changes out to the
towns where the the um Constitution was
discussed and voted on by all the people
in their Town meetings and what happened
was they turned it down okay they read
it they didn't like it they turned it
down and they sent back a bunch of
proposed amendments to this committee so
the committee met again they used they
looked through all these amendments they
made changes to the Constitution
proposal they sent it back to the next
town meeting well the next set of town
meetings they read it they discussed it
and so on and it
failed they voted on it it failed and so
they sent back even more amendments to
this committee right so the committee
get another cycle they they changed the
Constitution and so on and the third
time was the charm right so so on the
third vote going back to the toies so my
my point is it's not
something hard to read or or cute or
something you know maybe my Amendment my
my bill here is too cute but but um but
the Constitution itself is something
that people ordinary people read it
understood it discussed it and voted on
it right and even today if we make this
amendment ordinary people will be voting
on it you know so um so that's my point
is is is we don't have to sort of you
know 200 years later try to look at
subtleties and this word and that word
and and that sort of thing right there's
plain language in the Constitution all
right so
um because of that let's suppose so what
what um The Claremont ruling said was
that the state has an obligation to fund
a quote adequate education for all uh
public school children in uh in New
Hampshire
and um I would think
that at the so what we are currently
spending on this on the adequate
education is roughly a billion dollars a
year now some of it is is sort of fake
representative Smith has a bill to deal
with the fake part but but you know you
could say it's it's it's 700 million
real and 300 million fake or something
like that but um but the point is it's a
huge expense right this is this is I
think the second biggest expense of the
state right we don't we now have
Medicaid but but at the time in
1784 this would have been they intended
to make this an expense of the state
this would have been by far the largest
sort of expense that they would have had
right and so they wouldn't have they
wouldn't have put it in article 83 of of
part two it would be right up front in
the beginning part of part two where you
have all the obligations of of the state
right all the all the things the state
are supposed to do this would have been
the major biggest thing that the state
would have to do and the legislators
would have to do and so on right it's
not an afterthought it's not something
to be put in to a halfway through a
sentence through a runon sentence that
includes literature and other stuff okay
so this is not how it would have been
written and it's not how people would
have understood all right um so let's
let's read the phrase in question um
here and I'll just so so the way the
ruling the the Supreme Court ruling is
it it focuses on two words the the first
being Duty so if you look at the bill
line
six um it shall be the duty of
legislators and magistrates in all
future periods of this government to
cherish uh the interest of literature
The Sciences all seminaries and public
schools to encourage public public and
private institutions rewards immunities
for the promotion of Agriculture Arts
Sciences Commerce trades manufacturers
Natural History etc etc so so the the
two words they focus on is Duty and
cherish right so duty means you have to
do something
right these two words in in reality have
no different meaning today than they did
then I can go into more of that if you
have questions about it but but the
question is is and they and they say the
the subtlety is well how do they get
around the fact that we're not sending
checks to authors and scientists and
seminaries right because whatever the
sentence does to Public Schools it does
the same thing for literature and
Science and seminaries right and it's
not just any seminaries it's all
seminaries right so I don't think we've
ever SE sent a check to any semary I'd
be very surprised if we had so um so so
the the ruling kind of tries to finesse
this that that somehow when we're
talking Public Schools cherish means
send a check but when we're talking
these other things it means something
else right it means furthering their
purpose or you know something V so it it
this is this is the one of the major
problems with this is that the plain
reading of the sentence is all of these
things are equivalent right and so and
should be treated equivalently by the
legislature um so let's talk about so
that so this doesn't mean what the
ruling says so let's talk about what it
does mean all right so what's the
purpose of part two article 83 so the
original part if you read part two
article 83 it essentially is two long
runon sense sentences right maybe three
so so one of them is this first sentence
about uh cherish the literature Sciences
seminaries public schools for the
purpose of Education right in
agriculture Arts science Commerce all
these things the second part of this
which was added later so that that was
the original part and then the the
following sentence was added a little
bit later which is no money should go to
uh schools or institutions of a
religious sector denomination and then
even later than that was the was the
final part which was about monopolies
right free and Fa Fair competition in
trades um should be protected Etc so if
you look at this as a whole what it's
telling you is these are the at the
front these are the good guys right the
the people who are helping education
right who are furthering
knowledge those are the people we should
be supporting right I mean this is
obvious right but it's true and the
people we should watch out for at at the
end here are the you know greedy
businessmen who are going to create
monopolies and steal your money etc etc
right so that's what this is about and
and if you look at the particular phrase
literature Sciences seminaries and
public schools the weird part about that
phrase is the word Public Schools right
literature science seminaries those
aren't part of government those are
external to government right um a and
all the rest of this agriculture
manufacturing you know trades those are
all external to government right but we
think of public schools as internal to
government so if you look at the last
page of my handout I want to suggest
that the real word that they should have
looked up in
1784 is the word public
school all right so this is from the
encyclopedia britanica right and it says
that if you went to England even today
and ask them what's a public school well
they'll say this is a place like Eaton
and Harrow and Etc right this is a like
Philips exiter it's a private school
okay that members of the public pay to
attend that's what a public school is
even today in England all right what do
they call what we call a public school
they call that a local school all right
so according to this that term using the
word public school to mean that that's
an 18th century
term all right and the people we're
talking about who wrote the Constitution
were very recently
British right so I think it's possible
at least that um the meaning here was
they meant things like Philip exiter
when they said Public Schools they
didn't mean Local Schools right because
when you when you make that that mental
substitution the whole paragraph makes a
lot of sense right the good guys who are
furthering you know we' we've finished
in earlier parts of the Constitution
talking about how government works its
obligations all that sort of stuff in
this one we're giving you advice about
gen externalities to government right
how do you deal with um people that you
find in in the society right and so um
we want you these are the good guys
right the the people who are spreading
knowledge including literature
scientists seminaries and private
schools all right those are all external
then then this whole par this whole
section is about external stuff right it
isn't
about what are we doing with local
schools what are we doing with you know
my school your school Etc that in town
right that's earlier right that's not
this so so that's my the basics of my
argument all right so let's assuming
that I've convinced
you that this doesn't say what the
Claremont rule says right but you think
um what's the harm right what's what's
the harm of the Claremont ruling right
we we certainly want to
support um I'll use the word local
school just just to be clear but we
certainly want to support our schools
right and um we've done it for I don't
know how many years certainly well
longer than I've been in the legislature
and and we've done it in a smart way way
we've done it with targeted Aid right
the way we support uh schools is we have
a formula that has characteristics of
the students in those schools and it has
characteristics of the area those
students uh come from so that we send a
lot more money to areas that are poorer
like Berlin for example and a lot less
money essentially zero to areas that are
wealthy like newcap
all right and we send also if you have a
lot of say immigrant children a lot of
English is a second language like
Manchester we send them extra money
because those are a little harder to
teach right so so we do it we do
targeted Aid and it's it's reasonable I
mean it's it makes sense right that's
the way to do it all
right but what the court has told us in
the most recent so so the con the um
um Claremont ruling was only the first
of multiple Court rulings the most
recent one is a ruling called conal that
came out last year and if you read the
conval ruling it it it's the logical
conclus I don't blame the judge for poor
ruling or something like that um I blame
these Supreme Court judges for you know
wanting a certain outcome and creating
it but but what the conval ruling
does is it is it if you read it it it's
a it's like budgeting right there's a
there's line after line well a teacher
costs this much and a nurse cost that
much and a you know building costs this
much and a superintendent is this and
that and there's there's all kinds of
calculations and it comes to a final
conclusion dividing by the number of
students and it says that that the
minimum that the state should be sending
because the state has to pay according
to Claremont for for all public for a
base basic public
education it says the minimum that must
be sent is I'm not sure I remember the
number but it's like
$7500 and
75560 right one cent you know some some
number that's the minimum that the
constitution requires well the
Constitution doesn't say you know have
any calculations or it doesn't say
anything like that
but and so everybody who likes sending
thinks that this is innocuous right
likes the state sending a Aid to Public
Schools they're thinking well now we're
sending
$4,100 this ruling says we have to send
$7,500 right schools are going to get an
extra
$3,400 great right and so and if if we
multiply $ 3400 times $ 160,000 students
that's over $500 million right right so
the state as a result of this ruling is
going to send five extra $500 million to
schools
but that in my mind is is a
misinterpretation of the ruling because
and and so and so you might be inclined
to vote against this because you want
that to happen right but if you read the
the conval ruling in particular the key
point of it is it's against targeted Aid
right the judge as part of his ruling
said I only care about per
head right I only care about the base
the
$4,100 all the rest of the money you're
sending more to Berlin and less to
Newcastle that's irrelevant all right
it's just the base That Matters to the
Constitution right it's like silly but
but
and so therefore what conal wants us to
do is set up a regime where the money we
send to
towns is only on the base right it's it
we could do that right we could send
$7,500 without spending an extra 500
million which we don't have right we
could
send it might be a little bit more than
we spend now but but the point is we
could send
$7,500 to every per head to every town
but guess what that's a stupid thing to
do right um what we're going to start
doing is sending money uh to Waterville
Valley and Newcastle and molten Boro and
all these places that don't need it
right and and we're going to we're going
to cut the the the funds that currently
go to Claremont and and uh
um uh Berlin and other places that
really need it the places that would
gain under such a regime are places like
Londoner and Bedford and Bo you know
they have a lot of kids they have a lot
of expensive homes right and we send
them now next to nothing right but we
could you know so so that's the
motivation for voting for this bill
right let the legislature decide what's
the appropriate amount to send to to
Local Schools right we're
not um we're never going to forget Local
Schools they're a subdivision of the
state right I mean it's not like if
without this we would never send any
money to to Local Schools it's
ridiculous right this is just um the
courts wanting a particular outcome and
you know trying to enforce it on us when
it when it doesn't make sense what we're
doing now makes sense
but what the The Logical conclusion of
the of the conval ruling does not and
and so
um so that's
the I'm I'm happy to answer questions
all right questions for this
witness wow seeing none so I I guess I
have all right here's what um first of
all I have to say I'm very sympathetic
to what you want to accomplish I mean I
you
know I think the Claremont decision was
the wrong decision and it was I very
much agree with with uh attorney
sorg's analysis but having said that why
it it seems to me and I I I I say this
very respectfully but it it seems to me
that the what you're doing is kind of a
cutesy yes way of why not if you want if
you you want to
say the the state should have
no if you want to say I I assume you
want to say one of two things one
perhaps you want to say the state should
have um uh no responsibility to fund it
should be a local uh decision to to
decide on funding of Education or or
maybe more
specifically that the legislature
decides how much money should be spent
on education and the courts can't review
that if that's what you want to say why
not just put why not just say that okay
so why don't I have one that crosses out
the word public and just writes the word
private right and leaves everything else
the same right that that would work um
or why don't I do a more detailed thing
we part of it
is the way I look at it is that the
problem here here is not our
constitution there's nothing wrong with
our constitution it's well written it's
it's historical it's nice right the
problem here is the Supreme
Court misinterpreting it all right so
therefore changing the Constitution in
my mind is sort of like accepting the
premise right that the constitution says
what they say it says therefore I have
to change it right it and as opposed to
this amendment doesn't change the
Constitution really but it makes the
point right you see what I mean so
there's nothing wrong with the
Constitution therefore why should we
have to change it okay so I agree with
you I mean if if you felt like amending
it and you thought it could pass with an
amendment the the problem is we've tried
that before you know years ago when I
was in the legislature the for the first
time we did that but we got hung up over
the details of the language right
somebody had their right the way they
wrote it the way this one wrote it the
way that one wrote it and and and we
could never get it done right and so
this
one that's my answer all right so it
doesn't change the problem isn't the
Constitution the problem is the court
so other
question any other uh yes representative
St I I wish I had some questions but
there's a lot of stuff here and um but
I'm just going to reflect a little bit
before I ask a
question I remember when the first
Claremont lawsuit was talked about
initiating and I was in the auditorium
in Claremont New Hampshire and I was one
of the few that stood up and opposed to
it and I think I said something what are
we citizens suing citizens over what the
other thought that came to mind is
Governor Lynch did not he ask for a
revision so that we could avoid um what
ensued after over the last 30 years um
get away from and recognize that the
cherish was aspirational and not a
financial mandate did you talk about
that a little bit um I can't say
specifically govern about Governor Lynch
I don't remember that that
detail um but yes I mean this is not the
first such such Constitutional Amendment
that's come before your committee and
and the legislature so there have been
attempts and I remember one very well my
first term was when uh Bill O'Brien was
speaker right we had a super Republican
majority right almost 3 to one and yet
we couldn't pass anything right so and
the problem was it got hung up on should
I say this or that or you know whatever
so so that's the problem you're going to
run into if you try to amend
things yes yes please so um looking at
the handouts and I got to reread them
but it appears as though um the
direction is take the constitution in
the context of language and culture
as it was then written as a as opposed
to looking back and revising meaning by
any changes of
constitution um or any changes in
culture excuse me yeah and and I think
from from my feeling that was what we
did at the very beginning we weren't
putting it in context um do I have this
right that that you're stressing the
context of uh language and culture at
the time absolutely yeah so that part
that's one thing the ruling itself talks
about by the way um the ruling uses a
1784 dictionary if anybody wanted to
look up a copy of such dictionary it
exists online and I could send links to
uh to the committee and and you could
look up your own set of words if you
wanted to you know
so yeah representative
Smith good morning first of all I have
to say that I always
enjoy listening to you doesn't mean I
agree with you
but sometimes I do I always enjoy
listening to you and it gives me another
perspective um uh sometimes we believe
that the literal interpretation of the
Constitution is what should guide us
sometimes we believe that that that is
not what should guide us and to me that
is the strength of the Constitution it
is very
elastic and it has by and large
survived for a few centuries recognizing
that
elasticity I do want to respond to my
colleague's question I was
chairman of the finance
committee a number of years ago
and I had always opposed a
constitutional amendment to try to get
the state out of honoring it's what I
believe is its obligation to pay for P
public education and because I'm an
American I use the American
interpretation of the
Republic um and most of my Democratic
colleagues agreed Governor Lynch
was sitting in the corner
office he very much wanted a
constitutional
amendment we worked very very hard to
try to come up with an amendment
that we could try to get through the
legislature we finally came up with Lang
langage that people could live with not
happily but could live
with and
I
asked my colleagues on the Democratic
side I said I have never asked for a
vote before and I will never ask for a
vote again but I am asking for one vote
will you give us one vote on this and
they agreed and I then went to the
speaker and to the uh Republican leader
and I
said one vote is all I could guarantee
and in fact
um uh if you wanted to try to amend this
you would not get support so please
don't be greedy please realize that you
can get something close to what you want
we could get something close to what we
want and could get that
through and I said it twice to the
majority leader or to whatever he was no
he wasn't the majority leader the
minority leader and I said would you
shake hands on this and he
agreed and we made the
motion and it
passed and the next thing that
happened is that he stood up to
propose another
amendment you can go back and check and
verify what I've told you and that is
why it was
shortterm partisan
greediness that interfered with us being
able to address an issue that all the
these years later is still with us and
it's a lesson that I think we should all
be reminded of I apologize for not
asking a question um Mr Mr
chair would you believe uh well no I
could do that but I'm not going to you
know because the truth I can laugh about
it but I'm not amused um it to me stands
as a testament to what happens when we
try well we try to to do more than we
should and
um so now that who I was one of those
people who now you know the story I
don't remember who used to say that who
used to say that Paul Harvey Paul Harvey
PA Harvey the story um and that is the
story and that is why I love listening
to you but I'm constantly reminded about
the fact that this is not a laughing
matter this is not not something to be
cute about this is the
Constitution that has by and large stood
Us in good stad and I can't wait to hear
the next bill that you bring to us well
thank you very much and I the compliment
goes the other way as well I mean I I I
am happy to hopefully be your friend and
and uh um I always like to listen to you
including this um this is very
informative um
and and you're right the the perfect is
the enemy of the good right I mean it's
that simple representative
Greece thank you Mr chair thank you
representative at first I thought this
was cockamamy but I appreciate your
explanation of this and it goes way back
uh to in time long before I be moved to
New Hampshire um but my question is
because the state mandates that children
attend school we have comp cul
attendance does that then not obligate
the state to provide financing for such
an Endeavor if you're going to mandate
it you got to pay for it yeah thank you
for the question I would
say in
general all parts of government are
essentially parts of the state we call
schools political subdivisions of the
state right towns are political
subdivisions of the state so the state
has set up a structure
where certain taxes are collected
locally and spent locally and other
taxes are collected globally and and
spent however they're spent and so you
know in some sense the state is
fulfilling that obligation it's just in
a way that um you know obviously this is
all a giant political question and we
change the formula every two years and
we you know change taxes every two years
and all that sort of stuff so so I would
say the state
is funding education but they're doing
it in a certain way that this particular
Supreme Court disagreed with right other
other
questions yes representative Wallace
thank you and thanks for taking my
question would it be a fair analysis um
to say that this is really not a a
cutesy move but in fact giving the New
Hampshire voters a position to reinforce
um their position and enforce the
Constitution by uh replacing the word
cherish and reminding everybody involved
that the power that we drive derive from
our citizens are who's uh paying the
bill here and that's really needs to be
considered in this would you agree with
that yeah I um I'm going to recruit you
for the campaign to get this passed if
it ever gets on the ballot that's a very
nice way of putting um I don't know if
you have other pink cards but I know
we're we're running out of time so maybe
uh should any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much you I'm next going to call
on Representative Keith Ammon
please good morning to the committee and
Mr chairman um for the record my name is
Representative Keith Ammon and I
represent Hillsboro District 42 Town's
uh new B and Mount Vernon line bro I'm
going to keep my comments extremely
brief there's another Constitutional
Amendment down the hall that I'm also a
co-sponsor on I'd like to get to that
one um i' just like to make a singular
point and that has to do with um the
potential for The Logical conclusion of
the Claremont decisions one and two and
the conil
decisions as the state uh takes a larger
and larger role in paying for local
education it has the potential to
undermine local control if we if we plot
out the dots on the graph it seems that
the the trend is for the state to pick
up a larger and larger portion of of
funding of our local
education um and that's the point I'd
like to make here that um for 200
years that article 83 was interpreted a
certain way and within the last few
decades that has
changed and now uh there's a movement
and there's a a fairly large political
movement because of the burden of our
property taxes uh for the state you know
the promise is if the state pays more
our our local property taxes will go
down um that that may be a du a dubious
promise but if the trend continues and
the state picks up a larger portion um
it's how the world works the who who
writes the check the rules right that's
sort of a an axiom that is true most of
the time um and
so unless we uh consider carefully the
legislature's role in um responding to
Court decisions uh we may just be
accumulating more power for ourselves at
the state legislature level and taking
power away from local school boards and
their decisions so I just that that's
the one point that I'd like to make
representative Maguire is a hard act to
follow so I'm not even going to try um
one one ancillary
consideration is that our education
Freedom account
system uh will have more
money uh if the state pays a larger
portion so
indirectly uh we could be funding our
education Freedom accounts to a higher
level and maybe that's something that
hasn't been considered so um I would
like to get down the hall so I'll I'll
briefly take
questions representative
Smith thank you so much for being
willing to be here and understand you
pulled in a lot of directions um are you
suggesting that we are a local control
State isn't it true that the local
jurisdictions in this state only have
the power that is given to them by the
state
thank you for the question so we are a
dyan's rule state as you're I'm sure
you're aware um but the cultural
traditions of our state we we defer to
local control whenever possible so there
there so technically yes the the local
towns can do have to do whatever we tell
them to do but
traditionally for a very long time we we
defer to local control because we
understand decision- making closer to
where the decisions are made has a
better outcome so I would say
technically correct but traditionally
it's it's a little different thank you
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much thank you right
I don't have any other pink cards I've
already had two pink cards signed up on
this is there anyone else who wishes to
be heard on U
cic2 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
cac12
and we've got three minutes before the
my the correct time is 942 so we will we
have three minutes before we open the
hearing on
it's
is this
yours
like if you read it clearly
right
so
now Beyond 9:45 I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill uh
1169 um I don't see any of the named
sponsors so I'm going to recognize
representative Alexander to introduce
the Bill thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Joe Alexander I represent the town of
gown Hills bro District 29 I'm here to
introduce HB
1169 I'm not a sponsor of but with that
I won't take questions thank you thank
you um do we have
um anyone here who wishes to be I have a
pink card um Miss
miky no do
you sure please come up
y good morning chairman and and the to
the committee as well um my name is Anie
Malachi I am the executive director of
the commission for human rights um and
the content of
1169 um in essence what it's doing is
creating a private right of action for
discrimination based on uh someone's
hair and so the first first first
element for me is the concern about the
private right of action so what that is
effectively doing is removing the
commission from the process although it
is putting the language the
anti-discrimination language into the
commission's definitions it is removing
the opportunity for the commission to
provide um Justice if you will or to to
stop us from being able to take a charge
based on uh on that uh basis it does
allow I believe in terms of education
for us to do that however what I could
potentially see here is a quite a bit of
confusion um people do contact us uh to
ask questions for technical assistance
based on what the anti-discrimination
law contains at this point and so if
this definition is included in the law
then I could foresee them calling us for
questions uh to to get guidance and an
assistance of course we don't provide
legal advice but we would not have the
wherewithal to provide any training or
assistance relative to anything else in
the statute other than education
possibly um the next part for for the
commission is the commission is already
uh able to take charges in this area we
have jurisdiction over this area and uh
specifically under ra it could be taken
under race it could be taken under
gender uh it could be taken under sexual
orientation it could be taken under age
it could be taken Under Disability uh
and uh national origin and actually
actually also religion and so if the
language is put in the statute but
removed and only for um
employment then the protection that
other people may have has been removed
and it's not this protection that we
already have in the statute is for all
people so anyone any religion
not based on race specifically but any
hairstyle whether it's beards because
that's not mentioned as well some
individuals may have uh long beards
based on their religion or it could be
their uh national origin um siks for
example would wear a turban so would
would we take it under national origin
or would we take that under religion so
there's um the other part too is there's
a lot that's not covered with this and
uh for us at the commission we just want
to make sure that everyone in the state
of New Hampshire who may feel like
they've been discriminated against can
find themselves in the law and not have
a carve out for one group and not allow
another group which would be
discriminatory on its face so I am w i
welcome any questions that you might
have questions for this witness
representative Perez I apologize I did
not hear where you were from and I
apologize no worries the uh human the
Human Rights Commission thank you other
qu yes representative Alexander um thank
you Mr chair and just so thank you Miss
Malachi for being here just to make this
clear you believe that if we pass this
bill it will actually undermine the
rights of those that it's actually
trying to help correct yes uh it would
not only remove the jurisdiction
specifically in employment from the
commission people would have to go to
court versus coming to us but it would
it it leaves out other individuals and
other types of hair which could make
people not file a charge should they be
discriminated against thank you right
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much thank you all
um next I'm going to call on uh
representative wheeler
please thank you representative Lynn
chairman Lynn members of the committee
ranking member Smith I had to grab two
witnesses in Manchester who are coming
right now they're parking my car for me
so I appreciate representative Alexander
You introducing the bill for me and I
apologize for my tardiness um I did not
was not reached out by that commission
and did not hear where she was from uh
but would be happy to work with her on
an amendment to make this bill work I
think that the crown Act is an important
piece of legislation it has been passed
in over 22 States because people
recognize that this is an issue that
people are facing in our communities
people who have different types of hair
than uh we normally like to see and uh I
know this because I faced it myself uh I
worked at a restaurant in petero for a
long time about two is years and uh my
mother worked there as well and in my
final two weeks of working there uh my
mother had been talked to a number of
times by the manager nice guy decent guy
not a great manager he talked to her a
couple of times uh about my hair whether
or not I would be able to do it and I it
just to be clear my hair was uh a little
different than it was right now less
long um uh my hair is well kept I like
to think my hair is well kept now was
then I always kept it up kept it
straight wasn't touching it um and I had
friends that worked there friends of
mine that worked there that had that uh
that flop that some some of our boys
some of your sons might have it uh see
sort of Representative Kenny right there
he kind of I'm sure he understands what
I'm talking about although yours is
jelled up um but they were you know
touching their hair the whole time and
and that wasn't a problem for for the
manager or the staff but for some reason
my hair which was put up was and and my
mom was asked uh three or four times
whether or not I'd be able to do
something with my hair meaning cut it
and she told them off and as a result
she on I think it was like a Thursday
that that week was told to go home early
and then uh I was brought into the back
office at the end of my shift and told
that I didn't have enough spunk anymore
and uh anyone who has worked a service
job knows that after two years of
working that job uh you might not be as
enthusiastic but you're still do I I was
I I considered myself a good worker and
I think the other people there did
as well I don't think that was the
reason for it and my manager who fired
me told me something that I will never
forget um it was uh the most one of the
most condescending things that's ever
been told to me he said Jonah you're
great you're made for the White House
not the waterhous and uh I just you know
I think he was putting in an
uncomfortable situation where he was
told that he had to get rid of me and so
he was trying to do that as best he
could but but this is is something that
a lot of people go through in our state
and I I spoke to a lot of people about
this I have two people like I said
they're parking my car right now who are
coming one of them a loctician who does
my hair and the other uh someone who has
a lot of personal stories who they who
can relay some of the stories of the
people in Manchester and and other
places here in our state that are facing
this they're facing it in school they're
facing it at work and and and this is an
issue which needs to be addressed so as
I'm open to working with the committee
in whatever way possible and I know that
representative Linda Harriet goth who
would have love to be here right now but
is working very hard uh on a on a
personal family stuff and and other
legislative business that has to do with
criminal justice is going to have a
number of people from NASA people who do
hair salon work and other folks who have
personal stories to to send their
letters to the committee throughout the
process of this week so I would just
hope that uh there would be some way if
there is some uh language concern here
although I didn't necessarily see that
in my read of the bill although freshman
so you know give me space to to make
mistakes on that end uh I would be happy
to work to address those concerns in
whatever way the committee sees fit and
I'm happy to answer any questions
questions uh representative
katat thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative wheeler for coming in
and introducing this bill and I'm so
sorry that these things happen to
you did you know that the Human Rights
Commission was available when this
happened to you and if so did you file a
complaint with them when this happened
no I don't think that uh uh I don't
think there's a
good I wasn't aware that that that they
were available and I I didn't know that
there was a recourse to to be able to
get this done I I was told that um there
was no recourse for me to address that
because there was no uh place in law for
for me in the Discrimination law to get
that done if I wasn't aware of the Human
Rights Commission yes follow up yes
thank you
um so with that in mind and the fact
that we're told from the director of The
Human Rights Commission that this is C
covered under current statute do you
think
that the issue may be more of an
educational issue or maybe people need
to be made aware
that this law does exist and that there
are protections against these things
because if this is happening on a
regular basis and it's it it is included
in law broadly to not not be allowed
then it seems as if we need to get the
word out there and the message out there
to stop it from happening well
absolutely I mean I I I still think it
would be a good thing to to carve it out
and make it specific um might be my
position on that but I think you know
whatever happens it would be a good
thing to get education out there about
the law as it currently stands and what
recourse people can take on this thank
you other questions for this we yes
representative Stapleton please just to
be clear are you opposed to this bill as
written and saying it needs an amendment
for you to support it no I mean I I
would have to uh go back and see the
testimony of the humans right Human
Rights Commission um but uh I I I worked
decently hard on on this language um and
I I confident in it um but I would have
to look at the testimony of the Human
Rights Commission and see what they said
and and see what amendments could be
made from from what their perspective
was on the bill thank you other
questions for this witness you know I oh
I'm sorry yes representative Landon
please thank you for taking my question
would this also include um
uh coloring any coloring of the hair um
with this you
know this spill include anything about
that well I believe the exact list uh
protective hairstyles meaning hairstyles
hair type braids locks tight coils curls
cornrow band knots afro afro twists and
head wraps um I'm not sure if hair color
would be under hair type um but I feel
like that could be broadly defined
other yes representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my
question is this bill making it very
race specific and let me explain why I
asked that I'm a product of the 60s
everybody was judged by their hair if
you had hair you were a hippie you know
people were judged by their hair no
matter what their
ethnicity is this meant specifically for
people of
color and if it is I think we're leaving
out another whole group that has
discrimination perhaps against them
because of their hair whether it be I
don't know I keep thinking back to the
60s but um is it meant
specifically for people of color no I I
think that you know hairstyles or hair
types is broadly defined to uh any race
whatsoever I think it's just talking
about natural hairstyles you know so you
can't I can't discriminate you against
you if you have a a floppy hair or I
can't discriminate you against against
you if if you have uh uh braids or locks
or something along those lines and I
think the concern is right now that um
despite there being a broad def
definition of this in law that people
with braids locks sort of Afro style
types hair which you know not are not
always African people um that they're
being discriminated against uh in the
workplace and at school and other places
so I think that's why when hair styles
and hair types after that is uh laid out
in the bill on line 10 it goes through
braids locks tight corals Etc and I see
how that could be misconstrued as people
of color but I think it is sort of
broadly defined just uh humans in
general absolutely other questions for
this Witness yes representative Manos
please thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question one of the um uh
questions that the director of The Human
Rights Commission raised is facial hair
and beards and I just wondered if you um
had any perspective of on that in terms
of your
bill
um
and facial hair and beards as in
including facial hair and beards or just
discrimination
discrimination um based on the fact that
men um have facial hair or beards for
examp she used the example of a seik um
or for example an orthodox Jew other
situations where discrimination could
occur based on facial hair or beards I
think that that would be an appropriate
Amendment for the legislation I think
you know facial hair and beards
sometimes are you know as you just laid
out in some cases religious and and you
know spiritual in nature and so I think
it would be good to have that in the
bill
absolutely yes representative for thank
you I'm sorry thanks for taking my
question there are certain circumstances
where um for reasons of um hygiene or
reasons of um for medical reasons or
because of um sterilization and
cleanliness that hair can become an
issue
um I became a nurse in the 60s you could
not have your hair
below your fa line because you could
does this exempt those places from being
able to um say well you cannot have that
particular style without perhaps
covering it or doing this or that for
those particular types places I'm not
trying to be hard to get along but I I
see I see situations where um having to
cover your is this going to stop people
from
saying you're in an environment where we
need your head covered hair covered and
your facial hair covered in this
environment is this going to mean that
businesses or institutions cannot say
that that's a concern no I don't I don't
I don't think so I appreciate that
concern and I I I think that there are
places in which it's simply the policy
of the place and not discrimination you
know this applies to everybody and for
you know safety standards for um like
you said sanitation cleanliness
standards whether it's a a laboratory or
or something along those lines you're
working with hazardous material or
something like that you know there there
are
uh concessions that you as an individual
need to make to be able to work at those
places and and you know whether that's a
Time constraint or you have to change
your hair or what whatever that might be
those concessions are agreed to at the
point of um employment exactly so I I
would that that I think it it doesn't
cover that and I think that's uh that's
clear in the
bill other questions for this witness
representative Stapleton yeah thank you
for taking my question let's go back to
the restaurant where you were
working did you have to wear a uniform a
cap were you in kitchen or serving uh
what what was the environment like there
brought this on well I I mean we did
have to wear black so that's technically
a uniform we had to wear black shirt and
black pants um but we weren't forced to
wear a cap as I said there were other
people with uh longer hair much more
greasier than mine much much uh more in
their face than than mine was that uh
did not also have to wear cap and we're
not we're not talked to in any way uh
whatsoever I spoke to them about this um
I was a a bus boy and and a food Runner
um so I was in the front of the house
sort of just just with people and and
things like that
um
yes were were these other people with
longer or variant sty styles of hair uh
approached and talk talked to um as you
were
no thank you
other questions for yes representative
trip thank you for taking my question uh
I was just
wondering uh when you were
hired uh did you have long hair like you
had when you were
dismissed well hair grows so I I didn't
have exactly the long as long hair as as
uh as I did but it was long it was long
you know follow so the the the reason I
asked that question is I was just
wondering uh they did not make uh your
hair a condition of employment did they
no okay and and it was clear that I had
hair that you know would have grown and
you it was uh an off afro a dreaded afro
I don't know what it necessarily would
have been but it was clear that it would
have been you know if it was an issue at
the time it would have been an issue
that could have been a condition of
employment
well thank you for answering my question
thank you other questions for this
witness so I guess I do have a just one
or two questions uh representative wheer
um I'm the you have in the the bill uses
in quotes the term protective hairstyles
and I'm wondering if I I'm not sure that
I understand what that mean in other
words is the is
that should I understand that to mean
that the the hairstyles are protective
in the sense that because of the texture
of uh certain individuals here they need
to they need
to use these other things like uh braids
locks tight Co tight coils or curls
because of the texture I'm not sure I
understand what the term protective uh
hairstyles means I think I think you do
I think you've got it right um as I see
here in line 16 protective hairstyles
means hairstyles are hair type including
braids locks tight coils curls cornrows
Bantu BRS afro twists and head wrap I
think that that um I think you've got it
right in that protective hairstyles
means uh a hairstyle that is protective
of like you said the hair but there also
is a loctician here who would be able to
better answer that question than I think
any of us so
absolutely okay okay all right
um okay uh other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mr chairman I and I just I really
appreciate this this is a an important
conversation that needs to be had you
know I think that as I laid out in my
testimony that this is something that
does happen here in New Hampshire
there's a parallel Bill to this in the
Senate you know we see some of our bills
get copied by the Senate a number of
times sure but um I'm hoping through the
process of working here in the committee
I'd be happy to run down to OS at any
time before the executive session and
get an amendment that works for this
bill because uh you know the crown act I
think is an important piece of
legislation to pass here in the
Hampshire so thank you for your time Mr
chairman thank you thank you uh next I'm
going to call on uh Grace
uh krei if I pardon K kand I'm sorry
sorry yeah
please all right so thank you committee
for taking my testimony today for the
record my name is Grace kand I am the
program coordinator with the American
friends service committee um but I'm
also here today just as a resident um
and a citizen of New Hampshire um a
young woman who has grown up here who
has went to school here um and certainly
has worked here for the majority of my
life and so I here in support of HB 1169
um and urge the committee to P to ought
to pass it um so I wanted to share a
quick story with you all um I had the
pleasure of going to high school right
here in conquer right up the road at
Bishop Brady High School and I was the
one of the only students of color um in
my 400 plus uh school and one of the
things that I I dealt with almost on the
daily if not weekly um was uh getting
reprimanded for the state of my hair and
I've had all sorts of hairstyles as you
can see my hair is currently locked um
and but I've had braids I've had
cornrows I've worn my hair in wraps all
sorts of things um and I wanted to also
address um the chairman your question
about protective hairstyles um
absolutely because of the texture of our
hair um I often tell people that this is
what my hair naturally wants to do uh I
spend a lot of time straightening my
hair trying in very many ways actually
make it look like many of y'all hair um
because that's what my peers look like
that was what was most acceptable um
when I was growing up and I certainly
didn't want to stand out and I took me a
long time to learn how to take care of
my hair um but while I was doing that it
was not only a matter of trying to keep
my hair neat and healthy it was also in
order to ensure that I wouldn't
constantly be getting in trouble for my
hair so I went to a school with young
people um who would go on vacation you
know with their families during spring
break uh during summer break and would
come back with very similar hairstyles
to me um they would come back with
cornrow they would come back with braids
with beads in their hair and they would
get very much applauded they would get
you know praised for that hair um but
when I would sport the same hair I would
get a lot of scrutiny I would get
penalized I would be asked to change it
I would be and it honestly it might not
seem like a big deal especially if
you're not used to having to put your
hair like put so much attention to your
hair um but it absolutely impacted my
quality of studies it impacted my
comfort my ability to feel as if I
belonged in my school it absolutely
impacted uh my ability to focus on what
was important and I think that's exactly
what this bill is about it's making it's
sending a message to New Hampshire res
presidents to sending a message that
says very clearly that we don't Brook
discrimination when it comes to
hairstyles and I certainly have heard
through testimony from um um
representative wheeler um and from the
the committee that this might not be
needed and I think that that's wonderful
if the fact is that the New Hampshire
statutes and law already cover um
non-discrimination for hairstyles based
on the type of hairstyles then I think
absolutely that needs to become known
because I work with young people um and
they still undergo the same issues and I
live in Manchester I'm a Manchester
resident and if some of you don't know
Manchester has some of has one of the
most diverse School populations um in
the state and so I think it is really
important to send a message um that
would imp because this one impacts young
people it impacts people and residents
of this great state to make it known and
make it clear that yes absolutely their
are policies and rules in terms of how a
hair should be kept in order to perform
certain job duties but I think the
reality is again when you have hair that
looks like mine you spend a lot of time
justifying the state of your hair the
look of your hair and that does directly
impact your productivity your focus and
as well as your sense that you do in
fact belong in the state even if you
don't look like every other person um
especially those who are uh penalizing
you for that hair so I'm happy to take
any questions happy to take any
Reflections um and that is that is it
for me
me question uh yes representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair uh I'm very
sorry that you or anybody else ever has
any hassle because it definitely not
right my question is like when you were
in
conod who gave you the problem students
or the administration oh no my my peers
would always compliment me and and ask
me like oh Grace you know what did you
do to your hair this time it was
honestly primarily the administrators
and
teachers okay thank you I will say it
should never have happened thank you I
appreciate that other questions for this
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman uh
next all
right oh I'm sorry yeah all all right so
um uh representative wheeler I
understand are the the two individuals
sitting next to you people who wish to
testify if you wish to be if you wish to
be heard I don't have any other
cards oh oh it's they they use the blue
sheet they're new to the system oh
okay that that that's great yeah no no
problem uh you know what um yeah as long
as that's fine you sure if you want to
why don't you come on up sir please or
either either one that's fine
good morning morning hi hi good morning
my name is Shaquanda Allen um I am owner
and hair stylist of roots natural hair
shop located in
Manchester uh I did write something so
let me just open this real quick because
I get off tracked a little bit
uh um today I'm in the support of the
crown act um I open my shop to support
uh people of color or people that wear
their natural hair and to help them
guide them in a healthy hair Journey as
well as give them protective styles for
their jobs and Lifestyles um as a hair
stylist a natural hair stylist um my job
is to teach everyone how to maintain and
honor their natural curls and that's
from all textures of curls not just
ethnic people cuz I have a lot of white
clients that wear their hair straight
but don't use any chemicals or um get
their hair cut and they like braids and
wash and gos and pullbacks and
trims um I open my shop specifically
just to help people of natural hair
curls
to basically be happy in their workplace
or around on the street on their natural
curls so for example I have a lot of
clients that work in the nursing field
that have to pull their hair up and
that's my job to help them with a
protective style to pull their hair up
so that their uh bosses administrators
don't complain about oh your hair is too
long or it's in the way and things like
that I have a lot of construction um
client construction officers I mean no
construction workers that wear their
hair and protect the style so that they
can put their helmets on their head or
getting to a small space like
electricians electricians and things
like that um I also work with army vets
and people of color that's in the army
that have to pull their hair back but
they don't have time in the morning to
make a ponytail as tight as they can so
they use a protective cell to a leave
time for that scent and having me there
to help them with that allows to make
sure that they follow the rules of
uniform so when they put their helmets
on or their their army hats on it fits
properly it's not going to fall off it
is not causing any problems so that they
won't have to get called out of uh their
hair issues um I also work with a lot of
uh teachers uh scuba divers and things
like that and having the protective
hairstyles help all these workers and
people of natural hair wearing
techniques feel comfortable and making
sure that they're not breaking any rules
it's also allowing me to show the
workforce and people around that don't
understand that our hair is not not M
maintainable it's you haven't seen it m
maintain or not maintained before so
we're educating the world on today my
hair is messed up so you can see it's
messed up but tomorrow when I come in
after I came from Roots natural hair
shop it's been maintained so you can see
the difference so now when someone comes
in not maintain we have the we have the
right to say something because we know
it's not maintain maintain unlike
someone that comes in with the afro
somebody will automatically say oh this
is not maintained but actually this
person went to The Hair Shop Roots
natural hair shop by the way to get it
washed cut and trimmed and poofed out
properly so that it's not shedding all
over the table it's not out of order of
a uniform and it looks presentable all
the way around um I love my job I help a
lot of people feel confident in who they
are and and me having my shop and
helping them allows them to come to work
places like this place here and
especially like for Jonah he's one of my
clients where when he first started he
wasn't comfortable wearing his locks
until I showed him look this is a nice
protective style where it looks
professional so when you sit up here and
present your bills and stuff you feel as
powerful as you do with your hair so
that our Outsiders don't say oh well
your dread sticking up this way and it
looks this way is it clean or anything
yes it's cleaned we wash every time he
comes and it's uh combed well not Combs
with palm roads and put back so that he
looks professional at all times um also
my king who also is working his way up
here I helped show designs and stuff
like that so it's pulled back and looks
professional and not hanging all over
the face and things like that um as a
hair stylist I love my job I love that
people smile when they're done um and
allowing myself to do that for people
allows them to come to work and feel
happy and do their job properly and
effectively not feel like they're
getting um discriminated against um I'm
happy to answer any questions um and yes
all right questions for this way
representative gon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for your testimony what is
the name of your shop and where is it
located um it's Roots natural hair shop
roots with the Z and it's located in
Manchester other questions for this
witness representative Staples yeah
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for giving us the detail of
what your shop does myself being
familiar with um railroad Factory um and
Military environments safety is a big
issue and concern you've addressed that
yes um because if you go into a machine
shop and your your hair is like you were
R for this morning that would be a
safety right issue and violation for
yourself In Harm's Way um as well as
problematic for the the business or or
the
organization um but it sounds like you
you really are tuned into that safety
and compliance with those particular
environments yes I'm actually as the day
goes I'm learning more ways to fit um
the workforce uh requirements because
just like a electrician someone that has
to get into a small compact space they
can't have their hair down or loose
because of it can get caught on
something or things like that and it's a
health hazard for them to get dust and
insulation in their hair so a lot of my
clients we pull it back which is a
protective style like cornrows or a
barrel twist to keep it pulled back so
that these things don't get in the way
and they they're not getting unhealthy
either so thank you you're welcome other
representative tur yeah thanks
um uh at the outset I don't know if you
are in the room but the the question
came up from our Human Rights Commission
about whether this is is actually
covered and I guess I asked this
question because it sounds like from the
other testimony we had you may come
across lots of people who have
experienced this type of of uh workplace
or School push back um curious if you
the the idea of a Human Rights
Commission or or these sort of behaviors
being subject to the human rights
commission's purview had ever had ever
come up and and if um if that is is an
opportunity if not to to spread that
that message that was Wonder well I have
had um some of the clients come to me
and say you know well mostly from the
high schoolers that um you know they
can't play the sport because their hair
is pulled down a certain way and I know
that's coming from the higher ups and
not just the the kids yourself um I
never really had adults come to me and
say the human rights services are
somebody in human services um complain
and it's been a while too because uh
every day is changing so um but uh we I
think that just comes from us now having
certain bills passed and allowing things
to like such as myself and natural hair
styles I help pass uh House Bill 82 into
law so that I could perform uh hair
service to these people so that you know
these questions won't come up in the
human rights um
Department I don't know if I answer that
correctly but thank you representative
MOS thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking
good morning um I wanted to ask you you
were using the term protective hairstyle
yes and I I'm not familiar with that and
what it means so I was just wondering if
you could explain that okay a protective
hairstyle is a style that is performed
on someone that wear their hair in a
natural state that where you don't have
to touch it and it's uh put away so such
as um example as my King's hair here
it's that's a protective stuff from him
not keeping it down we don't have to
retwisted every day he doesn't have to
wash it um brazer is another protective
style where it's pulled back and and
pushed away for a while so you're not
putting any heat you're not putting the
comb through it you're not well you do
put products but not as much um just to
give your hair a break and leave it
alone so for someone like yourself to
have your hair out today your protective
style I would choose as a pullback
ponytail where we pull it back put in a
bun and you'll leave your hair like that
for like a week or so just so that
you're not combing putting stress on
your scalp or your your hair shaft so
that it's not shedding all over the
place and becoming a
problem you're welcome other questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
guys I appreciate everything have a good
day all right you too thank
you um can I turn this on no no sorry uh
Anthony um arst Harris Harris Mr Harris
please come on
up
hello um how are you kings and queens
doing on this beautiful morning uh my
name is Anthony Harris um I am the
founder and executive director of Boss
initiative the next chapter boss has an
acronym beating the odds and striving
for Success where we help previously
incarcerated individuals successfully
walk the path from prison to
Prosperity um I'm here today um in
support of the crown act um I've
throughout my life I've grew up between
New York and Florida and I've always had
locks um this is this is
my fourth set of locks throughout my
lifetime I'm couple of times I was
forced to cut them because the back when
I was uh when I first started the
workforce um I'll be 42 in May um I know
I don't look it I know I don't look
it and um so I came up um when I'm my
first job was a Denny in Florida and I
was
16 and um I had locks and the guy he
said I love my personality he thinks I
fit the position very well um I just
have to cut my hair in order to get the
job
um eventually I was forced to I was uh I
was forced to because if I didn't get
the job then uh I would get locked up so
I eventually had to cut my hair and
um it devastated me I was I was I was
pretty mad about it I end up quitting
the job two weeks later which made it
which made me even more upset but
growing up these are the things that
that um me and people like me had to
face you know I mean I remember reading
applications where it says if you have
cornrows this these These are hairstyles
that are prohibited but like uh my Queen
was saying earlier these are the
protective styles that we need for our
hair to grow and be healthy you know and
um so without being able to do that the
only options we have is what we call a
Caesar cut a low cut fade or blow out
you know and um that's not the look that
we all want to have and that's not a
look that that we all feel confident
with you know so um I I do see um a lot
of change since I was 16 but I feel like
we still we still got some ways to go
and um with this Crown act being passed
um that we're we're one more step
towards uh
uh the true Solutions and and and and
freedoms that that humans us as humans
should have period where everyone is is
um everyone is is is is is considered
and and being thought of um in the
process of our
hair and so um that that's my time today
if there's any questions I'll be more
than happy to answer representative
Perez thank you thank you for taking my
question I think it's absolutely
fabulous that there is an opportunity to
be able to do what you need to do for
your comfort for your hair for your
health of your hair I am sure that or I
guess that it's probably not
affordable for the majority of young
people and I just wonder do you
feel I I see this more protecting the
people who can't don't have the
opportunity to do what you all are doing
see it more as protecting the young
people who may be of color or
whatever who can't afford to go and do
what they need to do exactly to maintain
the health of their own hair what are
your thoughts on
that um yeah there's there's there's
quite a few people who um you know
parents either are absent or um just
can't afford
to to to to pay for the protective
styles um we we see it more and more
every day me and my queen like she's
phenomenal she she she does a lot of
um uh um I put this on the record but
you know when when when some when we see
certain certain ones um that we know
they need it and they can't afford it we
uh we figure something out you know we
we we we make it happen because it's
it's it's not the child's fault you know
um and sometimes it's not even the
parents fault they only can afford what
they can afford you know so um we uh or
sometimes we still do the uh my queen
loves
bartering and so you know we do a
service for a service you know um so we
we do whatever we can to help those who
can't afford it to afford it you know um
and sometimes we just Do It free you
know and um just to look out for for the
kids and some adults some adults
actually call and access also like you
know I would love this style but I just
don't have the money for it right now
but my hair is like this and so my queen
of talk to him and they'll figure
something out um I do wish we were able
and and had some type of program
available that that to where um we'll be
able to help more especially of our
youth um we're out of Manchester so I I
wish there was something where we were
able to um to to have some type of
program where we could bring the kids in
and and they'll be able to get their
hair um you know washed cleaned and and
um done up in in some sort of protective
style you know um without the cost
assist right I mean right now with with
the demand um we we wouldn't be able to
to uh um not say we wouldn't be able to
pay our bills but we wouldn't have the
time cuz it's only my queen I don't do
hair and so uh it's only my queen as The
Stylist so and these protective styles
some of these styles are anywhere from 2
to 10 hours um of sit time so we
wouldn't be able to do so many because
we only we're we're Limited in um in
Staffing and resources
but I would definitely love um if there
was something there representative
trip chair thank you for taking my
question uh you like a couple of the
other people that have testified have
have used the the phrase Crown act does
that mean
something yes so the um we've been
fighting for this around the United
States as the bipar community for some
years now and so the original the
original um bill that's what we called
it the crown act the crown of your head
um and so uh instead of I think this is
11 HB 1169 is the bill um we just we
just can we we just always put it
together with the crown act it's it's a
um another form of the crown act in the
state of New Hampshire follow up uh so I
imagine that the crown Act is a is a act
that is was enacted in another state yes
so there's there's uh we still got a
couple of states for fighting yeah two
other states 22 22 other states I'm
sorry so we still have we we we uh we
still have some um um some ground to
cover and and hopefully uh after today
New Hampshire be uh be on that list with
the uh um 2022 other states that already
passed this Bill thank you thank you
uh representative Stapleton thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
we appreciate your testimony today
because it uh informs us of things that
we didn't know and it's quite helpful
and uh I appreciate you're doing that
one question I had you mentioned your
experience in Florida at age 16 what was
that job I missed that oh Denny's it was
a Denny's restaurant okay thank you and
there was another um there's another
young man I can't remember his name but
it was big on the news um he was
wrestling and he was wrestling um one of
his white uh peers um in a tournament
and he was beating this guy and then the
referee stood him up and brought him to
the sideline and said he had to cut his
locks off cuz they were giving him some
type of advantage and he had to cut his
locks off where he forfeits the match
and this was a championship this was a
high school championship match and
eventually um you can you can watch this
video he's crying the whole time but he
cuts his locks because I mean he's
worked his behind off to get to this
level and to this stage at a state
championship wrestling match and he had
to cut his his his locks off on the side
on the sideline U while everybody's
watching him on the stadium um and he go
he went on to win to win the match but
um in my
opinion uh uh he
lost um because in the end he had to he
he he had to cut his strength off his
hair you know um and we just don't feel
like if that was anybody outside of the
bipac community that that would have
happened and so this bill is like so
important this is real important to us
cuz I love my hair like with a passion
and and and my queen takes care care of
my hair so um and I I can't see myself
without locks you know um I'm actually
running to be a State Rep this year and
I couldn't I I couldn't imagine them
telling me in order to be a State Rep I
would have to cut my locks off so in
order for me to help my my constituents
and my and and and and and my people and
my state I would have to cut my locks
off that just is is um I feel it's
inhumane um um to to to discrimin
discriminate against someone for the
style and texture of their hair and
we're born like this it's not like we
have a choice you know it's not like we
have a choice this is how our hair this
is how our hair is from um from the time
we're born so um I would greatly
appreciate if if all the representatives
here I thank you for your time and I
appreciate if you push this bill through
qu other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir all
right have a beautiful day God bless you
thanks uh I don't have any other uh Pink
cards on this bill is there anyone else
uh here who wishes to be heard on House
Bill
1169 oh ah yes so um the record should
reflect that there have been uh 72
people have signed up in support of this
bill and four opposed um
and with that I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1169 and open the hearing on House Bill
1220 and
um I'm going to rep recognize
representative Ben Ming uh as the prime
sponsor
and representative M can I just at can
you just fill out a card at some
point don't worry don't worry about you
can just do it after your yes sure thank
you
chairman um for the record my name is
Ben Ming I'm a state representative for
the town of Hollis and I'm here to
introduce hb1 1220 dfn this bill would
remove the requirement for municipal
clerks to requ request race and An
ancestry information of couples wishing
to be married in New
Hampshire uh before we get into the
details I'd like to lay out some of the
context for how this bill came into
being sponsors of this bill were
contacted by assistant AG Shan lock um
who is here and will speak in Greater
detail about the history he indicated to
us that in 2020 Governor sonunu voiced
support for a bill that would remove
this requirement from marriage license
applications the bill he referenced was
HB 1644 from the 20 18 to 2020 session
it sought to remove the collection of
race data from marriage license
applications as well as other
governmental
forms that Bill had much more expansive
reach and we're just talking about
marriage today and for the record the
statute in question for hb1 1220 is RSA
5c section 41 paragraph 3 with RSA 5c
being the chapter um of the rsas on
Vital Records
so there there are several reasons that
support removing this data collection
requirement in marriage license
applications uh first this requirement
has what I believe to be a chilling
effect on joining the institution of
marriage and uh prer perhaps for those
families that are many generations
removed from their immigrant ancestors
sharing race and ancestral information
may not appear to be a strong reason to
not apply for a marriage license
um but for those Americans that either
know their immigrant family members or
are um immigrants themselves this is not
a completely in inconsequential
question and recent efforts in other
states to remove these types of data
retention policies on these grounds have
been
successful um again attorney lock should
be able to go into greater detail on
that
point uh secondly the data being
collected is
ineffective it's incomplete and not
necessar not necessarily representative
of current reality and as a related
matter um race data is collected by the
national census so this data is sitting
around with no real purpose which brings
me to my third point and that's the fact
that we must be cautious with the type
of data our state government collects
and holds uh I think the importance of
data privacy is becoming more and more
common knowledge and even incomplete and
unorganized data can be mined for not so
innocuous
purposes so I thank you for your time
and
consideration um I request that the
committee give a recommendation of ought
to pass and be happy to answer any
questions questions for this witness
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question I have to ask why
do you see this as a
problem um I'll first say that I was
approached or the sponsors were
approached by um assist an attorney
general lock to put this bill forward he
had the language ready to go and he
identified it as being an issue that
could be a problem in our state because
um like I said earlier it's been an
issue in other states and there have
been uh efforts to have that removed in
other states so this is kind of getting
ahead of the situation and and that's
that's my understanding of it and it
what's what's also interesting is that
in this conversation
is I don't I don't know if if any of the
sponsors have their marriage application
in New Hampshire so we don't actually
have a whole lot of um upfront knowledge
like my marriage license is from
Massachusetts so I I had it's not
something that I I don't think any of
the sponsors had had real life knowledge
of but I I could certainly see why C
certain people would feel this
way
yes do you know if it is required
on the marriage certificate to state
that or can you leave it blank and I
asked
because my parents came here from Italy
yeah I don't say I'm
Italian you know I I'm a white American
so do you is it required that you fill
that out on your marriage
certificate as far as I know right now
yes other
yes representative trip thank you for
taking my question uh I suspect that
maybe this will be answered later but uh
do you
know uh what
this uh race and anesty information is
used for or is it just collected and
sits in the
drawer I think it's um your your second
point it's and and that's kind of why it
needs to it needs to be taken care of um
I I personally my my final Point um on
Dat of retention if it's not being used
somewhere it really shouldn't be
collected thank you yeah other questions
for this witness representative Staples
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you or the uh
Assistant Attorney General or um any
other research show that there were
problems of license denial um due to Ras
and
ancestry um thank you for that question
um I don't know if there's any
data but I think the success
of the the push to get rid of this
requirement in other states kind of
indicates that there is a
problem um and I think AG lock or
assistant AG lock will be able to go
into that in Greater detail thank you
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much representative
next I'm going to call on Representative
Keith Ammon
please it's still good morning uh
committee members this is my second time
this morning testifying it's a pleasure
to be here uh thank you for hearing my
testimony I I am a co-sponsor on this
Bill I'm here to lend my support uh to
the bill
um I think it goes towards the idea that
we strive to be a colorblind society and
that you know we see each other as
individuals not of members of a group
and that that is the the basis of my
support for this that I think it's it's
maybe an obsolete data point that we're
collecting um many people like to use uh
ancestry.com to uh track their ancestral
Roots um we have immigration records
that track where your ancestors Came
From Italy or Germany or some other
place um and so that data is is readily
available and tracked in large systems
like with ancestry.com so I I see this
data point as
superflous and uh I think I support uh
remove moving it simplifying the
marriage
license and happy to take any
questions questions for this witness see
representative gon thank you Mr it just
occurred to me to ask a question about
this the immediately following the uh
the race and
ancestry question is their level of
Education what would be the purpose in
collecting that data as well you talking
about Superfluous information what's the
reason for collecting their level of
Education as well yeah so the the bill
doesn't touch on that point um but I I
share your question I don't know why
that's uh collected either um maybe to
make sure
that I I don't know what the what the
reasoning was behind it I I won't even
Hazard a
guess representative trip thank you
chair thank you for taking my question
uh since you brought up
ancestry.com uh I I find that
interesting interesting because uh I've
never done it but my kids have and they
found out that they're uh
uh their ancestry is uh from multiple
places multiple being probably about
20 uh I don't know how the marriage
license works but uh is there just a
checklist of uh things you can put
down um the right behind me can answer
that question a little better there may
be a checkbox with a a line that you can
fill in for other I don't know the
answer I guess the the other question I
would ask is there is there a penalty
for falsifying that I doubt it that
there is but again I'll defer to experts
behind me so this is kind of like your
Facebook birthday everybody knows it's a
lie but uh oh I I don't use Facebook
so smart
man questions for this
sness
saying none thank you very much
representative next I'm going to call on
Sean Lock
please good morning everyone chairman
Lynn members of the House Judiciary
Committee my name is Sean Lock I'm a
senior Assistant Attorney General and I
direct the Civil Rights unit at the new
Attorney General's office I am here on
behalf of the Attorney General to
testify in support of House Bill 1220
which is a bill that we requested I'm
going to kind of have three things I
want to cover in this testimony first
the background of how did this request
came to pass history of this particular
provision uh RSA 5 c41 and then the
legal issues that have Arisen I know
there have been questions asked I will
do my best to answer those questions as
well uh so starting with the history in
February of 2020 governor sununu and
attorney General McDonald had received
notice from Advocates that RSA 5 c41
requires people seeking a marriage
license to provide information about
their race and ancestry and that such
requirements across the country are a
vestage of laws that were designed to
prohibit interracial marriages or to
limit interracial marriages that some
courts have had deemed constitutionally
suspect that those requirements remain
in the
law uh I worked with then Governor's
legal council John forel reviewed this
and we consulted and agreed that the
best course of action would be to remove
the requirements which led to Governor
cunu requesting of then speaker
shirtliff and president Susi to use
House Bill 1644 as a vehicle to enact
those changes unfortunately that
occurred on March 9th and about less
than 10 days later the covid-19 pandemic
began the state of emergency began and
along with many other pieces of
legislation that that did not go
forward in April of 2023 we were
contacted again by these Advocates about
these changes and realizing that they
had not they had been lost in Thea chaos
of covid we offered to pursue a fix for
this issue this afforded me time to do
the research and ensure that we were not
creating there were no conflicting
issues with respect to this data that's
being collected so the history of this
language is it first appears in 1858 it
was first codified in
1858 uh shortly after the requirement
for receiving a marriage certificate or
marriage license shifted from a
requirement that individuals have to
publish in local papers their request
that the idea that they are seeking to
be married and provide opportunity for
members of the public to object to the
marriage in 1854 was changed where you
go to the town clerk's office and get
something similar to the process as it
exists today four years later the
requirement that people provide their
color or ancestry data uh was in
codified into the statute and the
legislative record at that time you know
we I certainly couldn't find access to
it to see what was said other than the
house Jour House of senent journals
which did not provide a lot of
information but the political current at
the time in New England was dominated by
what was called the no- Nothing party
which was an anti-catholic
anti-immigrant
um party and so certainly there it
certainly creates a cloud as to why this
requirement suddenly came into law when
it hadn't been when we shifted from a
published notification to the town
clerk's
office over the years and decades this
law had been shifted around and
recodified and eventually became RSA 5
c41 in preparing this legislation um and
making this request I did consult with
the division of Vital Records as well as
the Department of Health and Human
Services to learn if it had any mo there
there's any modern reason any modern use
for this particular data and it was
informed by the division of Vital
Records that although they collect this
data you the federal government decades
ago used to collect this data it has not
since the 199 90 s um so essentially
what this data does it's it's
statistical data that's kept it's
accessible to the public but that's its
only use it's not used for any sort of
um other
purpose which brings me to kind of the
legal questions here so where these
requirements have been challenged in
courts it's implicated both the equal
protection Clause as well as the
fundamental right to marriage which has
been recognized by multiple courts or
the US Supreme Court multiple times
going back to the decision in loving
View
Virginia it warrants strict scrutiny
which means that there needs to be a
compelling State interest for for
requiring the provision of this data in
order to receive a marriage
license unlike states where this has
been challenged where there is a much
stronger link between the concepts of
racial Integrity or prohibiting
interracial
marriage and these this these
requirements that is not necess
president in New Hampshire New Hampshire
never had a law that prohibited
interracial marriage and and so that
link isn't as clearly cut but it still
distills down to even absent that link
the state interest may be limited
because all this data is collected for
it to simply be available for the public
to look up on the division of Vital
Records website it's not information
that's used for health information
Health kind of Distributing resources or
for any other state purpose that I am
aware of and so that is why you know and
I contacted the sponsors for this bill
um asking them to introduce it because
last year they had been the sponsors on
a bill that codified the loving standard
that that prohib that recognizes in
state law the right to interracial
marriage so I thought they would be a
good vehicle to start this conversation
having done that work in the previous
year but the Attorney General kind of
with that background asked that this
committee abandon this remnant of kind
of a a a previous time and vote ought to
pass on House Bill 1220 and I'm happy to
take any questions and I was just to the
most recent question pulling up the
worksheet for how this data gets
reported as part of the the licensing
requirement here so I can hopefully
answer some questions about that as well
right questions for this
witness uh yes representative
K thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question just for the record
purposes when you had initially talked
about the bill and the pandemic you had
referenced February 2021 did you mean
February of 2020 yes that's what I meant
sorry thank
you so can can I ask I don't see any
other question can I question what would
you say I mean it seemed that
representative uh Ammon had a good
point just as race and ancestry would
seem to me to have nothing to do with
you know the state would seem to have no
interest for marriage purposes and
knowing that what about level of
Education why would they have any
interest in that for marriage purposes I
would share the concern I didn't neily
the inquiry that how it came to us was
about the race and ancestry data so I
didn't ask about the education
requirement but I would share that same
concern con ER and when representative
Aon brought it up I also shared the
concern but wanted to at least keep the
bill for now clean and neat to the
specific issues that were presented to
us um but I I don't you know I I don't
know that there is a reason we were to
do an amendment to that also there would
be no problem as far as you could see
right all right representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
lots of questions s
sorry having been a health professional
for 42 years I think my ANC IND is
extremely important um um I think years
down the road um I mean I happen to know
where my parents came from in Italy but
years down if that is not public record
through a marriage certificate or
nowhere people may not know um there are
certain no matter what I eat I have a
fabulous HDL I'm called an olive oil
Italian I only know that from my
ancestry that's very important and I'm
in a study now because of that um I just
don't see if we don't have a
problem here in New Hampshire where it
has never been a
problem why to pick and choose to
eliminate this when that
information may be necessary for a
you know something a catastrophic
illness that has come about down the
road so I guess I'm not con it's the you
know if it ain't broke don't fix it you
say we do not discriminate we never have
discriminated in the state of New
Hampshire
um what do you say to Generations down
the road who want to know the ancestry
of their great great grandparents well
tough we didn't ask for it anymore well
so I think there's several answers to
that question the first is even though
there was no codification of a
Prohibition on interracial marriage it
doesn't mean that this requirement
doesn't have that same taint or Paul
kind of over it and you know you still
have to go to the town clerk and present
this data and it could lead to again I I
you know I'm not that much of a
historian to know what happened in the
1850s and 60s but doesn't mean that
people historically weren't refused
licenses because they came or it didn't
create problems going forward that it I
you know I don't imagine it's a problem
in the present day in the same way it
may have been historically but to the
the point about using this as a a tool
to track your own race and ancestry data
you still have to provide information
about your F your family history so you
have to provide information about who
your parents were um and both both
individuals getting married and so that
information is still something that can
be used to trace the information back if
you're trying to identify where your
ancestors may have come to how they
originally came to the United States
where they came from you could use that
information that knowledge just like
anyone would you know I know my parents'
names I can go look for their birth
records figure out who their parents
were and that's usually how the the
genealogy process works um it's not
necessarily you know I could put and I
in the worksheet itself it just asks for
a ra it's a fill in it's a a person can
fill in you know it's not a checkbox
it's a put what how you would
self-describe your race or ancestry but
I couldn't go look up your marriage
license in a public record somewhere and
find that information because it's the
the worksheet itself is done it's
collected by the clerk's office before
they issue you the marriage license and
then when the person is married it gets
sent to vital records as and compiled
into data that is publicly accessible
but only in a statistical sense so it
will say you know 1,000 people who
identify as black you know received
marriage licenses in this previous year
it's not to the point of this particular
person identifies as this race and
received a marriage license this year so
it's doesn't for those research purposes
it is isn't necessarily useful data in
that regard as opposed to um birth
records which would still still require
provision of race data adoption records
still require provision of race data and
family familial data so there's still
other vital records that may collect
this data that was part of the issue in
House Bill 1644 from what I recall and
why um the governor when he in his
letter asked for and I can provide a
copy of the letter for the committee um
to save this one piece with marriage
licenses because there were concerns
about other types of vital records birth
records death records adoption records
and the requirements under state and
federal law to ensure that Vital Records
isn't compliance with
those yes and I understand you can go
back but when my mother came here her
last name was changed because they wrote
it wrong coming off the
boat
so tracing things is not as clean as you
think it might be whereas if when she
had to have her marriage license she
said her ancestry
was you know a
brutes you could trace it so I I
understand in a perfect world that that
would work but names are dramatically
have been changed and people can change
their names and people can change their
names to change
their possible notif you of notifying
take the I and the O off and I'm not
aent anymore so um I just I understand
where you're coming from but again I
still just cannot see where this is in
the best interests of future generations
and I would just to quickly respond to
that I appreciate that concern but I
also re this is a question of whether or
not it's of a compelling State interest
to collect that data so there's a
question of I want to do genealogical
research versus you know why is the
state collecting this data because I
don't know that it's going to be a
compelling justification to say so other
people can so someone Generations in the
line might be able to do Gene
genealogical
research other questions for this
witness representative Manos thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question is there a technical definition
of An ancestry and if so what what is it
uh not in the statute let me see I will
look at the worksheet and see what it so
for ancestry it does it it lists as
examples English French Puerto Rican Etc
and it's open to that person to specify
what their ancestry
is yeah so then there isn't even
necessarily consistency between how
similarly situated people W would answer
the same question correct and that's
something that was identified in the
court that has most recently addressed
this particular issue is that even where
the data is collected it's not
consistent so how reliable is this data
if it has any purpose at
all representative uh trip Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question uh are there any other
documents like uh birth certificates or
whatever where race and an trusty uh
information is collected yes so my
understanding is birth
certificates um adoption records and
death certificates do still collect race
and an or at least race data I don't
know about ancestry off the top of my
head but those do and like I said that
was part of the codification that was
being prop or the changes that were
being proposed in House Bill
1644 and like I said with the I don't
remember which exact set of Records
became the problem but some of them
there was concerns raised by vital
records and the Health and Human
Services about removing that because
there are requirements under federal law
to collect some of that information I
know specifically with respect to
adoption records there are a lot of
federal laws related to Native American
Adoptions that if you were to remove
that requirement could create problems
in conflict with um Federal the federal
law government's ability to kind of
ensure that those laws are being
followed thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you all lot uh next I'm going to call on
Kristen kenniston
please good morning my name is Kristen
kenniston I'm the state registar and
director of Vital Records um so I'm
hoping I'll be able to answer some of
the questions for you that I've heard
earlier what I have coming around right
now is a handout and it has the marriage
intention worksheets for you all to look
at it also shows you a test sample of
what a marriage license would look like
that's created after the couple has
filled out a marriage intention
worksheet and then there is a certified
copy for you to look at of what a
marriage license looks like after so um
we'll start with the marriage worksheets
it's a two-page document on the back is
where the statistical information is
being collected so um as it's been
pointed out already that the statistical
component as far as race and ancestry
goes there's no check boxes it's it's
all entirely self-reliant so it depends
on what you want to put down um and then
there's the educational piece which is
um to standard education of um I can't
even talk right now I'm sorry the United
States education system so that it goes
through college so when a couple gets
married they need to go to the town
clerk's office or the city clerk's
office in the state of New Hampshire to
apply for their marriage license they
bring with them their photo ID $50 and
then they have to show some proof of
that they're free to marry so either
they would bring their divorce decree
with them or maybe a copy of a death
certificate for a previous a spouse they
fill out that information on the
worksheet they sign it the clerk then
goes to the computer and enters that
marriage license into our neverin system
so the neverin system is our electronic
database that we use for all of our
Vital
Records the system will then generate
off the marriage license which you'll
see on page two of your handout and you
can see if you look down at the very
bottom of that that the statistical
information does not appear anywhere on
there so it never shows up anywhere on
the marriage license at all and then
when you get to the point after the um
ceremony has been completed by the
officient and it's signed off on and
returned to the clerk they'll put that
into our neverend system to finish it
off it becomes a filed record and then
the couple can buy a certified copy of
the record so the last page is just a
sample of what shows up on a certified
copy and again you'll see that the
statistical information does not show
anywhere on there so currently the
reason that we are collecting the
statistical information just to back up
some of the testimony you've already
heard from today is because it's a
national standard so um somewhere in the
1950s the marriage licenses started to
be um looked at and a National Standard
was set for that so it's twofold for
that purposes one is from the record
side of things where when you get
married in one state you're collecting
the same information so that if you took
that marriage license to another state
you can still conduct your business
there they'll still accept it because
it's a standard form it's still
collecting all the same information that
other states are collecting from a
statistical standpoint the information
it needs to be obviously consistent
whenever you're looking at Public Health
you always want to look at the same data
set um and it just helps with the data
quality so that's a reason why it had to
be consistent in all the other states so
a lot of the other states are also
collecting this data at this time as
well I would say that the statistical
data that's being collected though is
not being used um we do not report any
of this information to the federal
government anymore they had a program
that used to actually use the
statistical information that ended in
the 199s so I believe in 1995 was like
the last time we actually give gave this
information to the federal government
for their use and also our New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
no longer uses this information I did
confirm that with them they don't touch
any of the statistical piece so to Echo
what you are hearing today this
information is simply being collected
and it's it's just collecting uh
metaphorical dust in our database and
there's no reason for us to collect it
so just another component so you
understand too we collect the data at
Vital Records we actually don't use it
we are not doing statistic work with it
so we have no use for it federal
government has no use for it and our New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services does not
either um so just going back to the
standardized forms so even though R RSA
5 C5 says that we follow follow national
standards on all of our records the
national standards for our Vital Records
for marriage licenses hasn't been
updated
since 1989 so we are still following
these old guidelines um that we don't
really need to anymore RSA 5c4 says that
we shouldn't be collecting any data that
we really don't need so I am not opposed
to this coming out if if you'd see fit
in removing it I would actually even go
one step further and ask that you do
also remove the educational piece
because that's sitting there and we're
not doing anything with it either to
answer a question that was brought up
earlier about education at one time
occupation used to be um something that
they sought and then somewhere along the
line the federal government realized
that wasn't a really great indicator of
socioeconomic backgrounds so they did
change that piece to being education
because they thought that that was a
better way of actually being able to
interpret that data so that's why that's
on there but again it's not being
used right um the only other final thing
that I would say is fiscal impacts
relatively small I think we said $10,000
in working with our software company on
some other things I might put that
closer to 20,000 but still not a huge
fiscal impact we'd have to redo our
forms which again aren't a big deal um
and the 60 days though for I think it
was an effective date of 60 days I might
respectfully request that's 90 just to
give us a little extra time to get our
forms changed and to make our software
changes should you choose to pass this
and I can take any questions questions
for this
witness
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question would
you mind repeating which uh statue you
stated um states that you shouldn't be
collecting information if you aren't
going to be using it RSA 5c4 and that
was my loose interpretation of that I
have it here if you want me to pass it
over need to look at okay that's okay
thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing n thank you very
much just making a note on
something all right um I don't have any
other uh Pink cards is there anyone else
who wishes to be heard on House Bill uh
2020 I should note uh for the record
that there were four people uh
supporting this bill three people
opposed um and that's it I don't U see
anyone else so I'm going to close the
hearing on uh House Bill
2020 and um what time is
it we have three minutes for the next
hearing oh okay great that's fine sure
yes Mr chair um do you think it's
appropriate that representative Ming
might
uh pursue
an it's appropriate that representative
might pursue an
amendment education oh ABS yeah no
absolutely and you know what the other
thing I would suggest representative m
is maybe maybe we' change the effective
date to 90 days also yeah I I I noted
that as well okay yes no that' be yeah
that'd be I think that I think that'd be
great right all right thank
you
oh right right right right right yeah
supposed to be 90 days of January
1 um it says well it's right now it's 60
days right I thought it's supposed to be
January 1 though because it affects
multiple agencies doesn't
it
stat yeah I I don't know yeah
right
John well everybody has food and drink
on the table not committed but I didn't
know is that
right right
water yeah just press oh maybe then
we'll
do thermostat it's
freezing thank you so much that's that's
it is but he was polite the witness I've
been there
yeah you definitely
don't no that won't
work doesn't make any difference you
could try but it's just
Aus maybe that one works none of them
work no you need to it
it's you need to
um get the
master to come and there's a magic code
who is the
master who is the master we need set F
I'm freezing so
no link
that I know I
know
have some interesting bills yeah right
right make the point to let represent
wheeler about our other bills to to the
Human Rights Commission all right so
this you know don't it's a good bill I
think reading the temp of the room
everybody likes you might
the human right that TR truck right
right exactly no I I think that's true I
think that's just talk to people if you
want to slow walk your claims through
the Human Rights
Commission six or years hi how you doing
good morning
how
see all
right
all all right I think it's I think it is
now Beyond it's 11:16 so we're we can
start we can start the hearing I'm going
to open the hearing on uh House Bill
1245 and rep and recognize
representative uh Peter Schmidt thank
you so much Mr
chairman I so tempted to call you Je
judge um because I remember you very
well as Chief Justice of the superior
court system and then Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court as well so it's a
pleasure being before you as my
colleague on the Jael car as so where we
sit next to each other um and so I I'm
pleased to bring this bill before you
again uh as all of you who are not new
to this committee this year know this
bill was for you um last term uh last
year and uh it was amended uh at at our
request as well uh and so the bill as
I'm bringing it to you uh is the amended
version since we are we were totally on
board with the uh with the amendment
that is that is Incorporated in was
incorporated in the bill last year so
can I just add can I just ask just uh I
don't mean to interrupt your represent
but is this is is the
1245 that we have before us now it is
the same bill as amended that was that
this committee passed and then the Full
House passed last year that is my
understanding Mr chairman because we
were totally on board with the idea of
the amendment we we we endorsed it fully
um and I said there's no sense going
back to the original Bill and and having
you have to amend it all over again that
made no sense um
so I am but I have uh several uh people
here who are extremely knowledgeable
about this issue and they will be
testifying
momentarily um but
uh this may seem like a small bill but
to the people uh in this in this
category this is a very important issue
um and I appreciate the hard work that
the committee did last year on getting
it to this point um and uh so I'm not
going to take questions on the subject
because the attorneys and so forth who
are here and uh to to present the facts
and and discuss the issue with you they
are the people you should be hearing
from and talking to but I'm I appreciate
the work that was done last year it it
it came out of the committee I think
unanimous ly uh otpa and went through
the house I'm not sure whether it was on
the consent calendar but you yourself
were there in the Senate after the bill
passed and testified in the Senate and
so forth and unfortunately the bill was
not understood properly by uh by some
members of the senate committee and thus
it was it but this is an important issue
so I recommend it to your to your
attention and to your competent
assessment
um and I thank you for the opportunity
to appear before you today and I would
like to uh yield to the attorneys who
are the experts on the subject matter
thank you great thank you thank you
represent Smith um let's see uh Karen
Rosenberg
um I know I saw her
I oh all right sure no that's fine um
then I'll I'll skip over her for a
moment and call on Carrie Tasker
please great thank
you
morning thank you I appreciate this
opportunity um as as indicated um by
representative Schmid I have worked um
with Karen Rosenberg on um moving this
piece of legislation forward
um what this bill is about in essence is
about persons who are under guardianship
so adults who are under
guardianship um and letting them have
access to their own personal records
records that include um medical records
Financial records education records any
any sort of personal records to
themselves um more often than not the
orders that um come out of
um the C the guard the probate Courts
for guardianships do include language
that um suggest that the W should not
have access to their records and so we
think that that is more of um an
unfortunate oversight and so we would
like to correct the issue both for
existing guardianships and for
guardianships going forward so the first
section of this bill um does talk about
um uh how we address new guardianships
and saying that we would like the court
to find um that there is a reason to uh
include in the order that the person
should have their right to access
records um um basically withheld and a
finding that the person can no longer
access their their medical or personal
records
and later on in the bill we talk about
how we want somebody who's already under
guardianship to who has an order that
that might suggest that they shouldn't
have access to their records or that
it's unclear whether they should have
access to their records that there's an
opportunity for them to approach the
court to find a way to obtain access to
their records and this can occur in many
different circumstances either when
somebody is trying to remove or change
their their guard Guardian whether
they're trying to terminate their
guardianship due to various reasons or
whether um they want to just amend the
terms of their guardianship that in
order to do a lot of those things they
need access to their own records so they
understand what their personal assets
are what their medical records might
State and so this gives them an Avenue
to approach the court approach their
Guardian for um for access to those
personal records what we see uh what I
tend to see myself um is that um a lot
of the wards
here um under guardianship feel that
they have no right to access their
records the Guardians do tend to tell
them that they have no right to access
their records uh and they don't really
know how to move forward with that issue
and present it before the court
necessarily so they more or less just
agree and never access their own records
we want this to be um clear um in both
the Court's orders going forward um that
they do have a right to access their
records unless there is a good medical
reason for them not to access their
records um or second that there is a way
for them to to petition the court
um in the you know for existing Guardian
ships for them to to now seek permission
from the court to access the records so
essentially this is just allowing any
person under a guardianship to obtain
access to their records unless there is
a good finding legal reason um found by
the court for the person not to have
access to those records all right thank
you Mr Rosenberg welcome I I apologize
for being late I'm Karen Rosenberg the
policy director of the disability rights
I thought I could run faster than I can
these days so I was trying to get some
information for the sponsor but I think
he probably so you know it m Rosenberg
since I know you were very intimately
involved in last year's Bill I just
wanted I wanted to sort of ask the the
same question to you that I asked uh to
to representative Schmidt this bill that
we have now before us is the exact bill
that was passed by this committee and
the whole house last year exactly the
only thing that's different is the
number everything else is exactly the
same I so I I I didn't mean to interrupt
you my my sense is at least I hope this
is the case that you're preaching to the
choir here um but please if there you
know tell us I hope so too and I just
think if anyone has any questions about
the bill or concerns that have Arisen
since last section that attorney Tasker
and I would be happy to address
them speaking for myself the only
question that I had having testified
before the other body the only question
that I have which you are not in a
position to answer
is what what the problem was I just
don't understand what this seemed like
seems like a perfectly reasonable bill
and I just don't understand what the
problem was well of course we agree with
you that it's perfectly reasonable and
hope you will continue supporting it and
I think we'll just have to do some more
work and make sure that folks in the
other body really understand what we're
trying to accomplish here and why so
we'll do our fast great are there yes
representative tur uh yeah just just one
quick question and uh this may be more
to our chair than to our our uh uh uh
person giving testimony um this has the
language in it the court shall issue an
order um I just wanted to make sure as
we're as we're going forward with that
language that we it's it's acceptable
for legislation to say the court shall
issue an order yeah yes I think that I
think yes I think that's I think I don't
see any problem with
that all right um any other questions
for either of these
Witnesses great thank you very much
thank you and my apologies for being no
no no problem no problem um let me see
um on uh
12:45 um Li Elizabeth S sski yes
microphone oh yeah thank you red means
on apparently not stop good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Lisa Brit solski Stevens and I'm
the incoming chief executive officer at
the office of public Guardian um I feel
a little bit like I've dropped into the
Fifth Act of a play so please forgive me
um I have been at OPG now for two months
um and this bill came to my attention um
we do have concerns I don't think they
are
insurmountable um I did reach out to
representative Schmidt who I have known
for many years to understand um the
origin and the intention and
unfortunately I think January being what
January is at the lob he was not able to
get back to me um the Office of Public
Guardian uh has guardianship over about
1,200 Granite sters so we are the
biggest game in town as it relates to
the performance of Guardianship Services
over adults in New
Hampshire and so our initial concerns
are how this would increase our current
workflow and how we would account for
that with our funders who are primarily
the Department of Health and Human
Services and the Department of
Corrections um we also want to raise a
concern um that there is a big
difference between allowing one of our
clients or Wards as they are referred
ref to in the statute um to access their
records as distinguished from being able
to authorize the release of their
records um and very different
consideration should be applied in
whether we are allowing access to that
record or in fact saying that the award
should that the award has the authority
to release those records frequently the
content of those records can be very
disturbing for the ward um and and we
want to make sure that we have a enough
protective measure in distinguishing
between access and authority to release
um I would look forward to the
opportunity to connect with Karen and
her colleague from the DRC again I feel
like I've dropped into the Fifth Act of
an ongoing play um but we did feel at
OPG it was important to show up today
and be heard okay questions for this
witness representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I guess I don't
understand I I'm trying to understand in
what
situation like you don't have to give me
a specific but in what situation would
it not be in the best interest of the
ward to have control over their own
records an adult Ward absolutely um
again sometimes the content of those
records can be very disturbing it might
recount trauma um and and things that
that individual has spent perhaps most
of their life trying to adjust to and be
able to be as independent as possible
despite the sequele of that trauma um
again there we feel like there is a very
important distinction between having
access to that record and then being
able to authorize the release of that
record so if I could just if I could
just follow up what's the difference
between the access and the release
because it's still giving the trauma to
the person that it's their own
information so I
guess yes you are coming into the Fifth
Act I feel like we've already looked
into this kind of thing and I I guess
I'm wondering what more are you
contributing that would make me pause on
a bill that we've already passed and we
think that somebody's information should
be their own information to send out I
guess I'm like give me something more to
go on you're right I'm flat footed I
I've been at OPG now since the middle of
November I'm surprised that nobody in
the office had been engaged prior to now
um I'd like to rectify that um the first
thing that comes to mind though about
the release is could that be being done
in a retaliatory way because somebody
has been named in those records as the
perpetrator of that
trauma representative
Smith congratulations on your new job
and welcome to the Judiciary Committee
you certainly have had a long history of
being involved in issues that are of our
concern to all of us and that we
share and I don't want to put you on the
spot but I've put myself on the spot
well a phrase comes to mind and I'm
not you know I'm not a lawyer I don't
play one on
TV um but the phrase that comes to mind
is not a phrase that I find attractive
and it is in local
parenes it is the assumption that
someone
else
has more power more right more
authority to make decisions for me than
do
I and do I or I do well I think either
way is grammatically correct
um and
I just wonder if this might be a
situation
where you H it might be possible that
you haven't had a Time sufficient to be
grounded in the history of this and why
after a lot of research and a lot of
time the decision was made to to support
this I I think the the tail end of your
commentary is spoton again I I rais this
with the leadership team at OPG and they
had not previously been engaged and that
was a little bit of a surprise to me um
we certainly are grateful for the
opportunity to participate in the
conversation now um in terms of your
introductory comment representative
Smith I I couldn't agree more and I
think that the the Guardians at OPG have
probably the deepest understanding of
the balance and a tremendous commitment
to ensuring the ongoing Integrity of
every ward in our charge um I'm sure it
is no surprise to the committee that the
burden of proof in determining that
somebody is incapacitated to the degree
that they cannot make those decisions
that burden of proof though it is a
civil proceeding is beyond a reasonable
doubt and I think that is precisely at
the ju toos of what you are describing
that nobody would be under guardianship
unless it had been demonstrated Beyond
reasonable doubt that that was in their
best interest and that they could do
harm to themselves or to others um I I
hope that's um responsive to to your
question other questions so you know the
thing I guess as I'm looking at this uh
and it um the language that um that this
bill changes um it it talks about to
have access to or to Grant
release um in section four and then if
you go over to um
um uh I'm sorry that was section one uh
uh Roman numeral 4 on page uh one of the
bill and then if you go over to section
four of the bill it also talks about
um
uh the that the ward May uh the ward May
request authority to access and Grant
release to of his or her confidential
records I don't see any in either of
those sections that would that would
prevent a court other words if there was
a if you had a situation where you were
saying to the court well we don't have
any problem with the the release of the
records of the Guardian to of the uh uh
of the ward to the ward but we don't
think the ward should be able to further
release them uh there would I don't see
anything in this would prevent you from
making that argument to the court and if
the court agreed with you they could do
that I I mean I tend to share
representative I think what the
sentiment of Representative Smith and
representative Alexander that would
strike me that would be a it would be an
unusual situation I would think where a
court would say you can see the records
Ward but you can't pass them on to
somebody else maybe that would exist but
I'd be that would seem to me to be
pretty
unusual and I think perhaps illustrates
why it would have been so important for
OPG to be a more meaningful part of the
dialogue and I would enjoy the
opportunity to be involved in the go
forward ours is not to say this should
not pass ours is to say we think we
should be involved in readed in okay all
right other yes representative Smith um
I I don't think you'll be able to answer
this but perhaps um one of our previous
Witnesses could was there a specific
action
ever taken to make sure that the Office
of Public Guardian was not involved in
everything leading up to the
initial preparation of the
bill last year and that then went
publicly through the house through the
committee the house and to the Senate I
guess I'm not sure no one in the office
of public Guardian saw fit to say hey we
might have a
problem I can't speak for my current
colleagues I can say that as the newest
member of the executive team and because
perhaps of my long history of walking
these halls I as a matter of custom
review the lsrs and review the bills and
I said guys what do you think about this
um I would like to give them all space
and grace and the benefit of the doubt
that um this might be something new to
their
calendar I'm sure you'll be adding some
valuable strength to the work of the
office you're very kind thank you uh yes
representative
Lonzo um thank you for uh taking my
question so in thinking about when um a
person who is in capacitate and is not
um is seeking to get their records um
first of all would it be the guardian's
um position to actually uh review those
records with that person um to go over
those records um and especially if
somebody really wants to know what
they're you know they're seeking their
records They want to know exactly what's
going on um it's the guardian Guardians
P um is they are for that person um and
they should be allowed
to um should they not be allowed to um
sit down with that guardian and and
review their records with
them I think it's important to clarify
that a guardian is not part of the Care
team for any of these individuals they
represent largely a legal status um and
as I'm sure all of you can appreciate
not all people under guardianship want
to be under guardianship so they have um
an appropriately distanced relationship
there is information that they
absolutely share um and then there are
also people under guardianship who have
very strong ties to their guardian and
work very
collaboratively um but I can't say that
it would
be customary to sort of have that
caregiver kind of relationship I think
it would be more likely that the
guardian would Express concern about
what that person might see in their
record and encourage them to work
through that with their care
team other questions for this witness
right you know ma'am I just want to just
want to um say and I I I please
understand we um this is in no way meant
as a you know in any kind of criticism
of view um but in light of the history
of this bill um we we may I'm not sure
if we're going to but you I just want to
let you know that we may decide if the
ranking member and myself agree that we
would exec this bill today given its
given its history and what I would say
is to the extent that there you know
that there are concerns that you would
like to you know bring forward um
obviously the fact that we execute and
even pass it in the house doesn't mean
that it's becomes the law it's got to go
to the other body um and so you will
have an
opportunity uh you know to raise the
concerns uh there and I would also
suggest I think you know there are
you've you've heard there are several
witnesses here um who have testified I'm
sure would be happy to meet with you and
talk with you about this and so um but I
do think you know we've got a very busy
House schedule um and to the extent that
we can exec things particularly things
that we've already sort of done the
dance before it it's in our interest to
move forward so I just want to let you
know that and it certainly mean no
disrespect to you in any way thank you
so much I appreciate that thank you very
much right is there anyone else um here
who wishes to testify on House Bill
1245 have
a yes so we have uh among the people who
just signed in we have three supporting
and zero
opposed
um sure come on up representative yala
we're going to get to you I
promise Sor
right I'll be quick um I just as far as
the issue that was raised about possible
harm to the ward the bill as written
actually provides guard rails that I
wanted to call your attention to so if
there's not a
determination that on this issue about
whether the ward can have access to
their records and they request access
from their Guardian if the guardian
feels that it would be harmful the
guardian can then petition the court for
an order and similarly um if the ward is
Seeking a modification or they're
seeking to change Guardians and their
asking for permission um they petition
the court themselves for permission to
see their records the court then would
have the opportunity to determine
whether providing such access would be
harmful and the guardian would have the
opportunity to weigh in on that so I
just wanted to put your minds at ease
about this there are some guard rails to
protect people if it would be harmful
and just because someone's under
guardianship doesn't automatically mean
that they are stripped of all of their
rights that an adult would enjoy courts
are required under law to consider
specifically which rights they're taking
away and why and affirming that the
person due to their incapacity is unable
to exercise those
rights questions for this
witness oh yes representative
Smith I don't want to delay it um if if
you are under guardianship are you
permitted to vote unless the court says
you're not yes you are permitted to
vote other question for this witness
thank you very much thank you for having
me again anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1245 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1245 and I'm going
to um open the hearing on uh the on non
gerain Amendment
2024 d202 37h to House Bill
1696 and I'm going to call on whoop
representative Josh
shella thank you chair and members of
house
Judiciary um I am happy to uh be here
today uh I guess my for the record my
name is Joshua Ellum uh
I represent Fremont Danville and
brenwood um I'm here to introduce uh
amendment to HB 169 96 uh
0237 and uh a little and I would like to
thank the the chair and the committee
for um the opportunity to um speak to
you about this today and especially
because um this
bill is really a right to know bill um
and you guys have a lot of expertise in
that area that that will be able to be
brought to bear on this
issue um I uh the Genesis of this this
bill goes back a number of years um and
I have been working with uh with my
municipality and uh
the municipal and County government uh
or Municipal Association sorry uh
regarding right to know and why um
there's not more
uh access to the right to know documents
I definitely um you know at my
municipality a lot of those records are
just stored in boxes up in some filing
cabinet and um if you're asking about
something that wasn't in the last six
months or something they're going to be
like uh that's going to be hard to find
somewhere you know especially if there
was some turnover in the office and the
person um currently in that office
wasn't the person that filed that that
document um there is some concern about
that and some hesitation and um that can
create one kind of a chilling effect on
the person requesting it that that it's
going to be a burden on their town which
they didn't want to impose necessarily
and also from the uh from the town uh
just uh feeling overwhelmed that they
have many things to do and that uh that
this is kind of a burden on them every
time there's a right to no request um
and I think that one option that would
be uh a win-win win for everyone
involved is to have those records online
and um a lot of municipalities are
starting to do that with their current
records um however there's space
constraints on their website and they
may pull them down if they feel like
they're you know old and people are not
regularly using them uh and so to cut
down cost they may limit to only the you
know current stuff uh within the last
six months or a year or something like
that on their website and then there's
uh and so this bill is here to kind of
create a central repository at the State
uh for those right to know documents if
the municipality chooses to upload them
to that um it's completely opt in it's
completely at the discretion of the
municipality how much or how little they
want to um take advantage of this option
that the state would give them um there
is uh the the website would be housed at
the office of the um
archist and uh they have the expertise
and have already done some due diligence
around this and what technology that
they would like to use or um
specifically technology that has been
used around the country for this exact
purpose and have um uh High degree of
certainty that the records will be kept
and maintained and stuff like that
and also they are very uh happy to be
able to use this uh local record or
local government records manager for
training and and helping
municipalities fulfill their their
obligations to retain these records and
keep them um currently that local
records manager is in statute already um
that position it's just never been
funded and and um so that position is
not filled and they have a limited
capacity to be able to help
municipalities right now this would
essentially allow them to hire that
person and provide even in addition to
the website more uh services to the
communities about how to um preserve
these
records um the win and so the win for
the public is the access to those
records all the time without even having
to do a right to no request they can
just go on the website and start pulling
down stuff I did that this weekend with
this the website uh one of the websites
that I I emailed the committee about on
Sunday with Texas I watched some video
about uh their their drought in the 80s
or something like that and being able to
do that on that website without a right
right to no request or anything um is is
beneficial to the public and and that
transparency that we're looking for that
is guaranteed in the Constitution um
very happy that that will be be
addressed by this um as far as the
public is concerned the state has that
ability to help the the municipality get
these records out and then specifically
the
municipality to the extent that they um
that they abide by the the guidance from
the archist and upload this these
documents to the the website under this
bill they would be uh relieved of the
responsibility to fill those 91a
requests in physical form um they would
just be providing the website address
for um those any records that they
uploaded to the website um instead of
you know filing going through all of
those records um saving the municipality
time and money and incentivizing the
municip municipality to do um and upload
more so that every document that they
upload they reduce that that liability
uh for potential right to know uh
requests in the future and I'm uh
I uh so I did want to I did excuse me I
did want to bring the the committee's
attention to um RSA
33a already allows for municipalities to
store records digitally entirely
digitally
they but most municipalities don't do
that and one of the questions was why
and part of uh that law requires that
they be be accessible um and so even if
they store them as PDFs or whatever um
um it's in the law that they have to
store it as pdfa or or other things that
were were granted by uh by the archist
or the Secretary of State um why aren't
they doing that and I believe that that
the accessibility option is kind of an
unknown right now they have paper they
know how to get it and and the
accessibility has kind of a well uh Worn
Path but the accessibility for these
electronic documents is kind of an
unknown Wild West um because no one
really has has paved the path for them
and I think that th this will pave the
path for them if the state um pavs that
path to that accessibility and then
municipalities will be um much more
encouraged to to utilize that option so
thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions questions for this witness uh
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question I have two quick
questions so it would be the
responsibility of the municipality to
upload these documents correct thank you
for the for the question um yes it would
be the the the guidance would be issued
from the state archist and would be
trained on how to do it um they could
also hire a third party to do that if um
the example I was thinking of for for my
town I went personally and scanned
essentially all of their documents um
and so I know the amount of work that it
would take kind of to how much we're
talking about and I also considered um
the possibility of putting a warrant
article or something on the on the
ballot to say hey we're going to raise
uh $25,000 to essentially do our
backstock of stuff and hire someone
contract them to scan it and upload it
to the website um that is another way it
wouldn't necessarily have to be the
current staff um and give the option to
the taxpayers if they want to do that or
not right my second question thank
you a concern about who picks and
chooses what they decide to
upload thank you for uh the question the
the qu the the question of who decides
is up to the municipality the
municipality can choose um either um by
board or or they can have uh you know
the Selectmen put some guidance
documents and and kind of put it out to
all the the people that they want to um
you know have this board or the entire
uh amount of documents that are
currently being generated uploaded I I
think that um
the the amount of effort is going to be
for the current documents to upload to
the website um many municipalities are
already doing it to their own website
and so I I think that uh it would
probably be just instead of or on top of
that and so not any additional real work
by those
municipalities other representative
Andrews thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking
my sorry about that and a couple of them
what is a person going to do that
doesn't have internet and we have a many
people in the state of New Hampshire
that do not have any internet access so
thank you thank you for the question um
I am going to uh direct you to page two
uh lines two and three of the amendment
specifically um essentially what what
what we are going to
um have is is that not only are you
following the guidance of the the
municipa or the state archist on how to
upload it but you also if you're going
to not keep those records at your your
municipality anymore you need to be able
to give access to uh the website for
costree access to the website um in the
municipality so if they were able you
know to go to the library or go to the
town hall to be able to fulfill that um
that copy uh or be able to get that
record in a c costree way to them um
then that would fulfill that
responsibility however um that's kind of
at a town by Town basis if they don't if
they don't wish to do that then then
they would still just have to go to the
uh the town office for that right to no
request as they do
today okay second
question uh there's 234 municipalities
in the state of New
Hampshire let's say even half of them
even some of your big cities MH did this
it says in here it's only going to cost
about 150,000 for the state to set this
up I don't believe it's an accurate
figure thank you for the statement
um however um the the figure came from
the state archist um uh about the
150,000 is one for uh about 100,000 for
the actual person to help train um uh
the local records manager and then the
50,000 is for the uh the actual website
and uh in the email that I sent you this
weekend they it included the uh the uh
quote from the the place that she's
planning to go and it came to
$50,000 um so you know if it is widely
adopted may we we have to you know buy
another you know some more storage
capacity or whatever yes but the storage
capacity is is not that expensive the
okay thank you thank you other questions
for this representative tur um yeah
thanks and thanks for taking question
the question I'm going to preface it I
guess uh with the idea that and and
excuse me this is my first time working
with a non-main Amendment
um uh this is being amended to a bill
that we have haven't uh finished working
with yet and it's a bill that I
particularly liked um I know there's
another amendment potentially to be
offered that would combine this with
another bill uh and it's a bill that I
don't par particularly like as much um
so I guess my my going back and I know
you have probably no say in exactly
where this ended up
um I guess could you explain what
because we're looking at an amendment to
your original Bill what it I assume um
Maybe I'm Wrong um what does this do
that needed to be changed or that's an
amendment from what you originally
introduced um thank you for the question
um so this is an amendment to not my
bill right this is not the bill is not
mine uh the amendment um has language
from my bill which is um HB
1708 and the only difference between
this amendment and my original bill was
a drafting error in OSS where the um the
on line 11 on page two there was an
appropriation ending in 2024 and instead
of 2025 that is the difference in the
language between 1708 and the language
that you have in front of you so so just
quick followup if I may yes of course so
the if this amendment was was not
adopted and and we went back to the
original bill that that it was added on
to um what would be the implications of
implementing um your would it become
completely unworkable or it would just
have the wrong sort of hor time
Horizon thank you for the question um I
guess if I could asked for clarification
the um are you supposing both
legislations
passed with as as you see in front of
you because I had an amendment in
Municipal and County to fix the the uh
the time frame issue
already
okay representative Smith thank
you I have the bailor already before the
robo
um is it not
true that this bill for reasons
that are not my pay grade um went to
Municipal the substance of this
amendment went to mun ipal and
County a committee that has a great deal
of
responsibility and
experience but none dealing with issues
related to right to
know by the time the
chair
realized that that did not belong that
bill your bill did not belong in
Municipal and County the chair had
already scheduled a hearing and
therefore the rules of the
house required that the bill be acted on
there it was too late for them to pick
up the phone and say to the chair of
Judiciary this is your court not ours
and
therefore the way to resolve that
problem and to get this language before
a committee that is familiar with to
know that is dealing with these issues
in other
bills the decision was made to propose a
non- gerine Amendment which in effect is
your bill with a correction of the date
for it to be attached
to a bill already before this committee
and that's how this poor little bill
made its way from Municipal and County
down the Hall to Judiciary is that a
correct summation of how we got here
today um that is a very very uh good
summation yes there there are some
language in here that um do historically
go to Municipal and County like the
records retention but that is really in
service of the 91a kind of issue and
this is more of a 91a issue than a
records retention or or even a uh you
know an estate archivist kind of bill so
yes I do believe that this is the
correct committee for this Bill thank
you Mr chair I don't know if that helps
um our colleague or not
but if it doesn't then he should proceed
and if not I do have a question to ask
sure and you know so you know and maybe
if I could just add as F forther
clarification I think I mean
this the way this amendment is was
proposed it it completely replaces
if if there was if there was a if if
you preferred 169 I mean if you
preferred 1696 other than as I had
proposed in another amendment to combine
it with 1069 there would be nothing that
would prevent us
from from from keeping
1696 as it originally was and I guess
we'd have to prepare another amendment
to make this a you know another section
of that but we could do that I don't
think that would be
prohibitive yes representative Kat or
I'm sorry did you want to can I just
clarify that because I feel like so if
we could take the
nment as it is and then we could add the
existing HB 1696 which is one one
section that just says nothing in this
section shall prevent the public body or
agency from accepting a governmental
record request by electronic means or
from providing such records
electronically without requiring the
physical appearance of the citizen
making the request so that sentence
could just be
added to the bottom of this non-gain
amendment is that
correct sure I think we can I mean I
think we can I think we can sort of yeah
I think we can do that for sure okay
that would make me more comfortable just
because I feel like this the original
1696 has Merit and it's separate from
the thing that it might otherwise get
combined
with
okay sure so I mean I think the I guess
to I think the answer to that question
is we could we can do that I you know we
and we certainly can discuss that when
we exact when we exact this this when we
exact 1696 and 1069 um we can certainly
you know if that's the way that the
committee feels we should go we can
certainly do that other questions for um
could in just in response to your
comment
um because it does not appear that the
chair is planning to have a work session
on this but instead seems to you know
see us moving towards an executive
session that would require in advance of
the executive session
that an amendment that someone else
might think it
appropriate uh to prepare before in fact
we
vote sure no that's ex that's so that
would have to happen um I have a
slightly different concern and it might
just be because I'm sitting here and I'm
not sitting on Municipal and County and
that is what has
happens in what I hope is going to be
less and less of a
possibility if a a particular
municipality does
not
welcome the opportunity to
share its work with the public is there
anything in this bill or an
amendment that could be done to
require communities
to make this alternative
available thank you for the question um
in working with nhma I'm sure that they
would be hesitant to require any
municipality to be part of
uh to to be a part of this uh I I
drafted it to be completely voluntary
obviously um if they do not wish it to
be accessible on the website they're
still required to be accessible under
91a the traditional way and so um I
do think that that there still will be
accessibility and I do believe that with
the um the records manager and nhma um
being able to help advertise this in
their training courses which I believe
that they you know they will be happy to
do as far as this being a good option
for municipalities especially when
you're talking about uh you know case
studies of municipalities having to
fulfill right to no requests that cost
them
$60,000 or something like that they
having that liability kind of hang over
their head will be uh incentive enough
but I think it uh a mandate from from
this uh to to utilize this at this time
is probably premature until it's been
you know off the ground and been working
for a long time and when we see the the
benefits of it could you provide for the
committee the case study that documents
the costs that you just alluded
to um you don't have answer I just I I I
I I've made my point Thank you thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much
representative uh representative
Alexander did you want um thank you Mr
chair I was planning on speaking but um
you know the video I'm just a bill went
through my head about the process of the
bill from fourth grade and representive
Smith did such she's been around a lot
longer than me and she did such a great
job explaining the way this happened end
up in this committee so I'm all set
thank you great thank you then I'm going
to call next on natch Grace please from
the municipal
Association thank you Mr chair n Grace
for the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we do support this
legislation um this non Germain
Amendment as it is um I want to first
thank the sponsor for his multi-year
partnership with us and obviously now
Secretary of State's office to work on
uh increasing accessibility and
availability of public
records um I think that's bring a very
fruitful uh fruitful relationship and I
hope that that continues in the future
um in this particular Bill we're trying
something new um and what we're trying
new is we're funding a state position
that already exists the um and that
position will both be in charge of
creating this um this uh Records
repository um which is basically a a
slightly more boring version of Netflix
for municipal records um and uh and also
assist municipalities with figuring out
how to best uh use that repository to
help everyone um have greater
accessibility for records as part of
this conversation of course everyone was
concerned about not only the
accessibility of Records but also the
security of those records um recognizing
that the bill provides that if a
municipality does use um this option and
does provide some sort of access at the
local level um for citizens to access
those records whether that's through the
library a terminal at the library a
terminal at um Town Hall we want to make
sure that uh that if that's that's
occurring and therefore they're allowed
to um destroy the original records as is
already allowed under 33a 3A a we wanted
to make sure that this was a system that
was Secure that we had faith in um and
we believe the Secretary of State's
office can provide that um as uh
representative yella mentioned it is our
first foray into doing this um it's
going to take some time um and some
effort for the Secretary of State's
office to set it up to make it work well
and to work with municipalities to uh to
start um providing opportunities to uh
upload records in this manner I imagine
that probably the ones that will opt in
will do something fairly simple like
meeting minutes because everybody has
meetings they all have meeting minutes
they comply with the law now and they're
used to that type of system and then
obviously for municipalities like
Fremont that have a large portion of
their oldo records digitized through one
way or another or looking at that in
order to free up storage space uh in
town hall or or where have you um
obviously we're trying to make this as
easy as possible as userfriendly as
possible and there are a lot of small
small questions out there that have to
be answered with kind of the software
development and how exactly that's going
to work um so we're asking for a little
leeway here um
to perform this perform this experiment
um and we think it's going to be
successful based on uh the many
conversations that we had with the
sponsor um and with the Secretary of
State's office uh so far about how this
may function and I'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
questions for this witness
representative
Andrews thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question you just stated this is an
experiment you mean to tell me we're
going to pass a bill and spend money the
towns may put all their records on and
it may not work and that's going to be
okay
what I mean to say is that uh no one has
done this before in our state um this is
this is a new area um we've had success
over the past several years helping
municipalities work towards greater
digitization of Records greater
accessibility for the general public of
records and we think this will work as
well follow yeah follow up okay so
you've been working with the
municipality
in putting their records together etc
etc so they have their records then now
why should would they want to even
consider taking them to the state level
to me putting their records at the state
level is taking away the right we're
just making a big conglomeration up here
that's my thing and I'm not happy with
it uh well thank you for the question
um I'm not I'm not sure I understand
what the question was but uh I would
refer to the
chair no I I didn't mean to stop you
from you know responding I just was I'm
not I'm not sure I understood what if
there was a question as opposed to a
comment which the representative's
certainly entitled to
make I will refer to the chair's
interpretation of this of the uh the
words used by the
representative other question
representative Smith yes thank you very
much
um I'm very pleased to
hear that
the I've been a little confused about
pronouns I mean when you say we I'm not
sure whether you be the state or the
municipal Association but I know you're
speaking to the municipal Association
and I'm pleased to hear you talk about
how important you think it is for people
to have access to records and including
um
electronic records I'm not sure how that
meshes with the information that was
presented to this committee on the two
other bills that are somewhat in the
same Basket in which um we have copies
for example of something that quotes the
municipal Association saying to the town
of new durm not Durham but new durm that
um
paper
copies can be required and can be
charged for at at certain rates I'm not
quoting I don't have it in front of me
but I guess I need to know if it is in
fact a statement of Municipal of um the
organization's policy of encouraging
all the municipalities that do all the
municipalities Belong by the way yes
they do ma'am okay um I thought so but I
just wanted to check that to encourage
them to move to electronic
recordkeeping well it seems to me that
the policy of the legislature has been
to encourage electronic recordkeeping
for instance there have been recent
Provisions passed about um posting
meeting minutes on the website um about
um other Provisions related to to you
know uh that type of
accessibility um you know there was
certainly an unfortunate
miscommunication uh at one of our
trainings um that I prefer not to speak
about um that has since been corrected
um
but what it it it appears that is the
general direction that the legislature
is moving in that society's moving in is
is this type of of Records access and
keeping um and certainly other leg
legislation has been discussed about
electronic records requests um and
everything else and so what seems to
make sense is to try to engage with the
uh the stakeholders and discuss with
them about you know what we can do to
help um promote this type of
accessibility and I'm certainly happy to
share our policies on on the right to
know um bill with the committee if
that's helpful we have a very lengthy uh
policy on that um and it does emphasize
the importance of of providing
accessibility to records and continuing
to work with stakeholders to make sure
that those are available um as openly as
possible so my if I just be clear then
my you my question isn't what the
legislature wants or what the state
wants my question is to you representing
so adequately the the municipal
Association is the municipal
association's policy
to encourage all
municipalities to move towards
electronic um
recordkeeping our our policies to inform
municipalities about what the law is and
what their options are under that and to
provide them as much guidance as we can
as to the direction of the uh the state
thank you very much so uh I I can't help
um I I I can't help recalling the
testimony we heard earlier in some of
these right to know bills in which
um if I understand correctly some
official maybe even the council for the
City of Rochester thought it appropriate
to take the position that because
somebody who runs a newspaper in
Rochester but lives in Maine made the
request that person would was not
entitled to get the records because of
an interpret of the the the provision
that uses the term citizen of the
interpretation of the word citizen is my
understanding of the testimony that
strikes me as incredible I understand
the trial court um uh rejected that
position out of hand but now apparently
there's been an appeal to the Supreme
Court it it it it's that is amazing that
somebody could take that position I have
to say
I can't speak to any individual position
any of my members may
take other questions for this
witness representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question do you have data
available of how many
municipalities have their records
electronically already and how many do
everything manually
I don't have specific data on that what
I will say is most municipalities
have some sort of cutof date where
they've started transitioning um for the
larger municipalities so if they've
started taking minutes electronically
and posting them to the website often
times it'll be you know they started
doing that in 2006 or whatever
everything before then is paper they
haven't necessarily gone back and
digitized those some have um it's kind
of all over the board at the moment
as I think follow up yeah follow follow
up one
more
um when a municipality if this went
through and they went on to the
state for their records how far back is
a m municipality going to go I mean they
may have been in existence for two two
300 years and they may have records in
their boxes are they going to have to
put all that anding Bring It
Forward um so the obviously they have to
still comply with the provisions of 33
a3a for what has to be kept as paper
regardless whether you digitize it um
but honestly I think that question is
better for representative yella because
I believe he's been one of the most
zealous individuals in terms of scanning
and digitizing records from his
municipality and I don't know how far
back he has gone but I'm guessing he
probably has the record for that well if
you know I isn't I'm wondering is
correct me if I'm wrong but wouldn't the
short answer to the question be
municipalities wouldn't h under this
bill wouldn't have to go back it's
completely up to them whether it's a COR
correct whether it's a digitize any of
them it would be a local option um and
that's why I would imagine that what
you'd see first is something like you
know any municipality opting in would
transition first to hey we're going to
put all of our board's minutes up there
that seems to be working well it seems
to be useful we're getting feedback from
the community what do we do next and
kind of phase in and then as they look
to do something like uh for example the
police department I used to work at we
had an entire records room if we were
able to digitize that we could use that
for some something El that space for
something else um so as they look to you
know repurpose rooms or whatever the
whatever the policy is the local level
um that would be when you'd see them dig
tie some of those older
records other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Ashley Miller please from the Secretary
of State's
office good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Ashley Miller I'm the New Hampshire
State archist under the Secretary of
State's office I support this
legislation as the Director of archives
and Records management for the state our
division is often sought out by
municipalities for answers to their
records related questions as you know
New Hampshire is home to over 200
municipalities each with their own
unique records challenges a local
government records manager plays a
crucial role in ensuring efficient
recordkeeping this role will allow us to
reach every municipality to promote and
implement
systematic organization preserve the
historic records they do have and train
them on digitization and metadata
standards this not only streamlines our
recordkeeping processes Statewide but it
allows us for quick retrieval of
information this bill does not create
any new positions within the Secretary
of State's office but it does fund a
current position a position that's
currently unfunded with the funding of
this position we can better serve all of
our municipalities by providing in
Outreach training best practices and a
convenient digital repository where
their records can be both preserved and
accessible to the public archives are
arsenals of accountability we strive to
preserve the historical record to
promote government
transparency increased access to records
for the public allows citizens to
monitor government activities and
exercise their rights as informed
participants in the
Democracy archives play a pivotal role
in cultivating and informed citiz R
which is essential for the functioning
of a healthy democracy this bill is a
step toward access thank you to the
committee for allowing me the
opportunity to speak and I'm happy to
take any questions questions for this
witness representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you
know how many of our
municipalities comply with the law and
have presently government records
manages thank you for your question I do
not um currently we have municipalities
who reach out to me every day in terms
of their records related questions
whether it's retention whether it's
access whether it's preservation but but
no thank you you're welcome other
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank
you I don't have any other cards on the
non gerain amendment to uh house bill
1696 is there anyone else who wishes to
testify regarding um Amendment
2024 0237 H to House Bill
1696 seeing none and do we have a it's
an amendment all right all right seeing
none I'm going to close the hearing on
uh House Bill 1696 and I'm happy to
report that we are in recess uh for a
half an hour for lunch
go
for
all
right is all
ready Jeff are you are you good okay all
right all right right it's um it's now
102 and um I'm going to uh call the
Judiciary Committee uh back into uh
session and I'm uh going to open the
hearing on House Bill
1432 and uh recognize uh the prime
sponsor representative
grion thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee that are are here those
that will be here a little bit later
will probably be falling asleep during
the the after this is the worst slot to
be in for any speech or time it's right
after lunch so I I appreciate your time
and if your eyelids are still open when
I'm done God bless
you so the bill that is before you is
designed to try to get ahead of if it's
even possible now
advancements in technology in the area
of artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence uh is not uh somebody who's
not as smart as they appear such as
me uh artificial intelligence is is a
development in computer uh
technology it is uh taken Mega leaps
over the last few years be it Computing
speed and capacity
and it is branching out into areas of of
video and audio robotics uh they're
literally talking about AI replacing
people in numerous
Industries because it has the capacity
or the capability of
selflearning um it can uh if it's
designed there are several uh different
program or or applications out there
that are being test driven for different
uh different
reasons but one of the things that one
area where AI has been in use for quite
some time and is is becoming very
dangerous is in video and audio and
they're called Deep fakes I can take
your likeness and this has been around
for for for several years now much more
than audio but I can take your likeness
and produce a video showing you doing
something whatever it may be it could
just
be something silly and innocent to
something quite devious or
illegal it's not you actually doing it
but it is an image of you that I've
created using a computer program or this
artificial
intelligence but I can also take your
voice and all I need is 3 seconds of
your actual voice and now I I can
replicate that to make you say anything
I want you to say though you didn't say
it and it becomes dangerous when for
example I take an image of say my high
school
classmate make her naked doing something
that would be embarrassing and then I
put that on the web or share that on
social media or something like that and
those kinds of incidents have already
started to happen
the girls didn't do what these videos
showed them doing but because their
likeness was used and using a program
there are programs that can just take a
still image of anybody and they call it
nud toying just take a photo of you and
now at the artificial intelligence the
program can take off all your clothes
and show what you would look like
naked that would be embarrassing enough
but what if I could now take your image
or your likeness and show you
and your voice and show you committing a
crime it's not just an embarrassing
thing it is now you conducting a
criminal a behavior but that wasn't you
now you're stuck having to prove your
innocence instead of proving your guilt
everyone's going to see that video that
lie will get out around the world and
embarrass you and shock you maybe it
might cause you to be arrested and
thrown in jail prosecuted in some
capacity for something you did not
do but by the time that the truth gets
out you're already you're already
hindered from being able to maybe uh
make a living or something like that and
so what this bill is attempting to do is
to penalize or or to to to to prohibit
the use of this AI
technology for the purpose of harming
doing some kind of harm to someone else
whether that harm is reputational harm
because even reputational harm can cause
you to lose if they say you're a
physician and now you lose patience
because they see this AI generated video
of you or audio of you doing something
that now now you're going to lose
customers or you're a contractor or
you're an attorney or maybe you're
running for reelection and your
opponents decide that they're going to
put something together and show you
doing something you didn't do now you're
not going to get elected because of that
now $200 a year or $200 $100 a year
salary isn't much to to sneeze about
here but you all have reputations and
you'd like to keep your reputation but
if somebody comes along and sulles your
reputation through a lie through a deep
fake well that person should be should
be punished for doing that that should
not be tolerated and no it's not just
well that's just politics for you no
that person is seeking to damage you in
some Capac
capacity and so this this bill seeks to
create a penalty for the use of these
deep fakes in harming somebody
reputationally financially or in in an
attempt to entrap them in some kind of a
crime to get them arrested or prosecuted
in some way and then also a private
right of action where there may not have
been a criminal act done they didn't uh
film you committing a crime or or they
didn't create a video showing you
committing a crime but it was something
uh and and it was just brought to my
attention this morning walking in uh
even billionaire pop stars are uh uh are
subject to these deep fakes I guess
Taylor Swift there was a video of her
which wasn't actually her but somebody
created a deep fake showing Taylor Swift
in provocatively a new a porn
pornographic video or something along
those lines and so uh you know that's
not something that some even a pop star
should have to shake it off that is
something that you and I have to deal
with going forward are we going to wait
until there's a trail of bodies before
we address it or are we going to get out
ahead of it and say no we're not going
to allow the use of AI for those
purposes there will be a cost to it and
so the private right of action would
allow Miss Swift to find out who did
that and go after them in that regard
because the the making of pornographic
images is not
illegal but if you're creating a
reputational harm and it's not actually
her then she can go after you for doing
it so that's what this bill does uh and
it it protects everybody because lying
about somebody and doing reputational
harm to somebody is not free
speech that's all I have questions for
this witness representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question I find
this very interesting that you bringing
this forward and I appreciate you
bringing it Forward because being a Law
and Order fan or
fan I just watched a program La last
week where they Ed this
technology to literally convict a man
for a crime that he did not commit they
use the technology and they kept saying
well he was left-handed but you're
showing him shooting with his right hand
they there was no way to prove that it
wasn't him so I appreciate this coming
forward because I immediately had the
discussion of what's to stop that to
happen to
anybody um
so I think the the charges or the
amounts or the penalties that you have
as far as I'm personally what made you
choose them they seem very low to
me well I
think in in in my mind I guess
the what what would people go for and
what it should it be uh there are times
when when you think a little Street
Justice is all that is needed um and
there was a time in our history where
you might you
know you you just took care of things um
we don't live in those we don't live in
those times anymore and
uh and so I look at like if you are
going to make an image a video of
somebody committing a crime and the
sentence of that crime is 10 years in
prison the person didn't do this crime
you made a video showing this person
doing a crime that carries a 10year
sentence to it so you should do the 10
years instead now that was my thinking
that's involved with it now whether or
not we can make that fly I don't know if
we need to amend the bill to say well
you get a slap on the wrist the first
time and three strikes and you're out
you know that's not Justice anymore
either and so why bother but there needs
to be a penalty for doing this sort of
thing because real people are going to
get really hurt by really nefarious
people using a very powerful weapon uh
this is a weapon it's a tool that's the
problem most tools are also weapons
that's why the game of Clue has
candlesticks ropes and pipes and not
just shotguns and poison pills so
everything that is a tool is also a
weapon and so these These are it's it's
very dangerous technology while at the
same time being very useful technology
thank you other questions for this
witness yes representative Manos thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
grien for taking my question I wanted to
ask you about the qu the uh definition
of deep fake and it said deep fake it
says deep fake means audio video or
audio that is generated with the end
goal of portraying something that did
not actually occur in reality correct
and it seems to me that that definition
would um that the only thing that that
it would limit it to docu mentaries that
unless something is a
documentary it becomes a deep fake and I
just wondered about your reaction to
that in order to define the terms I had
to do a search for common definitions
that would be recognized throughout the
shall we say the industry or the public
How would how would a deep fake be
defined and so those are not original
words with me uh that was how it just as
the same as artificial intelligence how
do you define what artificial
intelligence is those are those are
terms within the industry those people
who are actually developing those uh the
technology that's how they describe what
artificial intelligence is and so a deep
fake the the the term is is defined what
I have defined in there is taken from a
a broadly accepted definition of what a
deep fake is and the whole intent of the
deep fake is to portray
something that did not
happen it's it's it's showing something
that's it's it's a lie it's
fiction but the the it can it can be
though it is fiction it can be applied
as a weapon to try to to harm somebody
so we we know that Guardians of the
Galaxy is a fictional
story but if I could take something if
if it were limited to just fantasy we
wouldn't have this discussion but if I
can make it look like you've done
something that you didn't do that is
called a deep fake there are there are
images I I could take I could take your
face and put it on Fabio's body and make
it look like he did something haha
that's all funny look at look at me but
if I show
you robbing a
bank then that's different that is now
showing something that did not actually
take place but portraying it as being
something that did take place and
there's the
problem yeah uh yes
certainly um there are a number of this
this General topic of AI um and concerns
that come out of AI has been raised in a
number of committees a number of bills
before different committees and
different definitions of deep fake and
artificial intelligence and wondering um
whether you would be willing to work
with the language so that we can
reconcile it with other definitions of
AI and deep fake that are coming through
other committees and other bills we need
consistency within the law and so if we
need to make sure that the definitions
are adequate and accurate uh then by all
means we need to change the language so
that it is well understood again the
underlying premise of a deep fake is it
is fake
it is portraying something that did not
happen but promoting it or or or showing
it as being something that did happen
and so the the emphasis is on the word
fake and that's why it's very D so yes
we can always craft the language to be
to to be uh uh a
better a better understanding of what
we're talking about but the
understanding must be that it is a fake
and so that's that's
I guess that's the most important part
of it yeah other questions for this
witness yes representative Alexander and
then representative
Divine thank you Mr chair thank you
representative this is so fascinating
for me I love this area like learning it
and it's so new it's like almost scary
at like how much we don't know about AI
yet I guess my my question comes down
to like
it talks about any person injured like
the damages component of it but what
happens if it's the computer that causes
the damage not an individual is the
individual that made the computer liable
I guess I'm like I see AI evolving into
this thing where no humans have to
interact with it it just starts making
stuff right so what happens when we have
an RSA or a law at this point that says
something like this I I know there's a
lot of work need to be done but like
what happens next when when does AI
become a sentient being supposedly we
cross the
Rubicon um at that point in time I
should probably think we should pray for
the end of the world to happen um but
because right now it takes somebody
initiating some human being has to
initiate this deep fake they they it
somebody needs to sit down and say I
want the frame representative Alexander
I want to prevent him from getting
reelected uh I want him actually where
his neighbors seek to Tar and feather
him and run him out of town so that g
town is no longer his place of residency
wherever he works he's not going to he's
going to get fired from there or forced
to quit his job and by goly if we can
drive him out of New Hampshire that
would be even better and you know what
if we can just find an you know a grave
somewhere and Pitch him in there that's
fine too whatever the end result is that
they seek there's a human being at the
beginning of it seeking some nefarious
end to you
and so right now that's where we are how
we go beyond that where does the AI
decide I don't like representative
Alexander they've already hated me first
so I I'm pretty sure I'm the first one
to be in the in that unmarked grave so
um I I don't know that we could ever
answer that
question I representative Divine thank
you Mr speaker thank you rep gon for
taking my question um um I'm super
excited that you're putting this bill
together I think this is much needed
with in in light of some of the things
that are coming up with AI um one of the
things that I'm wondering if this will
address or if it's too soon to say is
what you have a creator of say a deep
fake or digital
forgery and it goes out viral on say a
distributor's site like say Tik Tok
Twitter Facebook meta whatever um this
kind of recently happened in in in two
two weeks one audio and one video
portion um that affected um some very
prominent
people how would this Bill affect the
Distributors say like Twitter who you
know it's up on their platform like it
recently happened would they be
accountable for Distributing that type
of content it's a good question actually
and unfortunately up to this point well
fortunately or unfortunately I'm not
sure which one um they are not
Publishers that's explicitly stated in
in in in in federal law they're covered
from liability I think it's section 230
they are not Publishers they are
platforms and as long as they maintain
that distinction then they are not
liable to what is posted on their
platforms and that's where all the
censorship comes in I don't like you so
I'm going to block all your content that
sort of thing
uh this bill does not address the
platform so Twitter cannot be held or X
cannot be held accountable for what you
post on there you will be so that's
that's the if it would require
alterations to to section 230 at the
federal level to to address that
unfortunately representative
tur yeah thanks Mr chair and thanks for
taking the question so I was focused on
um on page two the the difference uh s
sizable difference between the damages
described when this is used against um
any individual versus when it's used for
um essentially political purposes and
you know know it's $10 million cap on on
uh damages to people and essentially a
$5,000 penalty um for using this for
political purposes
um uh I was wondering why why that big
disparity I mean we've it seems like the
political realm is where this is already
we've seen used um why is that so much
lower
I don't have the bill sitting in front
of me to know what the exact wording is
the
the I believe it would actually be it
starts at
5,000 yeah I the the phrase I'm looking
at and it it's in the section that talks
about using it for um to Def defeat a
Party U measure or person in any
election it says a violation of this
section shall result in a civil penalty
of $5,000 per violation um and then it
goes on to have um you know that you can
recover actual damages or $1,000
whichever is greater and those numbers
seem very low given the um the the
utility of this kind of tool in that
realm yeah the I mean we could always
increase the penalties um the idea being
that um one political party could not do
one of these deep fakes against an
opponent uh trying to smear their
reputation again through doing some kind
of of harm and then just under the guise
of well that's just
politics um a lot of times politicians
are not are not covered or protected by
slander uh they're not protected from
other attacks against them and so this
is a means of protecting even
politicians they should be protected as
well because a lie is just as damaging
to a politician as it is any other
private citizen you don't forfeit your
rights just because you run for
political office and so there needs to
be protection for them
um
the so any person injured by another's
violation of this section may bring an
action for damages and for Equitable
relief including an injunction as the
court deems necessary uh and proper and
then it says the actual damages of
$1,000 actual damages or $1,000 which is
greater and so uh the court will
determine the
the the the section that says damage is
awarded under the section shall not
exceed $10 million per
claim is in this is in the section above
that so if the fraud fraudulent use of
AI led to the loss of employment damages
totaling twice a person's salary for the
duration of the unemployment not to
exceed one year shall be awarded if
you're fired because of this then
there's awards for that but the overall
amount of Damages in your civilian in
your in your
private
claim is no is limited to $10 million
okay in the political
field it
is the the actual damages of $1,000
actual damages or a th000 so the minimum
is
$1,000 you know if they're it but you
you would be protected in both uh in in
both ways you're running you're running
for office but you're also Mr
T and so you have protection because you
have a job that you work if if that
affects your job you have that portion
if it affects your ability in in office
it affects this and so you're protected
in both but your actual damages under
just the political section of it are
going to be minimally uh uh minimal
compared to your private life so I I I I
have no problem with with increasing
penalties um if that's if that's what we
need to do um but the the portion that
is that
is I guess I should say the most
significant or the most important part
of this bill is the private right of
action that if you are harmed personally
you have a right of action to that can I
just quick follow up on that um and and
I just wanted to make it clear I do not
dispute either of those instances it's
just when I look at the the the section
down below about um using this for
political purposes it seems as though
the the levels that are set could be
seen almost as the cost of doing
business for the modern political
campaign I mean you know $5,000 is is
you know unfortunate but it's a drop in
the bucket for what some of these
campaigns do and and I'm not sure how
you would calculate the damages right
you know if say somebody puts out a
statement you know that makes it sound
like you said something you didn't which
we just saw recently happen yep
yeah again I I have no issues with with
bumping up the penalties for that um my
my objective was to make sure that no
this is not just
politics and
so other questions for this
Witness seeing none thank
you
next let me just make sure we
don't we don't have any
reps
sorry all right um do there any do we
have
any anybody else wish to testify on 1432
yes
please
thank
you yes
please good afternoon Mr Speaker members
of the committee my name is Tamara
Hester I am a lieutenant with the New
Hampshire State Police I am assigned to
the special investigations unit with
where in our unit we investigate cyber
crimes child exploitation and we conduct
digital forensics not necessarily here
speaking in uh opposition or support of
this bill in general I just wanted to
bring up a couple of the concerns uh
that some of them have already been
brought up by other members of the
committee already about some of the
language as the bill as it is currently
currently written
um I was
hoping basically it's important that as
law enforcement in order to enforce the
laws we actually understand the law as
it stands uh paragraph 3 the way that
it's written which would be on page
actually would be page one of the bill
as it stands um and I'm not sure if the
sponsor can elaborate a little bit on
that it's just the language is a little
bit confusing as a law enforcement
officer I'm having difficulty
understanding what uh that might mean in
order to enforce that law if it I guess
an example of what I'm thinking in my
head and I'm hoping maybe we could get
maybe a clearer definition would be if
somebody uses a deep fake if somebody
wiretapped an individual in order to get
their voice to use that likeness in
order to commit the offense using
artificial intelligence is that kind of
what that paragraph is intended is
intended to mean that's uh one of the
concerns I certainly um agree with um
the sponsor as well as the members of
this Committee in the sense that it's
really important that we as a state get
ahead of artificial intelligence because
unfortunately it is being used to
exploit individuals online across many
different platforms so I don't disagree
with that in any sense um but there's a
couple other laws that are already on
the books that um as one of the sponsors
mentioned uh excuse me one of the
representatives mentioned um have
similar language being introduced uh
this this year to talk about um C
combating artificial intelligence some
of those other bills use uh synthetic
images I think as a definition obviously
that doesn't uh Encompass the whole of
this statute as the fact that audio
recordings could also be included so it
may need to be broader but I do
definitely agree with uh potentially
modifying the definition so that is a
little more um Limited in
scope that and there's a few other
statutes already that I understand
certainly having a penalty for this but
it doesn't necessarily the penalty for
this as it stands doesn't necessarily um
match up to some of the other penalties
that exist that are similar specifically
um where this is going in 638 so we have
harassment uh which falls under 6 RS say
6 38 violation of privacy uh which falls
under 644 and criminal defamation which
falls under 644 but all of those are
misdemeanors so this would be a felony
so it just the penalty of this crime
doesn't necessarily marry up with some
of the other statutes that are that are
similar to it so those are really just
some of the um concerns that that I
wanted to address and I think um one of
the other Representatives brought up
where where the origin is it so is it
the if any body who subsequently
disseminates this deep fake are they
also going to to be guilty of the same
crime or is it intended to be the
originator of the uh deep fake that is
the uh person who's going to be held
responsible all right questions for this
witness seeing none thank
you um is there anyone
else um who wishes to
appear um on hb1 1432 and I should know
we have um we have a letter uh received
from Timothy Wilkerson of the New
England connectivity and
Telecommunications
Association um does everybody which I
passed out so uh then that's in
opposition to uh to the bill um I don't
have any other uh pin cards anyone else
who wishes to be heard on House Bill
1432 and I should note that there are uh
from the signup sheet there are six
people in support and three people
opposed
um all right seeing no one else who has
uh any interest in in testifying I'm
going to close the hearing on House Bill
1432 and it looks like we have uh a few
minutes before we
begin uh the bill of the hearing on 1475
so we'll take a
yeah that's good so you know what
um um I'm where are we here um 12 12:45
right so you know what um oops my link
comes back
um G we're going to exact
12:45 okay soon as Scott gets back no
coming to oh okay
great I'm happy to make the motion and
do the report if you want to have the
report time
okay sounds great she'll make the motion
I have the report from last time so I'm
happy to do it and use the same report
we used last time okay all right so have
we got who's we waiting for oh there's
Joe okay all right um all right so I'm
going to uh since we have a few minutes
um I'm going to uh uh reconvene the
Judiciary Committee uh for an executive
session with regard to House Bill
1245 um I've conferred with the ranking
member and we both agree uh that this uh
that this bill can be exact now um
the uh as as we heard from the testimony
this is
exactly word for word a bill that we
passed out of this committee last time
and actually it passed the Full House La
the last time um it it died in the other
body um so uh um I think it's entirely
appropriate that we exact uh this bill
now in the interest of of you know
moving our business along as
as quickly as possible so um do I have
I'm going to recognize representative
katab for a motion I move on to pass is
there is there second representative
Smith second um uh any further
discussion
or I think we've P you know we went
through this the last time and we
amended it as needed and I think that
it's ready to move forward right any any
further discussion on how House Bill
1245 represent wh yes representative
Perez I just want to state that the
information that was brought forward by
the woman from the committee um I think
she had some very valid things that that
group should have been involved with
this from from day one since they are
the PE the keepers or the of of this
group of individuals so I just think
that I just don't think we should um
discard the fact that she had some
extremely valid points in the fact that
they should have been involved and it
was a mistake that they weren't
involved right I'm sorry representative
Alexander um and I happen to disagree
with my friend um I think that because
these meetings we've been talking about
this bill for a year these meetings have
been all public and I believe if there's
something a department or a committee or
somebody that would like to be involved
the onus is on them to get involved in
the process early on I think it's it
startles me that when somebody comes in
and no offense if she did not know or
the organization didn't know but comes
in at the fifth hour to come in and
raise concerns it's a way to defeat a
bill that might be that is a good bill
and we've we vetted it carefully to the
committee any representative Perez
representative Alexander I respect your
opinion right all right um any other
discuss uh representative
trip uh I believe it was you that said
if she really wants to be involved in in
uh the discussion she can always go to
the Senate since they're going to hear
it also so I think that uh our moving
the bill along is a good idea thank you
any other discussion on
House Bill 1245 seeing none I would ask
the clerk to please call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk tab votes yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith
yes yes rep Divine yes rep
Anza
yes R Manos yes rep tur
yes chairman Lynn yes motion passes 15
to
zero uh and representative kop would you
uh write the
report I assume we can put this on
consent happy too yeah all right great
all right
um I'm sorry you said said 15 to
zero all
right still have uh a couple of minutes
no I don't uh I don't think
so no I don't think
so just
in unless unless Ming gets the
uh Amendment back
12 right yeah I mean if he yeah I don't
know where he is on that but yeah that's
possibility we could we could do that if
he gets it
back
all right uh it's now past 1:45 so I'm
going to uh open the hearing on uh House
Bill
1475 and do we have the prime sponsor
here I hope ah Prime SP yes please on
up Travis Quirk uh repres presed from
Hillsboro 44 U my thanks to the chair
and to the committee um I'll be fairly
brief uh to explain the problem is to
sort of suggest the solution the concept
of slap or strategic lawsuit against
public
participation is a lawsuit that is not
designed to actually accomplish its
stated goals but is intended as a
strategic move in a greater game which
is influencing public
policy so um examples of when this might
happen have uh occurred in a lot of
areas um across the country and this is
sort of a non-political issue which is
to say that it's both a left and a right
problem so you might have um for example
a anti-act farming activist who is
speaking about conditions in a factory
farm and they will get sued by the
factory farm for a lot of issues uh such
as defamation or you know other things
and the goal is not actually to um you
know a normal defamation lawsuit of of
actually seeking to recover um things
the actual goal is to chill speech and
this works both in the primary way um
against the actual person who's being
sued but in a secondary way of um
setting an example for the others so you
know the next activist who comes along
thinks do I really want to take a second
mortgage on my house for $100,000 so
that I can afford to mount a defense
against some multi-billion dollar firm
uh that's a example that would you know
hopefully get the sympathies of those
left of
center but this can also work in the
other direction where a pastor running a
small church out of his garage uh could
get sued for statements that he makes
that go against some large corporation
or large NGO with a huge budget and this
is not a theoretical problem um there
have been hundreds of such lawsuits uh
and this has happened you know for
decades and the fact that it's happened
has given rise to a you know solution to
the problem which is anti-s slap
legislation New Hampshire is in the
minority there you know obviously 50
states and I believe 32 of them already
have anti-ap legislation there are
several groups that publish uh reference
standards and this proposed uh
legislation uh has been you know
designed with reference to these other
things that have been through the
crucibles of multiple States
legislatures and committees the goal is
basically or the mechanism of an anti-s
slap uh bill is basically to uh Empower
as a defense against these things that
you know hey I'm actually uh the the uh
Speech I'm engaged in is uh political
speech um and your lawsuit against it is
designed as a political act so the goal
is really to um refuse uh the larger you
know um Rich entities whether it's a
for-profit corporation or a very large
NGO um to stop them from weaponizing the
courts against the sort of uh smaller uh
protester or church owner uh or you know
gun store owner Etc and um I have uh
testifying after me a friend and
compatriot attorney Mark rzza who has
been very active in free speech issues
for a long time so uh for any detailed
questions uh I might say you know please
talk to the expert um but I'd be happy
to answer general
questions questions for this witness yes
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question so in the town I
live in we had a horrendous incident um
that ended up with a judge writing a 12
page slap on the hands to the people who
brought this lawsuit against this person
so is this going to protect the little
guy too you talked about Corp that is
entirely the goal it is protect the
little guy against the multi-billion
dollar firms well not only multi-billion
dollar film this was a municipality that
okay you know and and that's I always
say I'm here for the little
guy that's what we need this for and
this will protect
them from doing absolutely and uh to to
go meta for just a moment if you look at
my bio on the general court website the
reason I'm here in this room and wearing
a suit as opposed to my normal t-shirt
is because I was in something very
similar uh just absolutely brutalized uh
by the good old boys network in my town
where law was used as a weapon where my
budget came out of you know my pocket
and their budget came out of the
taxpayers so we're on exactly the same
side well
fortunately this judge made the 10 pay
for hers too so that's wonderful I'm
glad that uh some stories even if not
mine have a happy ending
yeah other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you for your time well you know
I'm sorry I have one question this you
said that there are 32 states that have
anti-s slap bills is the in drafting
this bill is this based on the language
of those other state bills and if I'm
going to have to look to my coach for a
hint
yes all right thank you thank you right
uh next I'm going to call
um uh Mark uh Ren asking
please okay yep turn the microphone
thank you there we go I'd like to start
uh by answering a a couple of your
questions in a little more detail
representative Paige your qu oh I'm
sorry I'm I'm sorry I'm not from here
and I'm looking at the uh the angle
there representative Perez this anti-s
slap law is I think the best one that
has been proposed that will protect the
little guy um I study these uh
Nationwide I do anti-s slap litigation
Nationwide as well as plaintiff side uh
defamation cases
Nationwide uh and a great example of one
that does not protect the little guy is
for example Florida which was written by
lobbyists for the motion picture
industry and it protects motion picture
uh producers and uh Publishers of books
and Publishers of newspapers but if you
were to write a negative review of a
hotel or something like that and got
sued for it that is not a work under the
statute so you wouldn't be protected um
the other way the little guy gets stuck
in a lot of these laws is there are uh
Forum Shopping tricks you can engage in
in order to evade a good anti-s slap law
so I have defended people who get sued
in another state where for example the
plaintiff in one case I'm working on is
in Colorado they have a very good not a
great but very good anti-sap law he made
sure to find another jurisdiction that
didn't have one to sue in so the poor
guy getting SU is now looking at I
should be protected by an anti-s slap
law here because it's supposed to limit
how somebody engages in a in a tort but
it doesn't work that way um and then uh
Mr chair you asked if this was based on
the other anti-s slap laws it's based on
two it has really two genetic strains to
it one is the prevailing I'd say Central
finite curve of anti-sap laws what it
protects but also in assisting uh
representative corkin with this I
brought a body of 20 odd years of
litigation experience saying these are
the places where other states have had
problems or where there have been uh
failures in the anti-sap law an example
is uh Mr surami who's going to testify
later I believe is from Connecticut
Connecticut's did not establish the
right to an interlocutory appeal very
well so it does exist now because Mr
sarami brilliantly handled the case in
front of the Connecticut Supreme Court
that then established that however here
you've taken care of that uh this bill
really takes look the first amendment is
to me uh practically a religion uh it's
a promise that we have the right to
engage in wide openen and robust
debate however that promise is ephemeral
if you do have to say you know I
remember there was a quote from Henry
loose that said if you want a free press
go ahead and buy one
well if you want free speech go ahead
and buy it you know the the thing that
inspired me to get involved in this kind
of thing was uh my my really my very
first case I ever handled all on my own
as a lawyer and there I was with a you
know ink still wet on my law license
defending a guy against a huge Law Firm
that had sued him because he put up a
website complaining about the plants
that his homeowners association had put
up and saying that he found that they
were ugly
now that shouldn't put anybody in a
courtroom or have anybody writing checks
to a lawyer but the developer had a big
ego and decided he wanted to shut down
all descent and so we fought this big
Law Firm it was in Florida we fought for
a little over a year and boy was I proud
when I got the ruling that I had won and
I called him up ready to celebrate he
said that's great kid if I won why is my
retirement fund empty and uh you know
boy was is that a a a real life lesson
for a young lawyer they don't teach you
that in law school that uh you know the
real cost that can hurt somebody if
somebody just brings a frivolous claim
now the way that this bill is drafted
it's going to create also one of the
things that it does that a lot of the
other ones don't is really just
stylistic but it will work for to a
great function and it separates your
procedural parts from your substantive
parts
uh California's is really the uh the the
OG of anti-s slap laws um after
California passed it Washington Oregon
Nevada all followed Texas and as
representative corkin said about 32
states have one but you have a trend in
the federal courts of not applying state
anti-sap laws anymore uh I frankly think
that the argument is foolish but uh it
has taken hold
that these laws are procedural and not
substantive and that's because they run
into one procedural element and the
court says the whole thing is procedural
well this disambiguates the substance
from the procedure uh procedurally
speaking it may stop for example stop
Discovery in its
tracks you can't legislate that in a
federal court that's in the procedural
section so if a federal court is looking
at a lawsuit brought in violation of
this section the federal court will be
able to take that part and exclude it
but really what it does is it creates a
substantive immunity from suit and every
word in that sentence is is in that
phrase is doing work okay you want it to
be substantive you want this to be a
right that you are free from not just
liability because if you're just free
from
liability uh I can tell you that judges
are human beings uh they make mistakes
they have biases uh
sometimes they're they're downright
hostile but let's think of you know I
can think of a case that I handled where
I was before frankly I think the best
judge that that I know of um he's a
wonderful man a principled man and he
messed it up uh my client made a
complaint to the real estate board in
Nevada about her real estate agent uh
had treated her in a racist Manner and
he to retaliate filed a defamation
lawsuit
now there are two reasons why that just
can't be one whether somebody's racist
to you or not as a matter of opinion and
two it's privileged if you're
complaining in an official proceeding it
didn't matter didn't matter to him and
you know the trial judge uh I've never
seen him make a mistake before but
everybody's human he made a mistake now
she would never have been able to defend
herself without the Nevada anti-s slap
law in place so what this does is not
only does it give you a remedy but it
creates an Avenue to access to justice
that poor people frankly don't have you
know I get calls every day for people
who are being sued for speaking out and
when it's in a state that I'm not
licensed in I I call somebody in my
network and I say do you want to take
this person and they their first
question is can they afford a
retainer and the vast majority of people
can't but in States where there's an
anti-s slap law I have people fighting
to take the case I mean imagine any any
place else where you could have poor
people getting fought over by somebody
who makes hundreds and sometimes over
,000 an hour to be their
client so if you have any uh specific
questions about the bill you know I've
looked through it uh I think that it it
makes a uh it makes a very good balance
it frankly I will say it's not the
strongest one that I've ever seen uh
Washington state had one before that
required
uh clear and convincing evidence in
order to get past it rather than mere
Prima fascia evidence that was ruled in
Washington to be a violation of that
State's uh right to trial by jury so it
was frankly a little too high test um
this one has been dialed back from that
standard to be similar to a summary
judgment standard so that you don't have
that problem um and the other
perspective I'd like to make sure that
you you have going into this is um last
year I would say despite me sitting here
you know waving my first amendment
bonafides the majority of my income last
year came from plaintiff's side
defamation cases I am agnostic if
somebody has been defamed somebody has
had their reputation damaged uh and they
have a supportable claim I have neither
fear nor embarrassment of taking one of
those cases and in fact I love taking
them in states with anti- slap laws they
do not create a speed bump for anybody
except for I would say uh lawyers who do
not know enough to look at a case and
say you should not bring this so foolish
lawyers um and unethical lawyers who may
take one and say it doesn't matter let's
do it
anyway but I think that this bill will
take if you look at the institute for
free speeches map of anti-s slap law
rankings uh right now New Hampshire has
uh is red on that map it has an f um and
while uh my native state of
Massachusetts may be the Cradle of
Liberty this is where Liberty
lives so uh I think that you should pass
this law in order to ensure that and if
you have any questions for me about it
uh I could talk about this all day
long questions for this witness
representative ter yeah just briefly
thanks for bringing a wealth of
knowledge um can I just ask are you uh
here on your own behalf or are you with
this particular group no I I am just
here as uh Johnny apples
seed other questions for this witness
representative
maners thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm an
attorney but I don't practice in this
area I don't do civil litigation well I
do divorces but anyway my question is
why a motion for summary judgment or a
motion to dismiss shouldn't end most of
the
cases well they very well could um and
if but here are the two problems one if
I were to take a case here and file a
motion to dismiss um that's not cheap
it's not free summary judgment same
thing but also if you have a substantive
immunity from suit what happens when you
have a a motion to dismiss that's denied
well the case goes forward so all you
need to do is plead it out uh if you
have summary judgment that's denied
that's not reviewable in an
interlocutory basis so what winds up
happening is look judges are human
beings and if you can look at a case and
say I can make a reviewable decision and
rule in favor of the defendant on
summary judgment or I can make a
non-reviewable decision and say or at
least not reviewable until the very end
and deny it well then that litigant is
still going along for the sixf figure
ride and perhaps that can be reversed on
appeal but
not very many civil litigants can
survive that
long representative
Smith um
um I think I'm a little
speechless
because every single thing you talked
about had a dollar
sign every single thing whether you take
a case whether you don't take a the case
whether you get money who pays it who
doesn't pay it
um so is this just about money and by
the way I do have to point out to you
since you're not from this state that at
least sitting on this committee is the
uh one person who was the former uh
Chief Justice of the New Hampshire
Supreme Court I'm not going to tell you
who but I just thought you might want to
be careful about what you say in the
future
um when they say it's not about the
money it's about the
money is there anything about this that
you would talk about that doesn't have
to do a bit with the money unfortunately
that's it's the fuel of litigation I
mean I look I certainly take pro bono
defense cases where it just wouldn't
matter if there was an anti-s slap at
least to the litigant it's free for them
anyway but money is the pressure that I
think a plaintiff who brings a slap suit
is going to use to bring to bear on that
defendant you if you think if that
defendant gets
sued they're going to think do I need to
mortgage my house to defend myself or
should I just shut up so I look at it
from that perspective but the money
eventually leads to whether or not we
have wide open and robust debate do we
have a real free speech ecosystem or not
so if somebody gets sued for something
like this for example the the gentleman
that I talked about in
Florida do you think anybody else at
that HOA ever spoke out again after
seeing what happened to him they didn't
not that I'm aware of uh the but you
know the woman who spoke up in Nevada
who was able to employ the anti-s slap
law to protect her uh that created an
ecosystem where people were happy to
speak up if they wanted to about
somebody being treated unethically so I
I do understand sometimes you know uh
there's more than just one lawyer on the
on the committee here you know I think
we uh perhaps sometimes we look at
things in dollars and cents too much as
lawyers you know you talk to a normal
human being about a spine injury and
everybody says oh that's terrible and a
lawyer might go oh that's a good injury
uh looking at it as a uh as as how
expensive it might be of on a
contingency fee case but really it's all
about can somebody defend themselves
this is this is The Shield that allows a
regular person to be able to use their
free speech rights and not be worried
that they're going to be bankrupted just
by defending
themselves thank
you other questions so I I guess I I
want to make sure that I'm understanding
one part can you am I understanding
correctly that
the the essence of whether the immunity
applies or not is what the motivation of
the plaintiff in the case is no sir it
it is not um okay in fact Illinois had a
a law that looked to that the first
thing it looked to is what is the
motivation and if you can't prove that
if you couldn't prove that their
motivation was to silence somebody if
they were clever about it if they simply
pled it in the right way well then it
didn't apply effectively that turned
Illinois's old anti-sap law uh into
nothing more than words on paper it it
was really never used again once the
state supreme court interpreted it that
way so no it's the effect not the intent
so you may come into it with Innocent
intentions but that's not what free
speech is about is it we want we want to
protect the citizens right to speak and
if somebody simply brings the case
because they're angry I'm not trying to
shut them up I'm trying to express how
angry I am well that's that's what the
gentleman who was the plaintiff in that
uh real estate case said but what what
but if you're talking about I it sounded
like in your answer when you say I
brought the case because I was angry or
I brought the case because I wanted to
shut him up I mean isn't that a motive
issue what what was the intent in
bringing the case that's what I'm words
I'm to to go back to the example of the
the uh I think you the condominium I
think you said with the big developer in
Florida yes sir so the the the
condominium owner
says the plants here the plants in this
in this condominium are you know they're
terrible most awful plants I've ever
seen it's you know it's and we're paying
a huge monthly fee or whatever and this
is all we get there you know a bunch of
tulips I hate tulips or whatever they're
terrible and so the developer the owner
of the thing of the condom of the
condominium complex or the developer
whatever brings a suit against the
person for defamation correct so I I
guess what I'm I
mean I guess what I'm having some
difficulty is this if the if the to
determine whether the whether the suit
was brought because the developer really
was you know worried about his
reputation his reputation as a Bas based
on the on the uh the comments of of the
person who complained or was just trying
to silence the person
don't doesn't the judge have to decide
or doesn't somebody have to decide what
was the motivation for bringing the
lawsuit not under any existing anti-s
slap laws uh that that I'm aware of so
then what so what the then what does the
judge what does the judge make the
decision based on the first step the
judge makes is was the defendant
exercising a First Amendment right
that's just a simple yes or no and then
it is whether or not the case is really
to overly simplify it then the next step
is well then is this case supportable uh
you know it's it's somewhat whether or
not the plaintiff had purity of heart at
the time of filing it is irrelevant I
mean really you know if you look at any
case or really any conflict uh I think
every combatant every every person who
gets into a debate they always have an
an argument that no my heart is pure I'm
just defending my reputation as a
developer who's going to want want to
buy a unit here if my residents are
complaining and
discontent uh I think if you if you had
a judge weighing the relative
motivations of either party uh I don't
think first of all I don't I don't think
it would be constitutional to do so
second I wouldn't support an anti-ap law
that did that
you know cuz remember the first
amendment is not always there for nice
people either in fact uh you know the
most constitutional rights are uh are
fought on grounds involving not very
nice people um you know if you were to
think about gosh some of the worst
examples I can think of you know the
Snider versus Phelps when uh you know
poor guy was just trying to bury his kid
and somebody came out and had these
awful protest signs well do we look if
we look at the relative motivations I'd
say that the person with the awful
protest signs had the most ill
motivations but the first amendment is
agnostic as to your
feelings it's the function here that uh
that's really important okay so I'm just
I I I'm I I guess I'm looking on page
two of the bill subsection f it says the
immunity may only be overcome by a
showing by the
plaintiffs uh respondent or counter
plaintiffs that the claim or counter
claim is sufficient is of sufficient
merit with primacia evidence um there's
a
uh there's a probability of prevailing
on the claim or counter claim so I I
guess what I'm mean does that mean that
in my ex in the example of the
Tulips the the uh if the if the
developer does a developer have to show
the judge you know these tulips really
are good they really are very very
pretty does the judge does that is that
what the judge gets to decide on are the
Tulips really are they really pretty um
you're you're analyzing it improperly so
the way that the judge would look at it
first of all a judge doesn't ever
neither a judge nor a jury would ever
decide in a defamation case are the
Tulips pretty that's a matter of opinion
what the judge would say is this case
has been brought because the developer
is saying in his opinion the Tulips are
pretty in the defendant's opinion
they're not well there's no such thing
as a false idea there's no such thing as
a false opinion therefore as a matter of
law this case is dismissed with costs
and fees awarded to the defendant that's
how that case would have ended right
then and there if this law had been in
place in Florida at the time why doesn't
why doesn't the why under existing law
doesn't the case end for the ly those
reasons anyway if it did I neither I
wouldn't be here and this wouldn't have
happened in 32 other states it should uh
it seems almost Unthinkable if you
haven't been through this that this
would ever happen but I can tell you it
happens to people every day judges make
mistakes you know and let's even you
know you don't have elected judges here
in your state courts but let me tell you
if there's a 1200 lawyer firm arguing a
motion to dismiss in a place where
there's going to be a contested election
that judge May simply say denied and
that's all you get out of that judge um
now not saying you're going to have that
here in New Hampshire but your judges
are not perfect you got good judges here
but they're not perfect they make that
mistake that mistake is $100,000 or so
down Mr I don't like the tulip's throat
so when it comes to most of these cases
are brought over claims that as a matter
of law are
unsupportable just like you in your
example whether there's an opinion or
not uh if that's a matter of opinion
that case should be over right there not
proceed to Discovery not proceed pass
the motion to dismiss because they've
pled it well it's got to have at least
praasa evidence which is a low standard
uh and and it by Design it's a low
standard um and that standard comes from
uh multiple cases there there was one
challenging the California standard
which is that standard there was another
one that challenged Nevadas which is
that standard now and uh that's the new
standard in Washington and that actually
is the standard in uh I think every
state except
Arizona uh representative Manos thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question the example of the condo
development and the Tulips which we've
got going he only knew how famous he was
now yes so I want to know um where is
the governmental action that gets you to
the first amendment in that situation
well ever since New York Times versus
Sullivan in
1964 uh we have uh operated under the
theory that the government actions the
use of the courts in order to enforce
the private Tor of
defamation other questions for this
witness thank you very much sir
appreciate thank you
you uh
next I'm going to call Mario sarami
please Mr Chief I mean Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Mario Samy it is a hard act to follow
Mark randazza I am an attorney in
Connecticut a free speech lawyer in
Connecticut I'm up here I actually have
some clients who would or would would
now or would have in the past benefited
from this who
are residents citizens of New Hampshire
um I want to talk about I want to go
straight to the Chairman's question you
asked a very sophisticated technical
question and I just want to follow up on
it I had a case come through the door
not too long ago which involved the
woman who was a victim of sexual abuse
and she was being sued by her uh
attacker because of statements she made
on social media that he alleged were
false and they were not on the face of
it false were there was not they were
non-falsifiable statements they couldn't
be sustained at the end say we get all
the way down the line to summary
judgment we would have won she could not
pay me upfront what would normally be
required of a retainer but I could take
that I could I wouldn't even be able to
consider taking that case but
Connecticut has a pretty strong anti-s
slap statute so in that case I'm just
going to get in the weeds with you a
little bit here so when you have to put
on a prima fascia case early on
are you a fact-based pleading state or
are you a notice based pleading State uh
pretty much notice okay so it's enough
for them to say this person lied about
me in these ways on these things these
these the in the internet this person
lied about me on the internet and this
caused me harm okay in our state you
have to even get a little bit more into
the facts but it it would be sufficient
to to pass early motions to dismiss or
we call motions to strike if you just
say hey this person lied about me in
these ways and caused me harm you don't
actually have to say the exact
statements you don't have to identify
exactly what the LIE the supposed lie
was what the those words were so you
can't attack them early on in the same
way you're suggesting as a matter of law
this doesn't sustain this can't be
sustained because it's just a matter of
opinion why doesn't this get kicked out
early on because of the way pleadings
work so the person would have to go all
the way through Discovery with all that
all the expenses of depositions and
electronic Discovery and so on and most
people they can't even get past the
first motion let alone the possibility
of going all the way down that way and
then having to go to a trial and then
having to take an appeal and so
on it's it's not even can't even think
about they don't they can barely make
their car payment these people some of
these people so uh what the person would
have to do the um I'm going to call the
Mal the bad guy in this case I'm just
going to presume it for the moment he
would have to in order to sustain
himself pass the special motion to
dismiss early on he'd have to make an
affidavit saying this is what she said
that isn't true now even if that gets
past the special motion to dismiss
strategically that is very useful he's
locked in early on he can't wait for the
convenience later on after discover's
gone on to come up with some cutesy
story way down the line he's got to say
at the start this is what you're saying
ma'am that's a lie and that's for for I
got to say that was really valuable to
force him to put him in that position
hey guy I'm going to put you on the
stand you're going to have to you're
going to have to put up evidence early
on in Connecticut we could have put them
on the stand here you just have to you
just have to have an affidavit or
something to sustain that burden but you
have to put some you have to put
something down you can you have to risk
perjuring yourself or risk changing your
story later on you're locked in that's
really a very valuable strategic tool
that isn't apparent that kind of way
that scenario plays out that's not
apparent in the text of this bill
there's a lot of this this bill is an
amazing piece of social technology that
has evolved through 30 years of anti-sap
litigation and development in law and
watching how other states mess up
including my own State Connecticut lots
of state and watching them evolve uh
attorney randazza helped draft this and
he did this is a really fine piece
there's a lot of technical pieces here
I'm happy to address any of them that
may not be apparent on the face of it
why is this why do we have this
substantive versus procedural piece I I
don't attorney sh can you help me
understand I'm happy to do that so I did
want to talk about I hope that addresses
uh no it does it does it was it was it
was helpful very helpful yeah so iway
yeah I I want to talk about a little bit
about some of the people that this bill
will help in my practice I'm not Mark
extremely successful I'm I'm a tier at
least one tier down right I drive a
Subaru because it's good in the snow
like I'm not you know I own one car
that's you know I'm not a I'm not a I I
have a managing member of my firm I'm I
don't get to call the shots I he gets to
say whether you know this is a problem
or not so I have to prove to him that I
have a decent case right so uh some I I
mentioned the sex assault victim and I
am sure that that story is not unique to
you know to Connecticut I'm sure you
that thing can happen in New Hampshire
and I'm sure it does now you just don't
see it you don't see the people this
helps you don't see the lawsuits that
don't happen you don't see the people
who shut up it's it's not visible I'm
telling you it does happen because I
hear these stories as I said I had a
couple people from from New Hampshire
um these are both of them are uh YouTube
content creators they are investigative
journalists of a style one of them uh
makes more long form content like
documentaries the other uh substantive
content like an hourong long form things
about corruption or about um
fraud that they have
identified
and one of them did get sued and that
was and I had to explain to him how much
it was going to cost him for me to
defend it and ended up referring him to
another firm and another one we I had
him because we expected for him to
possibly get sued by a person he had to
move his business and his intellectual
property to a more favorable state with
a better anti- slap law with an actual
anti-s slap law I said set it up over in
Connecticut just move we'll have your
intellectual property owned by your
business by a business in Connecticut
you can pay Connecticut taxes okay what
have you I but you because there was no
anti-s slap bill here it was a terrible
idea for him to try to defend himself
from a defamation suit in in New
Hampshire not withstanding the fact he
was writing a really interesting
documentary about this kind of this
piece of fraud I don't want to identify
my client um and so that's how we he did
so now he's guys a concut business uh I
would after this I would consider
becoming barred in New Hampshire because
this is and doing the exact opposite
this is a very strong a very useful
instrument this bill uh to helping to
protect those kinds of people now these
are little guys uh right so they they
also aren't driving around with fancy
cars they're they're they're not making
six digits but they are doing adding to
the discourse in America in a way that
uh is really valuable they can reach
different kinds of a es people can and
they bring even on things like uh
cryptocurrency and a lot of things so
they they're interesting topics that I
think are valuable in their speech um
those are so those are some of the
people who this bill will
protect right question I'm sorry mean to
interrupt you you have I thought you
were I thought you were done no no no no
uh well I was going to talk about some
of the value for the people of State of
New Hampshire you know law this is about
lawyers policing lawyers here the only
people who should be be afraid of this
bill are bad or bad lawyers who are
acting in bad faith there is one in
there's one in my area who I encounter
several times um sometimes my clients
can't necessarily Avail themselves they
come to me too late to be able to Avail
themselves of the anti connetic anti
slap statute so sometimes he gets around
it in that way but he the he's usually
just trying to shake down someone's
homeowners insurance for a few th000
he's got a garbage suit but they'll you
know the insurance company will will
settle if there is insurance
um but this is about this doesn't cost
the people of New Hampshire anything
this is just lawyers policing lawyers
there's a lot of value in that
um you know and another thing with these
cases a lot of nonprofits don't take
these kinds of speech cases uh these
defamation speech cases because there's
you can't package it right in order to
get people to help you out so a lot of
this kind of free speech defense really
does fall on the on private attorneys um
and you're giving us the ability to act
as private Attorneys General in terms of
defending the freedom of speech um I'm
happy to address any questions you may
have questions yes representative
Brie thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your your testimony how does an
anti-sap law protect a citizen from
a state
prosecutor from attacking him just for
political purposes to silence them or
intimidate using uh law
fair would I wish it did I don't think
it does I don't think it does would I
wish it did because I have that that is
a problem we have in Connecticut too
well the followup on that is the reason
why is it because in the analysis it
says uh this bill establishes legal
process for preventing strategic
lawsuits against public participation as
qualified immunity from suit prosecution
and from liability for any so I'm I'm
that that word prosecution implies to me
that the district attorney decides that
they don't like me they just want to
bring a suit against me to shut me up
for some
reason can you just direct me to which
paragraph you were talking about just on
the analis ah I believe a prosecution
means in the way that one might
prosecute a lawsuit doesn't necessarily
mean in a criminal manner it means I
believe in this context they're
referring to when I bring a lawsuit and
I try to follow it all the way through
that is to prosecute a lawsuit so uh I
don't believe this this applies to Mark
I don't believe this applies to any uh
government officials speech you would be
wrong I'm wrong yes I appreciate that I
appreciate the correction this is why
you drive the Subaru right this is why I
and just so you know I drive a Subaru
too with 200,000 miles on it and the
check engine light is
on Fair all right so I appreciate the
correction that's uh
I I I would we had such a spill in
Connecticut I would wish we did um any
other questions I may address other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much thank you so
much next uh I'm G to call
on uh Elizabeth
uh SL sski
yes good afternoon again Mr chairman and
members of the committee um I just want
to clarify because I was here earlier in
my professional capacity that this
afternoon I am here in my personal
capacity um so for the record my name is
Lisa Brit solski Stevens and I am a
resident of conquered um the chief
proponent of anti- slap legislation
you've heard from Mar and daza is a dear
and very old friend of mine um it is
funny for many of us who lived in the
same dorm at UMass Amherst to think that
he has used his tremendous intellectual
gifts to to become a preeminent First
Amendment lawyer but he
has and his Fidelity to the first
amendment I think you gathered is
unmatched and it's non
partisan like any friend of longstanding
Mark has made me laugh and cry has
introduced me to new ideas and
experiences and has saved my
bacon I think this bill is something of
a legislative unicorn its purpose and
goals both appeal to so-called
constitutional conservatives as well as
those leaning left or far
left the laws passed these laws have
passed some of the most liberal and some
of the most conservative states in the
nation I think one thing that in my
research and my tutorials from Mark um
there is that question of motivation
maybe not relevant to the judicial
analysis but it sort of speaks to the
origin of these cases that many of these
defamation cases are brought by people
who have no expectation of
winning and I would offer as a local
example and I don't know how this would
have played out if we had strong
anti-sap legislation on the books but
New Hampshire Public Radio has spent
several years defending litigation based
on reporting that their journalists have
done award-winning
journalism from somebody who didn't like
the content and didn't like the
reflection of their work they have spent
many many dollars to defend their work
that they could have spent on
programming I would much rather listen
to the folk show on Sunday evening
knowing that they don't have the burden
of frivolous litigation so that to me is
a very personal and
local explanation of how this might go
differently in the presence of anti-s
slap legislation in New Hampshire um in
my research I've also seen
that these laws are protective of
victims of Domestic and Sexual Violence
and trafficking um the the courts are
used as an instrument of further abuse
for such victims this prevents that
ongoing kind of
abuse I am not the expert you've heard
from people far more expert than me I'm
not positioned to say that this bill
goes too far or not far enough my ask of
the committee is that you give it a fome
review
have a fome debate and make whatever
amendments you think are necessary to
ensure that New Hampshire is not without
any anti-s slap
protection I'm thankful for your time I
could answer questions but probably not
well questions for this witness
representative
Smith and I just want to remind you of
course you do not have to answer the
question you could say you don't know um
I don't didn't understand your reference
um
uh you talked about who would benefit in
the state of New Hampshire and you
mentioned trafficking and I I don't get
the connection can you help make a
connection for me I will do my best and
if I falter Mark will help me but
essentially perpetrators of abuse and
violence and trafficking King will use
the court to retaliate against their
victims who are trying to get protection
from supportive entities if they maybe
out somebody um there is a lot of
literature about how this could have
been helpful in the Harvey
Weinstein hundreds of cases where
initially he was sort of standing on his
reputation and saying this can't
possibly be true and people with
legitimate complaints were not able to
bring them forward because of the
expense even though he knew he had
perpetrated those
crimes other questions for this witness
thank you very much thank you so much
none I'm going to call on attorney super
please good afternoon attorney sufit
from Franklin representing Hampshire
associ iation for
justice I know some of my audience here
and I got this bill yesterday Marissa
said look at this bill tell me what's
wrong with it um what I'm but I'm what
I'm hearing from the proponents of it is
that this is going to weaponize the
other side the side that wants to
purport to Be invoking Free Speech
rights that if you go against that Free
Speech rights and they sue then they
have substi of immunity and then if you
lose in the the person who is using this
anti-s slap they get um punitive damages
did we did you read that and the we
don't have punitive damages in New
Hampshire um but that that's what it
says and again I read it quickly but um
let's see one two three
the bottom of page
four
is the the one who is using the this new
legislation this anti-s slap first gets
the case dismissed because they have
substantive immunity then brings a
second suit against using the anti-s
slap get statutory damages of no less
than 100,000 WS compensatory damage
and additional damages calculated to
deter the other side pled from bringing
that's
punitive and then it actually uses
punitive near the bottom uh the line 26
of the last page if they bring in a case
and I didn't understand how this works
is if the they're using the anti-s slap
in a foreign jurisdiction so another
state and they win there somehow they
can get statutory damages of 10 to
100,000 um attorney's fees and then
bullet for punitive
damages um I mean just New Hampshire's
got a long history that that we don't
allow punitive damages you have actual
damages so this is basically a a game
Cher against our jurist prudence and
then I'm wondering if the proponents
have read the recent Supreme New
Hampshire Supreme Court case of Dan Hind
um some of you probably know him because
he sits in this body yeah and if um the
ne Hampshire Democratic party and
Raymond Buckley had the benefit of this
anti-s slap when Dan sued and and the
Hampshire Democratic party would say oh
we have uh we have immunity here and and
if they would have won with that statute
um then Buckley and the Hampshire
Democratic party would have gone after
representative Hines for these punitive
damages um and these $10,000 to $100,000
damages ladies and gentlemen that is a
chilling a chilling chilling effect that
this statute would bring to NE Hampshire
and you know somebody asked the question
well is this an attorney's
bill you know attorney's fees and cost I
I think it is kind of an attorney's
free-for-all if we would have passed
this here
and and the immunity word is like I
don't know eight or 10 times in the
statute immunity immunity qualified
immunity qualified immunity qualified
immunity qualified immunity I mean
they're seeking to get some sort of
immunity um in New Hampshire so I leave
you with this is you know we are dealing
with two constitutional rights here
right and in our state
constitution we have part one article
20 that the right to a jury trial for
the jury of our peers to decide
cases that right shall be held
sacred that's what the frame is of our
New Hampshire Constitution the right to
have a jury of our decide cases shall be
sacred that's not even in the US
Constitution right to a jury trial um in
article 7 so the Hampshire takes that
right as a a sacred right to have a jury
of our peers resolve cases and I
understand that the freedom of the press
is also a very high U right in this case
because we say that in article 22 part
one that the free speech and Liberty of
the press are essential to the security
of freedom in the state they ought
therefore to be inv viably
preserved you don't see those words in
our other rights in our state consti
so we have long Juris Prudence in this
state when we're balancing these two
high orders of freedoms that we cherish
in this state and this anti- slap seems
to
elevate this um freedom of
expression over our sacred right of
having a jury of our peers decide
disputes and and that's just not the
hampire way um so I understand that
there's a this is a national push and I
understand that um um Mar razzer is
behind writing this legislation that's
what Mario shery said that he was
instrumental in drafting this
legislation for the Hampshire
um we can deal with our own problems
here in New Hampshire we don't need
Outsiders coming in and telling us what
to do never have um we don't have this
problem here in New Hampshire our
Supreme Court
dealt with Dan Hines and the New
Hampshire Democratic party in a very
even way and they looked at our
Constitution and our statutes and they
came out with a very principal decision
this anti- slap would basically overrule
that that's nothing a h
away questions for this witness
representative
Smith um thank you very much I've been
waiting to find someone who I can ask
this
question um I have always had difficulty
personally with the the concept of
qualified
immunity which I see as a license to
behave in a way
that other people might not be permitted
to behave can you tell me how qualified
immunity I I read it in this bill but I
couldn't figure out how it would work
can help me I'm not sure I can because
when I well when I read the
legislation there's another problem that
is very similar to what you bring up
representative Smith is on page
two paragraph
F this immunity may only be
overcome by showing d da d d da DT so it
basically G the immunity is is um
presumed until it's proven otherwise and
then and um our former Chief Justice can
talk to this um unless must show the
claim can survive a motion to dismiss or
a motion for summary judgment well those
are two different tests we know in court
you know motion to dismiss is on the
pleadings is there a factual is enough
factual stuff in the pleading to survive
a motion to summary judgment is
basically after some evidence is in you
weigh the evidence
those are two different standards I'm
not sure what this legislation meant as
that standard why they drafted it that
way it it is confusing um so for for all
of those reasons I I understand the
proponents of this National move have
helped draft this legislation here in
New
Hampshire it it needs a lot of study it
needs a lot of study and and I don't
think we take that as a a sort of uh
pencil Whip approv It today without
really looking deep into the covers
here before we're going change questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you thank you um is there
anyone else who wishes to uh testify on
House Bill uh
1475 and I should note that um the
record that in terms of sign up there
are 10 people that signed up to support
this bill and one in
opposition um all right seeing that I'm
going to close the hearing on
1475 and um what time is
it oh yes it's two we're we're I'm G to
open the hearing out bill
16003 and I will uh recognize the uh
Prime sponsor uh representative
Hines
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee um so by way of background
basically this statute I'm trying to
overturn uh the Court's decision
perspectively in state bily um so that
was a case I brought back in 2018 where
um basically women were charged for
being topless on a beach and the court
um ultimately in a 3-2 decision um
upheld that ordinance um I'll just quote
from the uh finding basically the
majority's reason was that the ordinance
does not classify on the basis of gender
um because it prohibits both men and
women from Being Ned um so my statute
would essentially overrule that decision
um so New Hampshire as you may know is
not a home Ru state so what that means
is towns and cities can only do what the
legislature says they can can and so
this statute is um essentially
prohibiting towns from doing that so the
state if they want they can step in and
it's called preemption we can make a law
that tells Town specifically you cannot
do something that's what this bill is
it's preempting Bill it would prohibit
cities towns and unincorporated places
from discriminating or distinguishing
based on race or sex um now offand I
can't think of any ordinances that do
discriminate on Race um I hope there are
none but on the chance that there are I
think it's important that we tell towns
do not do that and the same with sex I
do not think an element of a charge or a
crime should be the sex of a person I
think it's very inappropriate and this
bill would essentially remedy that and
um so the words the reason I have
discriminate or distinguished in my um
bill is specifically to address the
courts language in state V Lily um that
dealt with classifications so just to be
perfectly clear if the court were to
look at this again to look at um
legislative intent my intent is very
specifically to overrule that case and
essentially that is what this bill would
do um if there are other instances of
the state or not the state of towns or
cities essentially discriminating on
basis of sex it would also make those
statutes um void and unenforceable and
I'm happy to take any questions on
this questions for this Witness
could I ask just one question um do you
differentiate between sex and gender I
did not
um I know some people use those words
interchangeably um unfortunately our
human rights um or basically our law
against discrimination also somewhat
uses those words interchangeably um so I
do not if the committee wants to put in
amendment I think I would be supportive
of that I think it further complicates
the issue um it's gonna my opinion then
you might want to address the difference
between sex and gend I think just
further complicates an issue so no I am
specifically only only dealing with
sex other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
um I'm gonna call on Anie Malachi
um to testify about this on this bill
good afternoon to the chair and the
committee thank you very much um my name
is Anie Malachi I am the executive
director of The Human Rights Commission
um the commission was asked to do a
fiscal note and we certainly would not
know how many calls that we would get um
I think the larger issue for the
commission is that uh we whether it's
public accommodation which this would
cover um or if the city or the town was
an employer um all of those locations
are pre are currently covered under the
Discrimination law or the
anti-discrimination law that we have
here in New Hampshire um and by singling
out or specifying race or sex um the
question would be does that mean the
other areas of the law are not
applicable and if so why not so um
there's quite a bit of
confusion for for me uh relative to this
information and it would it's not
helpful to eliminate other areas where
there could be discrimination relative
to a city or a town as a place of public
accommodation or even as an employer so
I'm happy to take any
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
um is there anyone else here um who
wishes to
testify on House Bill
1603 see
see we had one witness testifying in
support
yes oh I'm sorry sorry 61 people signed
up in support and one opposed
um on this on 1603 any other anyone else
here wishes to be heard all right then
I'm going to close the hearing on House
Bill
16003 and we're considerably early so we
we have we can take a break before we
get to the last
bill
I
don't
okay it's uh 3:15 we'll now uh open the
public hearing on House Bill
1037 and representative Muse the floor
is
yours thank you very much uh Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
representative David Muse I represent
Portsmouth uh Newington and
Newcastle uh I'm here today in support
of uh HB
1037 uh and that's because in our legal
system we have two types of law we have
criminal law that enforces public
Justice it punishes people who break our
laws the second type of law civil law
can also punish wrongdoers but in
instead of sending them to jail or
finding them civil law seeks to
compensate a victim for the harm they
have endured as a result of the actions
of a
wrongdoer a doctor who botches a surgery
can get sued for malpractice a car
manufacturer can be sued for installing
faulty ignition switches and airbags
that lead to Deaths and the injuries of
customers a pharmacy chain can be sued
for the overdistribution and dispensing
of opioids that contributed to millions
of addictions and many thousands of
deaths civil liability is not about
sending offenders to jail it's about
finding a way to help make victims and
their families whole again when we
can it's also about trying to compensate
them fairly when we
cannot the ability to sue another party
for damages is one of the great
equalizers in the American system of
justice you can sue Facebook and win you
can sue General Motors and win you can
even sue the state of New Hampshire and
you can
win taking the right to sue away from
people who have been harmed by the
actions of another isn't Justice it is
the opposite of
justice but here in New Hampshire our
law recognizes that there are on
occasion some very limited circumstances
where it can enhance the public interest
to limit
liability Good Samaritans and healthcare
workers providing emergency medical
assistance land owners who let their
property be used for recreational
purposes volunteer firefighters who may
or may not be able to save a burning
building these are all good examples of
sensible limitations on
liability we don't want people to be
afraid of helping other people in
emergencies we also don't want our
firefighters sued because they decide to
save a barn instead of a chicken
scoup these are some of the situations
that are spelled out in RSA 508 that
qualify for limited liability in New
Hampshire when it comes to personal harm
and property
damages police
officers I'm sorry police officers
healthcare workers Emergency Services
Personnel food donors state workers
volunteers for charitable organizations
what most of them have in common is that
nearly all of them are engaged in work
that has a real public
benefit then we come to RSA 508 colon
21 which is a statute that this bill
asks you to
repeal it provides the only limited
liability exemption under New Hampshire
law that covers an entire industry and
not just a
profession RSA 508 21 which this bill
would repal exempts New Hampshire
Firearms manufacturers sellers dealers
and their trade associations from civil
liability resulting from the criminal or
unlawful use of a fire armor ammunition
that they put into the stream of
Commerce that's extremely broadly
defined in effect what this law does is
Shield an extremely profitable industry
from facing basic Financial incentives
to better protect public health and
safety no other industry has this sort
of blanket protection from civil
liability in New Hampshire law which
raises a really critical
question what exactly is the public
benefit of giving one industry special
treatment and does it outweigh the
interests of victims and their
families the simple fact is that laws
that limit the liability of an entire
industry discourage
lawsuits in this case they also reward
and quietly encourage negligence in the
manufacturing selling marketing and
importing of firearms in related
products they also discourage
potentially life-saving
Innovations I'll give you an example of
that the idea for so-called smart guns
has been around for decades these are
guns that have biometric sensors that
can detect whether the person holding
the gun is the person the gun actually
belongs to a Smart Gun Won't fire for
anyone but the
owner widespread sales of smart guns
could save hundreds of children from
accidental shootings and also dozens of
police officers who have their firearms
rested away from them uh in contact with
offenders only one company right now a
startup company offers a firearm like
this to sell for the for sale by the
public um so why exactly is
that it's because there is no incentive
to invest in safety Innovations like
smart gun technology when any liability
that you face has been shrunken down to
a size so small you can drown it in a
bathtub the question is not about
supporting the Second Amendment it's
about special treatment for an entire
industry it's also about fairness to the
hundreds of other New Hampshire
manufacturers who do not enjoy this
similar degree of
protection and finally it's about basic
accountability for victims and their
families who should always under our
system have the opportunity to prove
their case in a court of law unless
there is a compelling public interest at
stake I also wanted to uh to mention a
kind of a brief postcript to the story
um earlier this week the New Hampshire
Supreme Court dismissed a lawsuit that
was filed by two police officers against
a gun shop owner the officers were shot
during a gas station robbery and uh the
officers claimed in their lawsuit that
the shooter should have been blocked
from purchasing a gun because of
previous mental health issues but citing
the statute the Court ruled that there
was no liability on the part of the gun
store
owner a lawyer for the Attorney
General's office was quoted in the WMUR
story as
follows it's good to know that the gun
industry in New Hampshire will now be
able to have this protection going
forward but apparently it's also okay
that this special protection for the gun
indust industry comes at the expense of
police officers and the safety of
members of the
public changing this is why I'm here
before you today and I'll be happy to
answer any questions that you
have represent
K thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I guess I just I
want to make sure that I'm understanding
something correctly so I understand why
for example a car manufacturer be
respons if say they were aware that
there was potentially a faulty break
issue and that they still sold the car
anyway because they wanted to have quick
sales um and then that person got in an
accident and somebody died I understand
why they'd be liable for that however
they wouldn't be liable if the person
just decided that they wanted to drive
their car into a river that's not the
liability of the manufacturer so I guess
my question is is currently is a
manufacturer responsible if the fire arm
is is faulty somehow in that they knew
that there was uh you know as part of
the manufacturing that there had been an
issue and that potentially it may cause
it to misfire somehow I would they be I
understand the reason why we would want
liability for that is that what you're
is isn't there currently already
liability for that there is liability
for for product defects that's my
understanding of this law it doesn't
doesn't address that um I think the
issue is actually more comparable let's
say you know if we're going to stick
with a car example um let's say you're a
car manufacturer and you decide that for
whatever reason uh instead of having
your pickup truck maybe be able to do a
maximum of 85 mil an hour uh you'll
design it so it can do 200 mil an hour
and not only will you design it to go
200 miles an hour but you'll put an
option on it that allows you to drive up
really close to another person James
Bond style and cut up their tires I mean
these are decisions that that you make
as a manufacturer how people use the
product is up to them um however what
you've done is you've created a
situation where you make it possible for
people to do a great deal of harm and I
think this is this is one of the things
I think that we're trying to get at
here thank you um so right now there is
liability for a faulty product but
you're trying to add in is liability for
if a person decides to use a firearm in
an inappropriate way and I guess I'm
just not understanding because I mean
there's many cars I don't know of really
any any roads that the speed limit is
above 75 but I know that my car can go
120 so does that mean that if I choose
to go 120 and kill somebody that my car
would be liable for that the car
manufacturer would be liable for that
and not me I think one of the things you
you realize is when you you have to
realize is when you design design a
product uh you know like this that can
be used in an inherently D dangerous way
uh there is a certain level of
responsibility that you bear uh when it
comes to the distribution of a product
like that uh there's a certain degree of
responsibility you bear for how the
product is
marketed um
uh I I I think the thing the thing and
and one of the reasons why I I really
think it's important to look at the
statute is I don't really see anything
like this in New Hampshire law for any
other type of industry and there are
lots of ways people can hurt themselves
um Firearms just one of the many ways
people can hurt themselves um what I
don't see is is protection for any other
industry in New Hampshire when it comes
to this uh and I for the life of me can
understand why we have
this representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
statement my
question I do not see this as comparing
Apples to Apples I see this as comparing
apples to oranges because all of the
industries you are mentioned are not
protected under
my first second third amendment the
right to carry arms is a protected under
the Second Amendment and therefore to
compare in my opinion to
compare gun manufacturers to cars or
whatever you're not comparing Apples to
Apples I believe and I think it was just
upheld by the decision that was just
made that there's a big difference
between a car manufacturer being liable
and a gun manufacturer being liable for
something someone does with a gun so I I
just don't see how you believe that um
you're comparing Apples to Apples here
what what I'm saying basically what I'm
saying and and I I I think there are um
there are probably if we brainstorm long
enough um lots of different scenarios
that we could potentially come up come
up with what what what I don't
understand is that why this particular
industry deser deserves a level of
protection that we offer to no other
industry manufacturing is not a second
amount M right it's not I mean owning a
firearm purchasing a firearm those are
second amendment rights but there's no
Second Amendment right to manufacturing
a product at all this is not a second
amendment issue this is a liability
issue yes go
ahead but I think we established that
faulty
manufacturing is already covered if they
knowingly fault faulty man manufacture
something and sell it it's already
covered so why do we need to make it
specific to to guns I do personally see
this as a
um an attempt to possibly um stifling My
Second Amendment right that's me
personally I'm a strong Second Amendment
advocate so um I just I I see it as a
difference representative Walsh thank
you thank you for taking my question
representative would you um in your
testimony you stated that uh RSA 508 col
21 out uh prohibits criminal and
unlawful acts with Firearms
manufacturers dealers Etc wouldn't it
make sense then to amend the statute to
include Motor Vehicles lawn tractors
other types of industrial equipment that
when used unlawfully causes injury of
death that they wouldn't uh that they
would also be
protected I would say knock yourself out
if you want to try to do that it would
be a heck of a lot easier simply to
repeal the statute the point is then we
wouldn't have just the Firearms industry
protected from unlawful acts committed
by Bad actors then we would have and
then essentially Firearms manufacturers
would have to play by the same set of
rules that everybody else has to play
with regarding liability in this state
that's what we're
after other questions for this witness
yes representative Stapleton thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question does
Connecticut have
um have reduced or eliminated this
liability for gun manufacturers and why
I'm asking that is it's heard that Ruger
manufacturing left Connecticut because
of the risk uh relative to U laws
adverse to them Manufacturing in that
state do you have any background or is
this patterned off of something that
Connecticut I don't know about the
Connecticut
situation other questions for this
witness so can I ask you a question if
the if we were to repeal this
bill am I would I be correct an
understanding that a plaintiff somebody
who was
hurt because somebody was uh uh shot the
person a person who was shot by a
criminal with an
AR-15 could bring a lawsuit against the
manufacturer of the
AR-15 saying that the AR-15 was uh
unreasonably dangerous and defective
because it shouldn't have been made at
all that that would be that would be a a
permissible lawsuit would it not well I
think I think in our system um anybody
can bring a lawsuit uh not everybody can
win a lawsuit but it would be up to the
jury wouldn't it wouldn't it so in other
words instead of us all of us saying
we're going to Outlaw
AR15s we would allow 12 members of a
jury pick that random to decide whether
or not an AR-15 should be outlawed was
unreasonably dangerous and and and
therefore defective be and if that were
if the jury came to that conclusion the
you one can imagine the a what would
happen to the AR-15 industry well my my
understanding of the way that juries
work is juries don't actually change the
law um judges don't necessarily change
the law legislators change the law um so
I'm not sure that a jury would actually
have the power to do that what a jury
would actually um have the power to do
would be to to take a look at our laws
see if the defendant has a case and then
the weigh the merits of the case based
on the way that our law is structured
currently the way our law is structured
Ed it is gained in the advantage of
firearms manufacturers Sellers and
importers and that's just a simple fact
it's why those two police officers lost
their suit now I haven't had a chance to
review the specifics of that case but
what proved to be the show stopper as I
understand it with our Supreme Court was
the fact that we had this Statute in
place that provides liability lock solid
liability for PE for for for dealers and
for manufacturers who are in this
situation
without this law in place the court
would have had to have looked at other
factors they would have had to examine
um issues at a deeper level uh there
would have been different evidence
provided whether or not it would have
been enough evidence for those officers
to win their case I have no idea but
what I do know is that the fact that we
have this law basically stopped their
entire case from proceeding and and I
think that's a
problem question representative sa yeah
thank you once
again I I heard on the radio or the TV
last night in the news
that the the suit was dismissed because
there was no
indication to the gun dealer um or or
even the police that uh there was um a
criminal history that would invoke
um the prohibition to sell the
gun so that's not the province of the
gun manufacturer that's the province of
the Intel and systems that keep track of
this or fail to do so I I would submit
that their suit was
misdirected well and you know and I
think you you know you might be right
about that I mean the Supreme Court
might have basically found that um it
you know IR regardless of of this
particular statute they may have found
that the evidence uh didn't didn't
justify uh the action and they they
might have uh found against the officers
but the the thing is is we'll never know
um and and to be to be clear full
disclosure I have not actually read the
Court's decision what I'm going by is
what WM reported but what Wu reported is
the reason why the court decided not to
move forward with this was because of
this
law representative
trip uh thank you for taking my question
uh your bill
reads relative to limited liability for
manufacturers Distributors dealers or
importers of firearms or ammunition is
repealed uh could you please describe to
me what limited liability uh consist of
what I'm sorry what what limited
liability consists of
H I would actually think there are other
people in the room who are probably more
qualified than me to describe you what
limited liability is I'm not an attorney
um uh but my understanding my Layman's
understanding of what limited
liability uh limited liability is is
that it it's basically what it says it
limits liability for for people who are
in a who find themselves in a certain
situation so this particular RSA not
only applies to guns gun manufacturers
but it also provide it also covers
people like volunteer firefighters who
may have to make on the spot decisions
about which building they're going to
save or not right um and by limited
limited liability uh I think in some
cases in the in the case of this
particular statute it seems to preclude
any liability just about any liability
at all uh which is really limiting
liability um but I think in other cases
it can limit and and this is where I'm
kind of getting out over my skis a
little
bit but I think in other cases it can
limit the amount of monetary damages
that you can
collect that's a great answer but not to
the question I ask thank you I think you
know if I can elaborate I I think I I'm
not positive in this but I think what it
when it says limited liability here what
it means is what you were talking about
before the liability is limited in
certain cases that is when yes when the
uh when the liability is predicated on
the criminal conduct of it results from
the criminal conduct of somebody else
but it would not there's there's no um
immunity from liability if for example
the you know the the trigger is faulty
and the gun goes off when it's not
supposed to or or uh or something like
that is that that's what I think it
meant that's that's it's limited in that
sense it doesn't cover the Firearms
manufacturers aren't completely immune
from liability if they have a defective
firearm for example but they are in this
kind of
circumstance yes representative K I
guess I'm just not understanding why
should a manufacturer or a dealer be
liable if the sale was
legal for somebody else's actions why
are they liable for what somebody else
chooses to do provided that everything
else was legal as part of the process
and that they've not participated in
some sort of other you know illegal
thing like giving a firearm to somebody
that they shouldn't
have yeah I I I think I've actually
answered your question several
times can I just ask one other question
is
the my understanding ing from around the
country uh is that there before there
was a federal statute there's a federal
statute that deals with this same area
but that before that and one of the
things that prompted the federal statute
is that there were claims against gun
manufacturers along these lines for
example um you make you gun manufacturer
you Smith and Wesson you manufacture Ed
too
many uh 9mm handguns there wasn't you
there there wasn't enough of a market
for 9 millimeter handguns to to justify
your making and I'm just making this
number up but there wasn't enough of a
market to to justify you're making
200,000 of those last year you only
should have made
150,000 um and it's your responsibility
Smith and Wesson to find out what the
market should be um for these and if you
didn't we're going to hold you liable
for that it was that kind of thing I
think that the at least at the federal
level that Congress was concerned about
basically saying wait a minute we don't
you know we don't tell General Motors
you know you made too many cars um we
don't we don't say you're you're liable
for for uh this Chevy Impala having gone
off the road and and somebody being
injured because you you made too many
Chevy ow we don't do that kind of
thing I mean I think I think that's
correct is it
not you know I would I would uh you know
defer to your understanding of you know
of federal law and the issues U that are
in question I guess I guess what I just
come back to is where is the public
benefit um where is the public benefit
of this statute you know as I go through
RSA 508 and I look at all of the other
uh instances where the state has
conferred limited liability I find
myself not in an agreement from the
state like if you're going to take the
right of somebody to Super damages
away I I think it's pretty well
established in our law that there should
be a public
benefit and the only benefit that I see
in this particular statute is the
benefit that is incurred by
manufacturers and dealers uh in an
industry that that doesn't have to
innovate um and that in many cases
doesn't even have to act responsibly and
and I think that's a problem
representative
Smith thank you Mr Mr chair um I
actually am going to begin by telling
the distinguished representative from
Portsmith that I don't agree with him um
about something that he he just said I
for example am completely opposed to
limited liability that protects Law
Enforcement
Officers um from being held
responsible for acting in an
inappropriate way I think that limited
liability in that area is not in the
best interests of the public I think
limit liability in that area has been
part of uh
increasing the sense of
distrust that many people in this
country have for um for police I happen
to think that they very few rotten
apples in that barrel and I just assume
make sure that the few rotten
barrels uh I the few frotten apples are
focused on and not all the other apples
uh so limited
liability
is is is very
tricky I'm sitting here though and and
this is a question maybe um I'll try to
make it a question um and I won't say
you know do you believe I won't say that
but I'm listening to the questions that
are asked and the answers that are
given and I believe that we're all
skirting
around
the I'll say the gorilla in the room I
don't want to say elephant because that
might you might think I mean something
different and that is the availability
in this
country of guns that are
designed uh to kill people and um we're
not talking here about all those people
we send off to war and give them weapons
supposedly in to defend us we're talking
about guns on the streets here um and I
think that those people who are asking
you questions about don't you believe
this and that believe that there
shouldn't be any limits on access to
weapons and I believe your answers
reflect your view and the view of
others in this room who believe that yes
access to guns should be limited and
what we're trying to figure out is how
to do that so the question that I asked
I did get to it eventually was is this
the best
way to
address the gorilla in the room that
we're not willing to recognize and that
is the availability of weapons many of
which were designed for war and not for
civilian use
in on our city streets it is a way for
an individual who feels that they have
been harmed to get redress um and that's
something that under the statute is not
available to them now um uh it wasn't
available to those two police officers
um and I and I think you know I we have
there are a lot of larger issues you
know when it comes to guns when it comes
to Second Amendment rights there are a
lot of things things I I think that we
need to have long and hard conversations
about um but this
one this one should be relatively easy
because it's literally a level of
protection that we provide to no other
industry um without any sort of
perceived public benefit now even even
in the case of police officers I know um
there's there are very good arguments on
both sides of whether whether or not
liability should be limited for police
officers we hear those arguments over in
my committee and criminal justice uh uh
a fair amount of the time um but I
think you know one of the things that we
you know that we need
to you know to to to basically just keep
coming back to is
um we're not here to solve all the
problems of the world we're not here to
figure out what the solution is to the
problem of gun violence or police
officer liability what we are here to do
is to decide whether or not we're going
to pass this bill and whether or not it
would create a public benefit for the
people of New Hampshire so um uh you
know I think that's you know basically
where I am on it other representative
katat um so you mentioned about the
other the other statues that are
currently in place with limited
liability and referenced their benefit
to the public isn't there a public
benefit in citizens being able to
utilize their Second Amendment right
when we've drawn to the fact that
manufacturers have left places like
California that don't have these limited
liability statutes isn't there a concern
that if we were to put this in place
that the gun
manufacturers wouldn't have anywhere to
manufacture their guns and we wouldn't
be able to to exercise our Second
Amendment right second amendment rights
are totally unrelated to liability
um there is there is no there there's
there might be sort of a tangental
connection that we make up in our minds
but I I don't think that there's a
connection there from a legal
perspective um this is not about second
amendment rights it's about whether or
not an entire industry um that has been
conferred this special right this
special privilege uh is actually
creating uh a a public benefit and
whether or not they should continue to
have the the right or or the ability or
or whether you know whether we should
continue to grant them um this this
special status uh that we've granted to
them in no other industry and and I'm
sure gez what about the ski industry you
know I mean how how cool would it be if
they didn't have to worry about
liability and and what are some other
Industries in New Hampshire you know I
think I think they
don't they don't they have don't they
have a good bit of immunity yes they do
I think they do they do yeah they do
with your purchase of the ticket right
right other question yes representative
Perez and then representative Wallace
thank you uh just to bring to
everybody's attention uh I think we'd
all agree that the lack of liability for
the uh pharmaceutical companies with all
the uh Jabs and uh injections they have
no liability so they're they're clearly
well protected and there's a lot of harm
going on there would you agree my
understanding is they're protected under
federal law I I do not see them listed
in RSA 508 as having that protection
under New Hampshire law and that's
that's really what this is
about representative
Press thank you thanks for taking my
question it's my understanding correct
me if I'm wrong that the suit that was
just settled was settled because the
gentleman who purchased the gun his
mental health
history was not made public to the gun
dealer so therefore he was able to buy a
gun that's my understanding of what the
several things that I have
read why wasn't his mental health
history come up is that because we are
protecting overprotecting that because
it's my understanding that most of these
mass shootings that we have had these
people have
had mental health issues that have been
known but I'm trying when and when
purchasing a gun they were protected so
we're protecting their right to privacy
with their mental health issues but yet
we are allowing them to purchase guns
and kill people so I think maybe we need
to look back and
see what's the best way to protect the
public and putting the onus on the gun
manufacturer or the gun salesperson as
opposed to the onus on what we are
allowed to to be
known is
we're we're missing the point had his
mental health status been available to
that gun person gun salesman he would
probably have not been able to purchase
the gun what does that have to do with
this it has nothing to do with this it
has to do with a man was protected by
our laws was able to buy a gun and use
it poorly so I know my high horse I'm
sorry all right well the good news is we
actually have a bill for that um and
we're hearing it tomorrow in criminal
justice it's a mental health reporting
bill uh New Hampshire is currently one
of three states that doesn't report
adjudicated mental health uh information
to the federal firearms background check
system um and uh I'm a co-sponsor of a
bill that uh representative Roy is the
prime sponsor of um and essentially that
bill would allow the reporting of people
who are involuntarily uh committed on a
non-emergency
basis um adjudicated as uh Innocent by
reason of of insanity uh or um
incompetent to stand trial um and uh and
there are privacy protections that are
built into that there is a redress uh
procedure for people who get better to
get their arms back and I'm really
hoping that when the time comes it would
have the support of everyone on this
committee other questions for this
witness representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I just found
something it was very interesting which
I think we all need to look into it's
called and I don't know if you're
familiar with it or not it's called the
protection of lawful Commerce in arms
act the protection of lawful Commerce in
arms Act
pcaa is a US law passed in 2005 that
protects fire on manufacturers and
dealers from being held liable when
crimes have been committed committed
with their products now are you familiar
with this and if we are I think it's
something we all need to look
into well I think federal federal law
and state law uh may sound similar but
they are they are two different things
uh what actually stopped the lawsuit of
those police officers that I mentioned
from going forward was not the federal
law it was the state law and that's what
we're trying to
change other questions to this Witness
none thank you very much representative
appreciate thank
you next I'm going to call on uh
executive counselor Dave
wheeler
okay oh yes thank
you thank you Mr chairman and and U
members of the committee um I was very
interested in this bill because I was uh
involved with my son Attorney James
wheeler when he was sitting on this
Committee in 2003 of writing this
legislation because of what was going on
at the time and people were trying to
sue gun manufacturers and dealers just
like uh they would sue the tobacco
companies um and so that's why we put in
that legislation uh back in 2003 there's
other people in this room uh that were
involved in that back then too and it
was also uh an initiative of the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition uh back at
the
time I wanted to say that I think that
the Chester RS decision was right and
just uh yesterday um based on the facts
and I think another speaker will talk
about uh why that person maybe um um
didn't wasn't on the prohibited person
list um at the
time I would I would also say that in in
my view and this is strictly my view uh
that this bill is brought forward so
that people can sue manufacturers
dealers and Distributors and the purpose
of that wouldn't be to protect the
public the purpose of that would be to
cost those manufacturers and dealers uh
their financial viability and put them
out of business and just chip away at
the number of Manufacturers um that
would be making Firearms making them
more expensive uh for the public to
buy um so and I wanted to also expound
on representative lind's example of the
automobile think of it this way if there
is a person who is drunk and kills
somebody with that automobile who's
responsible the drunk or the automobile
and this is a this is the same uh
protection that gun dealers and
manufacturers need it is not the
automobile that was responsible it was
the person who criminally misused that
firearm um and if I have just a little
bit of latitude I'd like to comment on
the mental health bill that's coming up
on Friday in the criminal justice
committee because I just want to put
this out there well over 90% of people
who are involuntarily committed are not
violent people and very often those
situations are very temporary you put
someone on the federal prohibited person
list try to get them off Cong regularly
defunds the mechanism to get people off
that list so again another bill from the
same representative trying to chip away
at our Second Amendment rights Peace by
piece by piece thank you questions for
representative wheer councelor wheeler
either
way seeing none thank you very much next
I'm going to call on representative uh
John Stone
please
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm representative
Jonathan Stone I represent Sullivan 8
which includes the city of clamont which
is adjacent to Newport which houses
Ruger firearms uh I'd like to start off
by saying in full disclosure prior to
entering politics I was involved in the
manufacturing side of uh firearms in the
state of New Hampshire and have quite a
working knowledge of both the federal
and state laws that are apply to it as
well uh the problem I see with this bill
and I had constituents reach out to me
with their similar concerns is that I've
heard testimony today that really
crosses line between trying to mix up
warranty and
liability warranty is something that's
provided by every responsible gun
manufacturer whether it be in New
Hampshire or outside the state of New
Hampshire that's already addressed with
a faulty product a company will call a
recall they'll put out a batch of
numbers usually that falls within a
certain parameter they'll pay for the uh
individuals to ship those fire back
correct the problem or replace it that's
warranty this limited liability that's
been brought up is mostly designed to
chip away at the gun industry that's
what this bill does is it does not it
repeals the protections from gun dealers
we don't hold criminals accountable that
is our number one problem and I also
serve on the criminal justice committee
with representative Muse and we differ
think on opinions on accountability if
an individual commits a crime such as
breaking into your house to steal a
firearm they then commit a murder if
committed two crimes how is that sterm
ruger's fault if it's a Ruger fire
should they be sued for two criminal
acts committed by a criminal should the
criminal not be held accountable for
their acts that's what I look at when
looking at some of these laws that we
keep trying to generate will this make
the public safer and I think we've heard
today that it probably won't make the
public safer but what it will do is
it'll impact the Firearms industry in
New Hampshire and I'm not sure if you
folks are aware of how many
manufacturers jobs are tied in to
Firearms now you mostly in New Hampshire
we think of Sig being the largest one I
believe that we currently have then you
have Ruger that's the second largest but
what about all the smaller companies
that are making firearms and the people
they employ whether it's an aerospace
company in clamont a manufacturing CNC
operation in Newport these are
livelihood I can tell you that clamont
Newport Sun they all have individuals
that work at strm Ruger do we want to
see strm Ruger say you know what New
Hampshire just repealed us this is
another reason why we should think about
moving our operation out of state we
can't afford to lose 900 jobs in our
area especially over failure to hold
criminals accountable and trying to hold
the individuals that work at these
facilities that could be in Jeopardy if
they end up being moved to say down
south I know Ruger has uh established a
factory in Maiden I believe it's South
Carolina they find it easier to find
labor down there the cost of materials
produc are cheaper down there energy
rates are cheaper New England's very
hard to start up manufacturing and I
think we're very privileged that Sig
decided to take a Gamble and bring their
entire operation here since they're an
international company they're not just a
domestic company in the end I see this
bill as being something that should be
ited I don't think uh restricting
individuals from suing uh a third party
for a criminal act is viable and uh I'm
willing to take any questions that
anyone might have questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you for your time thank you
next I'm going to call on uh Dr Joe
Hannon good evening Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
joeann and I'm the vice president for
gun owners of New Hampshire and we stand
in opposition to HB uh
1037 um there were a few points I'd like
to make uh that were brought up early
I'd like to discuss um one was uh that
there's you know no other industry we've
heard about um the vaccine industry also
the airline industry and internet
service providers are also immune from
defamation and other um other things
that they do uh so they're not the only
ones uh we also heard about what public
benefit why is this necessary if you sue
an industry and prices go up you
actually put the price of uh buying a
firearm or some product out of the reach
of many lowering inome and maybe not
lower inome people uh that's that's
definitely something it may be indirect
but it is definitely something that has
a direct effect on someone's right to
exercise their second amendment rights
also it can pose a danger to the
Readiness of the United States for
National Defense if we start suing all
the gun manufacturers what are our
soldiers going to fight with you know uh
that's another large thing that often
gets overlooked uh the reason why these
laws are often brought about these
repeal laws is because they want to go
after the gun manufacturers and have
less Firearms we've heard this multiple
times the former mayor of Bridgeport
Connecticut he said that they're trying
to create laws with litigation he sued
multiple gun manufacturers the HUD
secretary Andrew Cuomo also was trying
to get uh gun manufacturers to
voluntarily adopt uh locks and other
things in their um in their
manufacturing processes and they said
that if they don't the gun manufacturers
would quote suffer death by a Thousand
Cuts end quote Elliott Spitzer said
those who don't comply would have
bankruptcy lawyers knocking at their
doors so um real quick I'd also like to
talk about briefly um the incentives for
things like smart guns and we're not
allowing that to happen if something is
a good workable product that people want
the market will respond the reason why
you don't see smart gun Manufacturing in
the way that we might have we've we've
heard about is because they they're
they're extremely limited they're not a
good product they're very prone to break
a firearm is a pretty simple uh device
you pull the trigger it goes off I
wouldn't want to have fire extinguishers
my house house that only worked if I was
the only one capable of taking it and
using it to save my own life that is
ridiculous we also heard about cars if
they're too fast or too big and powerful
they could be dangerous now I'd love to
have a truck that went 200 mil hour I I
can't afford one but there's a smart car
you've all seen those little smart cars
some may have one I don't know they
average between 1,500 and you know under
3,000 lb for a Smart car so say at the
lowest number 1500 lb going at 20 M an
hour if you use the formula to decide
how much to find out how much energy
that produces when it hits
someone it's about um 27,000 jewles a 9
millimeter
bullet traveling at about a th000 me uh
feet per second which is pretty standard
is 346 Jews of energy that's 80 times
more energy than a smart car a Smart car
going only 20 miles hour if that same
smart car goes 55 miles hour since the
formula is masstimes velocity Square
halftimes Mass velocity squared at 55
mph this little dinky smart car has
25,6 57 jewles of
energy okay that is 594 times more
powerful than a single 9mm bullet so
we're we're not comparing apples and
oranges we're comparing apples and like
blue
whales um you know and as far as
qualified immunity for government
officials and law enforcement I'm not
going to get into that debate or take a
position on it but I will say that
qualified immunity actually protects uh
people when they are potentially
breaking the law or in violation of
someone's rights uh in the in the
furtherance of their their legal duties
if someone is breaking the law in a
manufacturer whether it's Firearms or
anything else they are still able to be
sued if they make a faulty product if
they make something with deceptive
practices there are long list of things
that they can be sued for and held
liable for so uh I think this is an
absolutely necessary uh bill for
preserving people's second amendment
rights and for uh preserving National
Defense more than just the economy of
New Hampshire so there's there's many
reasons this needs to be um ited I'd be
happy to take any questions questions
for this
witness yes
represent thank you for taking my
question I just want to ask you uh what
type of doctor are you
retired what Ty I was a foot and ankle
surgeon thank you thank
you uh any other questions for this
witness being none thank you very much
sir thank you all next um I'm going to
uh call on
Kimberly Mor from the uh women's Defense
League I guess it
is hello my name is Kim oh that was a
little bit harder of see you guys need
some questioning over here um I'm gonna
um I'm Kimberly Moren president of the
women's Defense League um our members
are we represent members from all over
the state women um Firearms
manufacturers manufactur inanimate
objects I think we've established that
the objects themselves do nothing
without human interaction and if they do
we've already established the Firearms
manufacturers can be suit somehow the
sponsors of this bill believe
manufacturers should be held responsible
for what a human does with their
inanimate product after they purchase it
of course this bill makes zero cents
what's next holding automobile
manufacturers liable for the actions of
drunk drivers which we already talked
about as well what about holding knife
manufacturers liable for the actions of
a criminal who stabs someone or what
about match manufacturers responsible
for a person who commits arson I think
you get the point this legislation is
nothing but an attempt to put firearm
manufacturers and Distributors out of
business or to make Firearms so
expensive granted saders won't be able
to afford to practice their fundamental
human right to self-defense which we
also admitted for first that that second
me is our right representative Smith
actually called it out when she talked
about the elephant in the room by saying
they wanted to limit access to firearms
and implying that this bill would do
just that please vote inexpedient to
legislate on this ridiculous
Bill questions for this week seeing none
thank you thank you next uh Katherine
gens
please
thank you Mr chairman and uh members of
the committee and um thank you to
everyone here who has spoken so
succinctly and actually summed up all of
my points so perhaps I can make this a
little bit shorter um my name is
Katherine giddens I am a lawful
permanent resident here I'm a
competitive shooter and I'm also a New
Hampshire's very new dur director of a
group called women for gun rights um who
like the women's Defense League um Works
to educate and Advocate and to preserve
um the legacy of the Great American uh
right to bear arms and uh I'm just here
today to maybe just make a couple of
observations now that the most obvious
points have been brought forward and um
in particular the um issue of personal
accountability
um which in a funny little way little
bit ironic maybe a little bit sad um
Senator Ella last week when speaking to
Bill 360 actually gave the most perfect
example of personal accountability when
referencing a pen that was across the
desk which uh she mentioned very
correctly would do nothing unless she
reached out picked it up and began to
write with
it everybody acts to write a hand is
controlled by a mind I don't need to say
this really with a will to write
something maybe something loving maybe
something kind maybe something hurtful
maybe a lie and lies destroy
lives and they harm people and this
bill I
believe is
presented there is a smoke screen
here there is an overreach here that is
hidden under a blanket
of community interest and the interest
of well we're here in the interest of
granite Staters but as it's been pointed
out the interest of the majority of
granite Staters is to enjoy the
freedom that they have here as part of
the Live Free or Die State and the
industries the firearm industry here
within 50 miles of here there are up to
30 small
businesses um independent operators
family multigenerational family run
businesses that their livelihoods are
sourced from the Firearms industry and
the state itself in some part uh derives
his livelihood from this industry um I
just recently learned that a couple of
years ago before I uh began long before
I actually I began this journey just a
couple of weeks ago so bear with me
please while I while I get my feet um a
couple of years ago Sig won a contract
to manufacture the arms for the uh arms
and Munitions for the the US Army um Sig
being uh with pistols I think they take
the top two spots of most uh last year
they were the top two for most popular
pistols Ruger as well um top one and two
spots for popular um shotguns both
semi-automatic and bolt action uh these
guys are top earners for our state
they're also top Trainers for um so many
gun owners so many women uh now uh
learning to defend themselves learning
to defend their families learning to
defend their rights um and those of the
loved ones and communities around them
through these
businesses and um in a little
interesting twist um uh senator shien
actually applauded our Firearms industry
here uh when she said um I'll just do a
little uh quote here um this contract
this is with Sig this contract reaffirms
the powerful role that the granite state
businesses play in support of Our
National Defense through this Federal
contract with the US Army New Hampshire
will manufacture and deliver all Army
soldier weapons for decades
congratulations to sigar for winning
this contract and for their invaluable
role in safeguarding our troops with
every Federal contract of this nature
comes jobs and economic growth in the
region which Granite State communities
need now more than ever as we rebuild
from the financial Fallout of covid and
as families endure difficult economic
challenges this generational investment
for the state will create hundreds of
New Hampshire jobs and ensure the
granite state remains at the Forefront
of our national security for decades New
Hampshire is renowned for its
manufacturing capabilities in support of
national product priorities from the
defense sector to the Aerospace industry
and Beyond I'm thrilled sigar is further
bolstering our state's proud reputation
that is um from
2022 and it's what is so damaging about
this bill if it's passed the granite
state is suffer and my heart honestly
does um go out to victims of unlawful
use of firearms and victims of crime and
super suicides it's it's a terrible
terrible situation and it's a terrible
reality that we all live with but this
sort of
Bill it doesn't
benefit the most people it hurts the
most people it hurts Granite status um
hard workers people who love their guns
people who love their freedom and I
think it's ethically wrong I think it's
logically wrong to pass this sort of
Bill and I would urge you
to um not support it and that's all I
have to say on that thank you questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much thank you very next I'm going
to call on Jay simpkin
please good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony I do have prepared
testimony in consideration of the hour I
will not repeat not read it uh thank
thank you you're we will read it but you
don't have to you don't have to read it
yourself what I will do though is hit
some of the main points because there
are unanswered
questions I want to begin with a
foundational fact at the end of
2022 there were in the United States
approximately four 474 million
firearms in my written testimony I
explain where that number comes from but
anyone who can do basic math should
understand that the ship of gun control
sailed years and years ago anything that
numerous and mainly concealable cannot
be controlled the effort is for doomed I
understand some people people are blind
to the reality I just set
forth further the notion that background
checks stop folks who shouldn't have
guns from getting them by virtue of the
point I just made is plainly
absurd the number of folks who want to
get firearms and abuse them in the
United States might be a few
million they're roughly even if they're
10 million they're 47 firearms for every
such person the likelihood of any law
that you or anyone else can enact
stopping those folks isn't
zero I'm an economist as well as a gun
dealer but it's very
close
second many presume that gun control is
a prere a prerequisite for Public Safety
this is simply not said
at least since
2001 Maine New
Hampshire and Vermont have with a single
year exception 2015 been the three
safest states in the union measured by
the incidence of violent crime per
100,000
residents the enactment of this bill and
I'll
explain
shortly what is the mechanism by which
it will damage Public Safety the
enactment of this bill will subvert
Public Safety its proponents plainly
want to live in a more dangerous State I
suggest they move to
Massachusetts which has thickets of gun
control
laws the incidence of violent crime in
Massachusetts 2022 two and a half times
that of New Hampshire and nearly treble
that of
Maine why would anyone in their right
mind want to replicate here what exists
in
Massachusetts it's akin to someone
catching a flight to Riyad Saudi Arabia
going into a restaurant and then seeking
an order of ham and
eggs for those not aware Muslims do not
touch
pork not in any shape not in any form
I'm Jewish I can touch pork I simply
can't eat it so a rational person would
not go to Saudi Arabia and berak the
chef for refusing to serve up an order
of ham and eggs why would anyone come
here who wants gun control it's
irrational and truly it is now let me
get to the I guess the heart of what I
want to tell
you
the purpose of this bill is to do two
things it is as some alluded to earlier
to destroy businesses who make wholesale
and sell
firearms the
mechanism as some have said is
lawsuits what is missing from the
equation is who is going to fund those
lawsuits I have a really good idea what
it costs to litigate
I hold in my hand in a
moment what I'm pretty sure is the most
expensive Massachusetts non-resident
license to carry firearms on this
planet an earlier version of this
license was sarily
revoked it cost me
$125,000 and about three and a half
years of effort
to get from the Supreme Judicial Court
of
Massachusetts an order restoring the
license to me I broke no
law I infringed no regulation and no
charge was ever brought this gives you
an idea what it cost to litigate and oh
by the way Representatives I did most of
the law
research and legislative history
research in order for my my very capable
attorney to pursue the
case so litigation
expensive further disclosure I've been
before the New Hampshire Supreme Court
as a non- attorney representative in a
firearm related matter on behalf of a
fellow
nashan who had two firearm related
licenses wrongly and unlawfully
revoke I wrote I researched and wrote
his brief it was the hardest thing I've
done since I wrote my doctoral
disertation and I hope never to do it
again I as a non- attorney couldn't
charge him and I wouldn't even if I
could
have it took about a thousand hours over
a couple of
years my point is litigation is
burdensome so here's the key point I
believe
that the backers of this
bill implicitly or explicitly work on
behalf of Michael
Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg according to
Forbes Magazine is the 14th wealthiest
person on this planet his fortune
according to Forbes is $96
billion he Champions gun control and has
done so for years and in my prepare test
testimony I provide you with links to
his
website Mr Bloomberg is
brilliant I give the devil his
due I have told folks that the Nazi
dictator wore on his uniform only one
medal it was an iron cross that he
earned legitimately as a Frontline
fighter in World War
I his air minister Herman
guring had all kinds of medals but
guring himself earned Imperial Germany's
highest award guring was a a fighter
pilot and an ace so even people whom I
have little regard for that's a British
style understatement nonetheless I'm
constrained to tell the truth about and
that is what I do
here Mr
Bloomberg has bottomless
Pockets most firearm businesses
Nationwide are either sole
proprietorships or limited liability
corporations they are not Mega
firms Mr
Bloomberg donated to his alma mater also
my alma mater Johns Hopkins 1.8 billion
that's with a B
dollars and there is at that
University an entity devoted to quote
researching gun violence end quote
anyone who uses the term gun violence
May fairly be deemed to be a rabidly
anti-gun so in short were you to enact
this bill it clears the way for Mr
Bloomberg to bankrupt or or Force out of
business for fear of
bankruptcy anyone involved in firearms
in this
state
now some might say well that's a good
thing but I
refer to you that the presence of
firearms may have some power to explain
why the incidence of violent crime in
New Hampshire is as low as it is we are
now the second safest state in the Union
Maine is number one and even when we got
rid of compulsory licensure for
concealed carry the incidents of violent
crime in New Hampshire continued to
fall the same thing is true in Maine
which ended compulsory lure in
2015 and Maine again was at that time
still is safest state in the Union in
short
I go out on a thin limb and a high wind
as an economist I do that a lot but I
think the proponents of this bill have
bluntly put been less than candid and I
think that's wrong anyone who testifies
before you just as they would in court
has a duty of cander to the tribunal
that Duty I have that Duty I have done
and I will be happy to take any
questions that you may have right
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee stay
well thank you next I will call on
Xandra Hawkins
please
hi thank you my name is Xandra rice
Hawkins and I'm the state director of
gunsense New Hampshire project of Grant
State progress um we have tracked and
waited on Firearms policy at the state
level since 2009 and convene the New
Hampshire gun violance prevention
Coalition uh we support the bill before
you with nearly every other industry in
the United States Civil liability can be
used as an important check on
irresponsible and harmful industry
behaviors but the gun industry has
enjoyed enormous exemptions from
liability and accountability in New
Hampshire since 2003 and at the federal
level since 2005 civil liability plays
an important role in promoting community
and consumer safety in circumstances
where legislators have been unwilling to
enact laws regulating a dangerous
industry the possibility of civil
litigation lawsuits can help incentivize
Industries to take responsible steps to
prevent their products or business
practices from causing foreseeable risk
to human life and well-being
traditionally this means that victims
harmed by wrongful industry conduct or
public officials acting on the people's
behalf can seek Fair Justice and
accountability in the courts by filing
lawsuits seeking monetary compensation
or other court-ordered relief when
Industries have negligently or
recklessly caused harm or failed to take
responsible steps to present foreseeable
to prevent forceable harm I want to
emphasize that when Industries have
negligently or recklessly caused harm or
failed to take reasonable steps to
prevent foreseeable harm in too many
cases however this principle does not
apply to the Gund industry because the
industry has obtained unprecedented
immunity from the system of justice and
accountability you heard earlier um
about the federal law in the the what
preceded that was that in the 1990s a
series of lawsuits actually resulted in
court judgments holding certain members
of the Firearms industry liable for
particularly Reckless practices but
instead of comprehensively reforming its
business practices and response the
industry responded by lobbying to pass
new gun industry immunity laws in States
Across the Nation to prevent plaintiffs
from bringing many types of lawsuits
against firearms and ammunition
manufacturers and sellers that passed at
the federal level in 2005 and again at
the state level in
2003 right now these legal immunities
have helped to Shield this profitable
industry from facing basic Financial
incentives to better protect public
health and safety too often they have
encouraged a head in the sand behavior
that shks any role for those
manufacturing selling marketing or
importing firearms and related products
to identify dangerous patterns
proactively change behaviors and Lead
toward life-saving Innovations and
solutions too often they've left victims
of gun violence who are harmed by
wrongful of firearm industry conduct
without any measure of compensation or
Justice these legal immunities also
provide an unfair business advantage to
irresponsible Firearms industry members
over more responsible competitors who
take stronger precautions to protect
human life and
well-being I want to draw to your
attention um the example from the Sandy
Hook shooting in February of 2022 after
enduring years of litigation to
establish their right to sue Firearms
manufacturers under an exception to the
Federal gun industry immunity law the
families of the children and Educators
murdered Sandy Hook Elementary School in
2012 reached a record $73 million
settlement with the
manufacturer that made and marketed the
shooters assault weapon but the same
families had suffered the same
unspeakable tragedy in many other states
they may have never been able to seek
Justice at all because of similar state
level G gun industry immunity laws there
were a lot of conversation in this
committee today about other examples and
I do think it is important that you do
think about this from the product piece
that this is an exception that every
other nearly every other industry and
product has some kind of liability and
this is a very distinct special carve
out for the gun industry that in itself
is an admission that something is off
right like if you are afraid to have
them face the same consumer protections
the same recourse the same Justice and
accountability then something is not
working we talked there is liability for
those who serve over serve people who
don't take steps to intervene when
somebody's about to drunk to um drive
drunk the opad crisis the manufacturing
and selling marketing of those drugs has
resulted in massive lawsuits and the
state of New Hampshire and cities across
our state are um are benefiting from
those do to restore the the loss of life
and the costs that have been incurred by
our community members this is just
asking you to take away the special car
vs for unlim uh for limited liability
that the gun industry enjoys again it is
an admission of guilt if you cannot go
to a court of law and pursue these
conversations because you're afraid that
the ruling is going to go against the
irresponsible practices and marketing of
the gun
industry when people talked about the um
jobs and other things that also goes to
my concern one I think it's really
important to know that the gun industry
does not lack for funds this is a record
profit making industry but if folks are
worried that being accountable to
Consumers is some somehow going to cut
into those costs it's because they know
that the practices as they are right now
are not safe for our community they know
that they're will be wrongdoing found if
people are able to go to the court you
have two questions before you today the
first is do you believe the gun industry
should receive special legal immunity
above and beyond other
Industries we would say
no the second is do you believe the gun
industry has any role or responsibility
in the manufacturing marketing and
selling of
firearms we would say yes we urge you to
support this
Bill questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank
you I think that's the last card I pink
card I have is there anyone else who
wishes to be heard on uh this Bill yes
please please come
up
yeah no you are are you coming back if
the committee will permit I want to
answer specific wait before no before we
get to you sir I'm going to there was
somebody who just indicated they wanted
to speak I'll I'll you can come back in
a minute but I want to hear from this
other person first thank you sir thank
you yeah why you why don't you just come
up sir and you can fill out your card
just you can fill out the card after
just so we get yeah it's not even that
sheet anyway it's a pink card it's a
pink
card honorable members of committee uh
my name is Justin Davis I represent the
National Rifle Association I'm also a
gun owner in New Hampshire I appreciate
the opportunity to oppose this
legislation today um I know it's late in
the day you've had a marathon day of
hearings and understanding that I am an
obstacle between you and your warm
supper on a cold January day I will be
very brief um you know I think a lot of
it's been discussed today we've talked
about pla which is the uh proect
protection of legal Commerce and arms
act or lawful Commerce arms act rather
um which is not only for gun
manufacturers like we described as for
manufacturing the United States so
whether you're Ford whether you're Ruger
whether you're Sig uh you all fall under
that so just like we used example before
if uh fors an S1 F-150 and that's using
a crime they're not liable for that
legal sale and they cannot be held
responsible for anything that happens
after that sale same with gun
manufacturers right so this is not just
purely for gun manufacturers this is a
long-standing federal law um we've
talked about uh about the impact on the
economic impact in New Hampshire um this
is passed it would be not prudent for a
gun manufacturer gun retailer to operate
in the state of New Hampshire where they
could be sued out of business overnight
because of a legally sold firearm so if
Ruger sells uh their firearms to L Cody
who then makes a legal sale through the
Knicks background checks and then that
person turns around and commits a crime
or the way these bills are written
typically if that is a legal sale and
that firearm is stolen and then used in
a crime well then Ruger would still be
held responsible for that I think most
reasonable people on this uh in New
Hampshire would agree that that is
unreason
um so for all those reasons St above and
it seems like this committee has a very
good understanding of why this is a bad
idea for New Hampshire the NRA and our
members oppose this bill and I'm happy
to uh take any questions you may
have question representative Smith um I
just have a technical question are you
registered as a lobbyist in the state of
New Hampshire I am yes do you have an
orange badge uh my orange bag badge is
being made uh just as B A backlog and I
do not have it yet but I will have that
I apologize so I have my other state one
but I understand that that is necessary
thank you which just in the issue of
fairness I wanted to make sure yep 100%
I appreciate that other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much very much uh the witness who
testified before you may return I I want
you to like please keep it brief
okay good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee and thank you
for your Indulgence I will be
brief the fellow who shot those two
police officers and I have read the New
Hampshire Supreme Court opinion
carefully there was nothing in the
records that disqualified him yes he had
mental health issues but he had never
been
adjudicated that term has a very
specific meaning in the
law
and the department of
safety did its homework and they
determined he was not
prohibited secondly a statement was made
repeatedly that
the
statute at issue here prevented those
officers from bringing their case it did
not they brought their case it went all
the way to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court the court found that there was no
liability because the buyer was not
prohibited and the Dealer did nothing
wrong it's that simple again folks need
to do homework get their facts
straight one final point and then I go
and it is
this globally the downside to gun
control is
genocide it is impossible to murder
hundreds of thousands or Millions unless
and until the targeted group and their
sympathizers have been disarmed in my
written testimony I cite the example of
the Soviet Union if any of you want to
see the authentic text of Soviet gun
control initiated on 1 April 1918 I will
provide it to you with a
translation and the translation's
accurate all right thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee again if there
are any
questions uh my email address is at the
bottom of my
testimony please feel free to contact
me thank you thank
you all right anyone else who
wishes no I don't want to if you have a
if you
have
okay double-checking this as we speak
but I would just encourage the committee
to take a a closer look at that court
case
I believe if memory serves me right that
the um authorization to sell that
firearm to that individual had not gone
through yet there's actually a loophole
in state and federal law that after 3
days you can you can proceed with a sale
if there has not been if um there has
not been a holder Den I think I think
you're right but but I mean the bottom
line of that is that was a lawful sale
because but the point is about immunity
so the the gun store knew knew that
there were concerns they had been
flagged that there were concerns there
the public safety for everyone was at
risk should that sale proceed now if we
have a if we have immunity there is no
skin in the game there is no stake to to
require that those who are in this
industry take proactive steps to help
either ensure those policies are in
place or to
independently um through a voluntary
process uphold Public Safety processes
that will keep our community safe and
that is what this type of Bill is about
so I just want to be thoughtful let me
make sure that that you rais a very very
interesting point so what you're saying
is that despite the law the statutory
law saying that if you don't if unless
they unless they tell you you're
prohibited within three days it's lawful
for the man for the dealer to transfer
the gun what you're saying is if we if
we we pass this law saying that the
immunity is relieved then some clever
lawyer may come in and and try to
persuade a jury that despite what the
statute said the the the gun U dealer
acted quote unquote unreasonably by
selling the gun that's what you're would
you what you would like to see I think
the I think the question before you is
are you going to pass public policies
that ensure the safety of our community
or are you going to encourage volunteer
actions by the gun industry neither of
which it seems this committee is
prepared to do thank you representative
Wallace thank you thank you for taking
my question in the case you just brought
back to our attention were any charges
filed against the uh the Firearms dealer
in this particular case I believe I
believe they were one of the I believe
it was the excuse me Department of
Safety and the gun store but again I'm
just refreshing it real quick in
response to this I don't recall any
charges being filed against that gun
dealer because everything they did was
lawful
for Chester Chester arms that's correct
um well he was cleared and they were
open for
business yeah I will double check that
but I believe that at one point that
they were included in the lawsuit
proceeds thank you thank you very much
anything anyone else who wishes to be
heard you knowk thank you very much maam
but I really think we we I don't want to
turn this into a a debate but than thank
you um thank you all members of the
committee for hanging in there um uh and
I will see you uh we're starting at the
session starts at 10: but uh you have
your caucus we have our caucus at nine:
so see everyone tomorrow um uh you know
representative M can I speak to you just
for one second about some issue not this
bill but the one you're going to be
considering
tomorrow